Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt.
Heute wie in den letzten Tagen auch schon im Dienst der Kriegsberichterstattung aus der Ukraine einfach um ja
ein wenig zu verstehen, ein bisschen zu kontextualisieren und uns darüber Gedanken zu machen was da eigentlich tatsächlich passiert und was wir davon noch
erwarten können und was getan wird und all diese ganzen Fragen, die wir im Kopf haben. Ja, dazu begrüße ich natürlich Pavel. Hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Denn ja wir haben uns wieder viel Gedanken gemacht. Jetzt muss ich grad noch mal schauen. Wann haben wir eigentlich die letzte Sendung veröffentlicht das haben wir getan am.
Letzten,
am 14. März, das ist dann auch schon mal wieder sechs Tage her. Das war der letzte Montag, dass das rauskam, genau.
Ja und muss sagen, also inhaltlich ist die Sendung okay, aber ich fand's wirklich
schwierig. Ich war da nicht gerade der Fitteste und werde versuchen, also heute doch ein bisschen mehr auf den Sprachfluss äh zu achten und weniger
und ähm sonstige Geräusche von mir zu geben, die dann den Sprachfluss stören.
Keine Versprechungen, die du am Ende nicht halten kannst.
Wir schauen mal, was äh passiert.
Ja ansonsten ja ansonsten ich glaube es ist eine der der best vorbereitetsten Sendungen, zumindest von von meiner Seite aus jetzt hier aus der ähm Ukraine äh Reihe.
Das kann gut sein. Ich habe heute zumindest nicht ganz so viele Nachrichten wahrgenommen, aber ich denke, der Tenor ist ja ohnehin derzeit, dass ähm grade auch nicht so richtig voran und zurückgeht.
Aber da kommt man ja,
gleich auch ausführlich zu, aber es ist trotzdem so viel passiert und so viele auch einfach neue Erkenntnisse jetzt zu Tage getreten, immer in die halbe Welt denkt ja gerade
oder fast die ganze Welt denkt ja gerade darüber nach und hm das ist schon faszinierend dann auch zu sehen äh was da an
ja einen guten Ideen oder Überlegungen dann nach nach oben kommt, so in der in der westlichen Welt, sage ich mal oder überhaupt in der Welt.
Ja und davon äh haben wir jetzt einiges auch gesammelt und uns sortiert und ähm weiter gesponnen und äh ja mal gucken. Also ich glaube heute heißt es ein bisschen anschnallen, denke ich mal, eher,
so
So, du möchtest auf jeden Fall die Sendung heute jemandem widmen.
Ach so, ja, ja, also ähm ich ähm.
Jetzt Otto von Bismarck äh rausgekramt äh einfach, weil der mir auch so oft jetzt in der letzten Woche über den Weg gelaufen ist ja und eine unglaubliche Quelle.
Von Weisheiten äh ist und ähm ja äh und es.
Gibt einfach so viele Sprichworte oder oder Aussagen, die er gemacht hat, die einfach
wunderschön passen und ähm ja ich warne schon mal davor so die Sendung äh wird halt äh ja mehr als ein Bismarck, Zitat
enthalten und ähm aber vielleicht für diejenigen, gut, eigentlich sollte in der Schule jeder von Bismarck äh gehört
haben so, aber das ist vielleicht auch schon eine Weile her oder man hat nicht so richtig zugehört und deswegen wäre es vielleicht sinnvoll, noch mal kurz.
Bisschen zu erläutern. So, ich meine, Bismarck wurde ja auch der eiserne Kanzler genannt, so ähm
so eisern ist ja auch so ein so ein Wort, was dann ganz gerne verwendet wird äh bis bis heute, um irgendwas zu klassifizieren, eiserne Lady, eiserne Union, wie auch immer. Jedenfalls achtzehnhundertfünfzehn geboren bis achtzehnhundert.
Also hm ja jemand aus dem 19. Jahrhundert und er kann sagen, der hat faktisch Deutschland gegründet.
Ja der hat die deutsche Einigung nicht Wiedervereinigung, sondern die überhaupt erstmal die Einigung Deutschlands ähm herbeigeleitet.
Ja, also das Deutsche Reich ist eigentlich wesentlichen auf seinem Mist gewachsen. Also da war da die die Haupt äh Treibende
Quelle und was vielleicht auch noch interessant ist natürlich, was man dann nicht so direkt mitgesagt kriegt, wobei historisch ist das jetzt alles ganz ganz,
belegt, aber ähm so bis Mark war zwar später, wie gesagt, der eiserne Kanzler und Disziplin und so, aber eigentlich als junger Mann so ein ziemlicher Halogri, also war halt ständig
pleite wegen niemand sagen würde jetzt Nutten und Koks beziehungsweise,
äh äh wie es damals hieß Wein Weibern und Gesang, äh wie das dann natürlich auch
Eingang in die Nationalhymne gefunden hat oder modern würde man sagen jetzt Sex and Drugs and Rock 'n' Roll. Leider wird diese Strophe nicht so gerne äh gesungen, wobei obwohl mir das die liebste äh Strophe ist.
Was? Wie das welche Strophe meinst.
Ja Wein, mit das mit Weinweibern und Gesang. Äh so, ich glaube.
Ach, dass es im Deutschlandlied wirklich drin? Aha.
Deutscher Wein und äh und so weiter ähm.
Deutsche Frauen, deutsche Treue, deutscher Wein und deutscher sang sollen in der Welt behalten, ihren alten, schönen Klang.
Ich sage ja, Sex and Drugs and Rock and Roll.
So ja.
Kommt noch die Treue dazu. Das ist doch schon mal das heiß.
Genau.
Ja, ja. Ja, also jedenfalls äh war galt er auch irgendwie in konservativen Kreisen als zu extrem für ein Ministeramt und
ja wurde dann halt eben im also ist uns jetzt doch zu gefährlicher, landete dann irgendwann.
Als Gesandter außerdem in Sankt Petersburg, also ist deswegen relevant, weil ja auch eine ganze Menge über Russland und über den Krieg äh gesagt.
Äh ja war irgendwie auch als Gesandter in Paris und er hatte dann aber auch pflegte dann äh glaube ich auch eine,
offene Ehe, weil hatte dann irgendwie noch eine geduldete Liebesaffäre mit Fürstin Katharina. Ausgerechnet der Ehefrau des russischen Gesandten in Belgien, also sozusagen da gab's dann schon gewisse Bande.
Zu zu Russland, so. Ähm ja, 1862 konnten,
sie ihn dann aber nicht mehr davon abhalten, dass ihn dann äh ja der, ich glaube auch, der der Kaiser war's, glaube ich, dann wurde er jedenfalls zum Preußischen Ministerpräsidenten und Außenminister äh.
Ernannt und wurde dann auch gerne als Konfliktminister bezeichnet, ja und ähm
hat dann damals eben auch im Parlament wieder für viel ähm,
Sagen Kritik mit seiner Blut- und Eisen äh Rede äh gesorgt. Das klingt halt heute auch ganz martialisch und wird da eben auch immer
gerne zitiert, nämlich äh so das Statement von ihm war, nicht durch Reden und majoritätsbeschlüsse werden die großen Fragen der Zeit entschieden, sondern durch Eisen und Blut. Und ähm
Ja, das klang wahrscheinlich jetzt so die letzten 1hundert Jahre, die letzten 50 Jahre, sage ich mal
wenn man das wahrscheinlich zitiert hätte oder so dann gleich in eine Ecken gestellt worden. Jetzt fragt man sich natürlich hm äh steckt da nicht vermutlich doch
irgendwo leider eine gewisse Wahrheit drin. Ja und dann äh wie gesagt, das hatten wir ja schon äh Gründer des Deutschen Reichs und dann noch keine ganze Sendung über über Bismarck werden, aber es muss ein ziemlich
heftiger Typ,
auch gewesen äh sein so, weil Kaiser Wilhelm der Erste meinte dann es ist nicht leicht unter einem solchen Kanzler Kaiser zu sein, ja. Also.
Äh und er mochte irgendwie Sozialisten überhaupt nicht, hat dann irgendwie massive Repressionen dann auch gegen Sozialisten,
und dann im sogenannten Kulturkampf noch, aber hat uns eben auch die Krankenversicherung und die Unfallversicherung beschert, so um ja links das Wasser abzugraben und so und,
Am Ende wurde er dann äh vom jungen äh Kaiser Wilhelm den zwoten äh gefeuert, weil er ihm zu konservativ und nicht progressiv genug war. Aber ich meine Wilhelm der Zweite war jung und ich glaube, der wollte einfach nicht so einen alten Sack,
haben, da der eben äh dauernd erzählt, wie man es eigentlich machen soll und äh ja ihm da einfach ähm,
ja zu alt war.
Aber was meint er denn mit seiner Blut- und Eisenrede genau? Also das das er der Meinung ist, dass ähm also eine Feststellung oder es ist eine Meinung, dass den Krieg als politisches Mittel.
Ähm erfolgreicher ist oder sein sollte oder.
Nein, er hat er war er war eigentlich eher also äh dem Krieg gegenüber abgeneigt. Also da ähm sondern äh,
Er erhielt nur auch wiederum nicht,
allzu viel von Parlamentarismus, das war das das andere Ding, also findet halt auch haufenweise Zitate, wo ihm eigentlich dieses die das ganze Gequatsche und die Medien und das Gelüge und so äh wie er das gesehen hat äh so offen.
Aufn Geist geht und äh letztlich war das eigentlich nur so ein so ein realpolitischer Appell. Ähm.
Nach dem Motto also auch sein Ding war so je stärker wir sind, desto unwahrscheinlicher ist der Krieg.
So ein so ein Zitat äh von ihm. Also er meinte im Zweifelsfall kann man halt viel reden und viele viel Papier äh beschreiben, das ist geduldig, aber äh wenn's drauf ankommt so dann
erzählt halt dann doch leider äh noch mehr so schön heißt die die Logik der Macht, an die auch die Russen äh glauben, so
als an äh die Logik. Ja des Verstandes oder des des,
ist, wobei er das das lieber gehabt hätte so und er hat mir halt auch gesagt, äh dass er, ja
ich betrachte einen auch einen siegreichen Krieg an sich immer als sein Übel, dass die,
Staatskunst den Völkern zu ersparen, bemüht sein muss, so oder.
Eben seine Feststellung war dann auch, dass es jetzt nicht mehr in der freien Hand von Herrn äh liegt.
Kriege zu führen, weil sie da grade irgendwie Lust drauf haben oder sich profilieren wollen, sondern ähm er hat das dann
nationale Gründe
genannt, also auch ein Zitat. So, man darf nur noch aus nationalen Gründen, das heißt aus Gründen, welche in dem Maße rational sind, dass ihre zwingende Natur von der großen Mehrheit der Bevölkerung
anerkannt wird, Krieg führen. So. Also sein Punkt war ähm es muss schon einen wichtigen Grund geben und äh das.
Also die Mehrheit muss das eigentlich genauso sehen, dass das dem so ist. So, das das war eben auch auch so ein Ding.
Ja und und ansonsten hatte sich äh wie ich mir aufgefallen ist.
Bismarck auch zur Gesprächskultur im Internet, äh eine ganze Menge geäußert.
Das zu einem 19. Jahrhundert.
Genau.
Na ja, äh so ein Ding so äh war ja verfallen wir nicht in den Fehler bei jedem anders meinen entweder an seinem Verstand oder seinem guten Willen zu zweifeln. Also.
Diskussionskultur klar, entweder so die Leute sind meiner Meinung oder sie sind doof äh oder böse so. Dieses.
Irre.
Ja oder irre. Genau äh und dann fand ich äh eben auch noch so ein äh.
So ein Ding, wo ich das Gefühl hatte, dass das auch wir oder unsere Podcasts oder oder auch meine Tweets oder so, das das die.
Ein bisschen auch in einer
ähnlichen Überzeugung ähm stehen, also einmal Umgang mit Kritik äh so. Da hatte Bismarck eben auch gesagt, ich bin dankbar für schärfste Kritik, wenn sie nur sachlich bleibt.
Bei mir ist es geht's sogar noch weiter. Ich bin dankbar eigentlich für jede äh Kritik, weil das dann auch interessante Sozialstudien äh gibt und auch einfach meine Meinung
auch informiert so über den gesamten Stand der Gesellschaft und nicht nur den Teil aus meiner Blase
aber äh ja auch so ein weiteres schönes Zitat mhm von ihm
Wer seine Ansicht mit anderen Waffen, als denen des Geistes verteidigt, von dem muss ich voraussetzen, dass ihm die Waffen des Geistes ausgegangen sind.
Und.
Das finde ich natürlich gerade auch so im im Hinblick jetzt auf auf Putin. Ähm ja oder oder die ganze die ganze Situation ja hm
ganz offensichtlich,
waren seine Waffen des Geistes oder seine Kultur einfach zu schwach, um äh sich jetzt darauf zu verlassen, äh dass seine,
Ideen jetzt auch, die die Herzen äh der Ukrainer ähm so
ja auf seine Seite ziehen und seine Gedanken oder seine Philosophie sich sich verbreitet, so aber ganz offensichtlich ist dem ist dem ja nicht so, sondern er hat ja eher Angst davor.
Und,
noch äh ja dann dann so ein weiteres Ding äh was mich auch erinnert hat, was er gesagt hat so ich kann die Achtung aller Menschen entbehren nur meine eigene nicht.
Und da äh denke ich ja, ist äh glaube ich ist schon Selbstachtung einfach einen einen ganz, ganz wichtiges Motiv, dass man
manche Dinge einfach tun muss dann, weil man auch nicht daneben stehen kann oder nicht schweigen kann oder ähm.
Ja so viel zu Bismarck äh jetzt, aber er wird wie gesagt noch im Laufe der Sendung das eine oder andere Mal äh sein seine Stimme hier erklingen lassen oder seine Worte.
Werden hier erklingen.
Gut, das gibt uns die Gelegenheit äh auf die eigentlichen Konflikt zu kommen und ich denke ist erstmal ganz sinnvoll.
Militärische Situation nochmal
dazu stellen. Also äh letzte Aufnahme war am Sonntagabend, also am dreizehnten
ja wir haben jetzt äh eine Woche äh verstreichen lassen so und zwischendurch wusste ich auch nicht so richtig äh werden die Dinge vielleicht wieder mehr Beschleunigung aufnehmen, dass man da irgendwie.
Nochmal früher ran muss, weil weil die Dinge sich überschlagen, aber tatsächlich hat sich dieser ganze Konflikt eher festgefahren.
Und äh geht auch gerade jetzt äh S wie Speak so ein bisschen in so einen Pausemodus über. Alle alle äh haben sich irgendwie eingegraben und jetzt geht's eher um.
Strategiewechsel, Verstärkung und all das. Aber gucken wir doch mal, was überhaupt passiert ist.
Ja also ähm ja zum einen ähm so hat sich ja der Konvoi aufgelöst. Dazu höre ich noch ein bisschen. Dann äh,
versuchen die Ossen jetzt auch Pipelines zu legen und äh Tankstellen aufzubauen, also Feldtankstellen, wo sie dann ihre Panzer und LKW auch im Land
auftanken können. Da sind auch einige in Betrieb. Hm dann äh haben sie teilweise wohl insbesondere äh von der von der Krim aus wohl die eine oder andere Eisenbahn
Linie äh zumindest teilweise nutzbar gemacht. Das heißt, sie sind durchaus auch jetzt in der Lage hm etwas mehr
ja Versorgungsgüter heranzuführen hm von der von der Krim aus zu zumindest.
Das gelingt, wäre das für sie natürlich ein großer Fortschritt, weil.
Ähm diese ganze Versorgung der Fronten mit Trucks haben wir ja hier schon mehrfach diskutiert. Das hat einfach hinten und vorne nicht gut funktioniert. Ist natürlich alles sehr angreifbar. Jetzt muss man aber auch sagen, dass natürlich diese Bahnlinien jetzt auch,
ziemlich verletzlich sind. Also,
Das dürfte den Ukrainern schon gelingen. Es gab auch irgendwo eine Sprengung in einer Bahnlinie, aber ich glaube eher so weiter im Osten. Keine Ahnung, ob das jetzt die Verbindung zur Krim war, das wurde in dem Moment nicht klar.
Nochmal eine Eisenbahnbrücke gesprengt haben. Ähm ich denke.
Es müsste den Ukrainern eigentlich gelingen, diesen Nachschub per Zug in irgendeiner Form Einhalt gebieten zu können, aber was weiß ich schon.
Ja, aber es gab es gab auch Meldungen jetzt aus der aus Weißrussland, dass dort sich wohl das Zugpersonal irgendwie weigert,
die Züge weiterzuschicken oder durchzufahren.
Ja, aber da da gibt's definitiv Meldungen, auch aus der äh weißrussischen Opposition, also offensichtlich gibt's eine gibt's einige Leute äh aus dem aus der Zivilbevölkerung und in dem Fall halt diese Eisenbahnmitarbeiter.
Die in irgendeiner Form sabotieren.
Also.
Ja zumindest äh gab's die gab's die Meldungen äh so und irgendwas ist da dran, aber welches Ausmaß das hat wie wie stark das jetzt die äh Russen behindert, das ist schwer.
Nicht. Wissen auch nicht, wie irre äh äh ob das irreversible äh Sachen sind oder so, keine Ahnung. Na ja.
Aber es ist natürlich auf jeden Fall ein zusätzliches Problem mit dem sich dann äh das russische Militär herumschlagen muss. So.
Ja. Ansonsten habe ich von äh diversen kleineren Offensiven auch gehört und hm es gab äh gerade auch heute oder in den letzten Tagen,
sehr viele neue Bilder über.
Vor allem zerstörte äh russische Panzer und ähm Wagen so bisschen mehr von der ukrainischen Seite. Klar.
Die gibt natürlich äh so was so was gerne äh raus, aber am Anfang waren's immer wieder so mehr oder weniger dieselben Bilder, die man gesehen hat auch im.
Im Fernsehen, aber.
Es gibt jetzt auch eine ganze Menge Leute, die halt offiziell sammeln, Sights, die aus dem äh Boden äh schießen, wo jede einzelne Meldung dokumentiert und analysiert
wird und hm.
Das ist in dem Sinne gar nix Neues. Das gibt's natürlich schon schon länger dieses diese gesamte Bewegung der Open Source Intelligence.
Da sind viele Leute aktiv, die haben so ihre eigenen Discordserver, da gibt's auch ein äh schönes Interview auf Netzpolitik Org, Markus Reuter äh geführt hat, wie die so arbeiten
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall immer ganz hilfreich und vor allem
die halt in dann in der Lage all diese ganzen Twittermeldungen, Bilder die gepostet werden irgendwie zu zählen und halt mal diese ganzen Verluste zu quantifizieren.
Nur das erfasst natürlich nicht die vollständige Wahrheit, weil du weißt halt nicht immer, wann ist das passiert, weil das vielleicht doch nochmal eine Situation äh die schon mal gezählt wurde.
Ja dann siehst du irgendwas explodieren ist da wirklich was bei kaputt gegangen et cetera PP. Schwierig zu sagen grundsätzlich kann man aber zu den Fortschritten sagen.
Also, wir hatten es da auch letztes Mal geschildert. Wir haben ja die Situation im Norden, also der Angriff auf Kiew, wir haben eine Situation im Osten, also äh Dunetzk.
Luhansk, der Vorstoß und natürlich ausm Süden von der Krim,
Das hat ja äh zwei Ziele einerseits äh der Lückenschluss, die Verbindung eben zu der äh Ostfront, die es
hat ja stattgefunden und deswegen wurde die Stadt Mario Pohl so eingekesselt und deswegen ist das ja auch derzeit einfach der tragischste Ort. Dort.
Also dort ist es einfach grade richtig scheiße. Also die Stadt ist halt einfach komplett ohne Infrastruktur, ohne Versorgung, ohne Strom, ohne Heizung, ohne alles.
Wasser und die Leute darben da einfach äh hin, versuchen auch irgendwie Widerstand zu leisten und dann werden sie halt die ganze Zeit unter Beschuss genommen und werdet die Bilder ja und die Berichte auch gesehen haben. Ist halt einfach das ist halt einfach alles ganz furchtbar, was da passiert.
Anderen Seite im Westen der Vorstoß nach Odessa, den die Russen sicherlich gerne machen wollen, der ist ähm.
Der kommt nicht voran. Da gibt's ja so eine spezielle Situation.
Ähm auf der einen Seite ist das ja die einzige Stadt, die die Russen eigentlich bisher so richtig eingenommen haben. Ähm jetzt äh.
Nicht was man äh.
Nein und nein, nur deshalb haben sie nicht eingenommen, sondern ähm ich wollte gerade den Namen der Stadt sagen und dann äh kam mir da meine,
meine Schwäche äh mit mit ukrainischen Städtenamen äh hoch, deswegen muss ich noch mal kurz in mich gehen. Äh das ist äh Kerzon oder Cason,
Das ist so quasi die nächst größere Stadt nach der äh Krim.
Und das ist ja diese ähm um um von dort nach Odessa vorzustoßen. Da gibt's so verschiedene größere,
Flussmündung, die die Russen erstmal umschiffen müssen und da gibt's dann so zwei Städte, die äh die Russen angegriffen haben, Niko live.
Und noch ein bisschen weiter im Norden äh.
Und es macht zumindest so den Eindruck, als ob die ukrainische Armee hier in den letzten Tagen kräftig zurückgeschlagen hat,
Also dass wirklich die Russen auch mal wieder zurückweichen mussten, äh es Kämpfe gibt um diesen Flughafen in äh und das,
Das sind so diese kleinen Hoffnungsschimmer immer wieder äh in diesem Krieg, weil's einfach den Russen nicht gelingt, in irgendeiner Form nach Westen vorzustoßen, was dann eben.
Potenziell äh und übers Land für die Russen erreichbar machen könnte und das scheint.
Nicht stattzufinden derzeit. Da ist also der Widerstand der Ukraine stark, ne? Aber im im Osten ist es halt wirklich bitter
mit ähm Mario Pohl. Im Norden haben sich die Stellungen einfach fast überhaupt nicht bewegt,
Die Russen kommen einfach keinen Schritt äh vorwärts. Das ist also permanent so die versuchen irgendwie äh voranzuschreiten. Werden dann aber immer wieder äh in den Versorgungslinien äh angegriffen und werden auch einfach
direkt angegriffen halt an an der Front. Da gibt's ja diesen Fluss Irrpin, der,
Westen, Kiews, quasi von den Russen erstmal überschritten werden muss. Dahinter ist noch so ein größeres Waldgebiet. Das das ist sozusagen so der große Schritt, den sie dort einfach gehen müssten, um überhaupt an Kiew richtig ranzukommen.
Offensichtlich ist es den Ukrainern gelungen ähm Durchflutungen,
keine Ahnung, wo die ausgelöst wurden in in welcher Form. Aber dieser relativ kleine Flussirpin ist also mittlerweile eine eine komplette Wasserlandschaft zumindest in Teilen.
Dass das alles so ein riesiges äh Sumpfgebiet geworden ist. Da geht's also hin und her, ne.
Man streitet sich jetzt darum, sagen wir uns die Ukrainer, die das jetzt geflutet haben oder was die Russen äh die sagen versehentlich äh da Dämme äh zerschossen haben oder.
Geflutet haben. So ähm man man weiß es nicht genau, aber auf jeden Fall ähm scheint es nicht vorteilhaft zu sein für den Angreifer, dass die Gegend geflutet
ist und ja und auch auch ansonsten sagen wollte, ich.
Im Gegensatz zu den zu den Vorwochen gerade doch ganz viel auch bestätigtes Material gesehen jetzt von der ukrainischen
Armee
die da jetzt eine Menge rausgegeben haben, wo wenn man allein nur die Panzer äh zählt. So da kommt man dann gibt's dann ein Video, da kommst du auf auf zwanzig Panzer und hier acht und da zehn und also
Plus man sieht jetzt halt auch ein bisschen mehr so,
ukrainische Artillerie und so im im Einsatz, die dann die dann auch zurückschießt und ähm ja
Das ist definitiv, also haben die Russen definitiv äh wirklich schwere Verluste wahrscheinlich.
In der Größenordnung äh jetzt ja fast das, was sie im gesamten Afghanistan-Krieg,
an Verlusten erlitten haben so in der Größenordnung zumindest, je nachdem welcher Quelle äh man man glaubt
Aber sie werden jetzt nach äh ja einigen Wochen äh sagen, dort sein, äh wo sie nach Afghanistan in zehn Jahren
Das ist eine ganz andere Intensität und das ist jetzt auch ähm ja sagen der der intensivste Krieg, der seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg geführt
wird.
Ja, absolut. Also ein bisschen schwierig zu sagen, inwiefern
jetzt einfach nur auch nur Fortschritte sind, weil es natürlich auf der anderen Seite auch äh entsprechende Gegengewinne äh gibt, wo die Russen dann halt wiederum der Ukraine äh Material abnehmen, aber ich glaube unterm Strich kann man schon festhalten, es macht schwer den Eindruck,
die Verluste bei den Russen halt auf der einen Seite signifikant sind und aber auf jeden Fall sehr viel höher als ähm bei der Ukraine. Das,
auch einfach ein Ergebnis der.
Also einerseits natürlich der Situation. Du bist natürlich in gewisser Hinsicht als Verteidiger immer so ein bisschen im Vorteil in Anführungsstrichen. Andererseits machen's die Ukrainer halt auch sehr klug
indem sie eben mit
sehr viel kleinen, sehr beweglichen Truppen unterwegs sind ja, die äh schleichen da durch die Wälder, können sich super verstecken
haben sich da mittlerweile einfach auch tief eingegraben, haben natürlich auch einfach eine massive Ortskenntnis, sind gut koordiniert, sind hochmotiviert
können eben jetzt auch mit den ganzen Waffenlieferungen von diesen ganzen Men Pads, also diesen tragbaren panzerzerstörenden
Waffen einfach super arbeiten und damit können sie halt äh Hubschrauber versenken, Tanks, Lastwagen, alles mögliche.
Angreifen und tun das halt auch am laufenden Mieter und das schwächt natürlich. Auf der anderen Seite die Russen sind natürlich jetzt auch nicht blöd und lassen natürlich auch Verstärkungen kommen.
Nur in wie fern sie da mithalten können mit der Zerstörung
inwiefern sie überhaupt auch in der Lage sind, personell auch nochmal aufzustocken oder auch nur die Verluste auszugleichen
ist sehr schwierig zu beurteilen, aber man darf auch nicht unterschätzen, dass es einfach eine massive Kriegsmaschinerie ist, die da anrollt und da wird's nicht reichen, nur ein, zwei Wochen gegenzuhalten.
Na ja, auf der anderen Seite, man begab's ja von Anfang an, habe ich schon gesagt, die die Ukrainer haben eigentlich.
Einen fast unbegrenzten,
Boden oder oder unbegrenzte Quelle an Freiwilligen während es auf russischer Seite halt anders aussieht und je nachdem.
Welchen Zahlen man glauben darf, über die über die Größe der auch russischen Reserven so.
Kann es sein, dass tatsächlich die Russen so langsam,
in die Nähe dessen kommen, was sie überhaupt haben an Antruppen, weil äh offiziell
Gibt's halt da zwar auch russische Reserven und und und Truppenzahlen, aber das Problem dort ist auch, dass natürlich jeder nach oben mehr meldet.
Als wirklich einsatzbereit ist. Das war früher ja auch schon so zu Sowjetzeiten und bei der Bundeswehr war ist es jetzt auch nicht nicht anders, dass du zwar hundert Prozent.
Jetzt an, wie sagt man Panzernhass?
Aber davon sind nur 60 Prozent einsatzfähig und dann, wie man es auch gesehen hat, und davon nochmal äh äh bleibt die Hälfte nach ein paar Kilometern stehen, weil es schlecht gewartet
ist und äh das haben wir auch gesehen, dass dann die chinesischen Reifen.
Abfallen, weil da jemand dann wieder zu billig eingekauft hat und der kam natürlich auch nicht gewartet äh wurde und dann in der Sonne stand und dann dies das Gummi bröckelig geworden ist und wenn man dann.
Wie das im Gelände nötig ist, dann mal den Luftdruck
pumpt, um durch einen Schlamm zu fahren, wenn man gesehen. Da haben sich dann reihenweise dort auch die die Reifen einfach aufgelöst, ähm weil äh ja, weil billig eingekauft und schlecht gewartet.
So.
Ja und äh und dann äh geht jetzt das Essen äh ja auch noch äh aus. Das das wissen wir auch, dass dass sie viel geplündert äh haben oder versucht haben bei den Einheimischen dann Essen zu kaufen äh und jetzt
Jawohl bei China sogar angefragt haben MREs zu liefern. Also diese sogenannten meels ready to eat ähm typische Soldatennahrung. Und,
da fiel mir ein, es es gibt ähm halt ein YouTuber, hm der.
Ähm alle möglichen MREs testet und die ist teilweise auch,
1hundert Jahre altes Zeugs. Buchenkrieg oder 150 Jahre altes Zeug ausm Bullenkrieg und Zweiten Weltkrieg, keine Ahnung, wie der das alles zusammenkriegt so denn auf eBay und so und dann dann testet der das und macht das dann so bisschen wie einen Gourmet-Tester und so.
Und dann schrieb ich nur, okay. Also wenn ich wenn China jetzt auch noch das Essen liefert, dann ist die russische Armee endgültig geschlagen, weil hm so.
Weil er schrieb dann, ich äh kann man sich auch angucken, dass das das Video, da wird einem wirklich schlecht und ich meine der der Mensch ist was, was gewohnt
So also es wird da jetzt nicht nicht pingelig, aber er meinte, okay, die Hälfte, es ist wirklich nicht nicht essbar und hat dann äh und ist das,
das Schlimmste äh die schlimmste Militärration für großes Militär in der Welt, die er je gesehen hat,
schwer niedrige Qualität, Hälfte von dem unessbar. Er war dann äh drei Tage lang krank, äh nachdem er von dem einen Mal probiert hat, sieht halt wirklich eklig aus
und äh ja. Dann habe ich gesagt, okay, also er ist alles
außer jetzt irgendwelchen ja so das das ja Qualitätskontrolle
ähm für chinesische Militärrationen ist einfach unter unter aller Sau und äh ja.
Das ist so ein Paket Nudeln im Prinzip.
Sieht's erstmal gar nicht so schlecht aus.
Nee, aber wohl das Schweinefleisch, was da drin ist, ist wohl auch grün, hat wohl auch grüne Farbe angenommen und ähm ja und wie gesagt, er hat's dann probiert und hm ja.
Was ist denn das für ein King bitteschön irgendwie? Also Leute kommen echt auf Ideen.
Ich fand das aber total interessant. Ähm natürlich mit die besten MREs so, die Franzosen haben ziemlich gute natürlich, klar, wer sonst.
Ähm aber auch die japanischen äh sind wohl ziemlich gut und ja vom vom Bund, die die ich kannte die waren okay.
Was war das Beste, sagtest du?
Äh ich glaube Franzosen und und Japaner sind sind ziemlich ziemlich weit oben, was so MRAs äh angeht.
Okay. Die Israel ist bestimmt auch nicht schlecht.
Ja also kann man sich da alles alles angucken so samt ja seiner Geschmacksbewertung und ähm.
Bewertung, aber egal. Ja jedenfalls ja geht's geht's den Russen nicht nicht gut dort und.
Das Bild, was ich jetzt natürlich verdichtet, ist auch durch diese ja jetzt schweren russischen Verluste und jetzt zeigt, dass die russische Armee insgesamt auch eher schlecht kämpft. Hm.
Weiß man ihm, dass eine schlechte Armee halt gefährlicher ist als eine gute Armee in so einer Situation, weil eine gute Armee kann natürlich, wenn man tatsächlich zielgerichteter arbeiten kann, jetzt wirklich,
ja nur Militär bekämpfen und kann präziser äh
äh kämpfen, während eine schlechte Armee wie die russische jetzt einfach nur jetzt ihr Training
abspult und halt eine Granate nach der anderen aus der Entfernung irgendwo in die Richtung des Feindes äh schießt und
guckt, dass äh ja sie halt, wenn sie genug in Schutt und Asche legen äh so, dass dann der Feind irgendwann halt aufgibt, aber.
Mhm. So ich war ja nun bei den Fallschirmen,
und da gab's dann auch immer natürlich in jeder Militäreinheit äh gibt's dann so ein bisschen so die auch die definierenden hellen Taten und für deutsche Fallschirm Jäger äh war's dann unter anderem Margretha,
so aber dann auch Monte Casino, die Schlacht um Monte Casino und da haben die Amerikaner, beziehungsweise die Alliierten, haben ich glaube sieben
mal versucht, das da wegzubommen. Haben den halben Berg weggebombt und hm kam aber trotzdem nicht durch, mussten dann mussten dann außenrum
gehen, weil äh obwohl da nur eine Einheit von Fallschirmägeln noch nicht mal mit schweren Waffen äh war, aber wenn du dich da eingräbst so einfach,
Leute wegzubomben ist halt nicht nicht so einfach und woran man eben auch die Verzweiflung der Russen äh merkt, ist das jetzt angefangen haben sogar da ihre
Hyperschallwaffen auszupacken oder eine zumindest und dann äh mit den teuren Groß-Missheits äh da 50 Stück
äh abgeschossen haben da auf dieses dieses Militärlager und dass so was machst du natürlich
auch nicht unbedingt, wenn äh du jetzt Herr der der Lage äh bist, ja, dann gehst du da nicht nicht hin und packst jetzt deine deiner teuersten Waffen aus, von denen es auch nicht so viele gibt,
Ja
Grade mal zum Angriff da an der Grenze zu Polen.
Genau.
Wo sie das Lager, wo auch viele Freiwillige frisch angelandet sind, ähm äh angegriffen haben.
Genau, das haben sie mir halt mit 50 Gruß Miss Hals äh an angegriffen.
Von denen glaube ich auch viele noch von der Flugabwehr abgefangen wurden. Das war teuer.
Ja, ja Waffenlieferung, gutes Stichwort, also es gibt ja jetzt neue Waffenlieferungen oder was heißt neue Löffel, es gibt kontinuierliche Waffenlieferungen und es gab auch explizit die Aussage der USA, dass sie halt Waffen liefern werden.
Und ähm wir haben ja auch hier, glaube ich, schon öfter so die Position vertreten, dass vor allem diese Ablehnung gegen eine Nofleihsohn.
Gut sich auch, sagen wir mal so metapolitisch begründen lässt mit wir dürfen nicht in den Kampf mit den Russen kommen et cetera PP, ja? Das ist wahrscheinlich auch so ein militärisches Assessment der Situation ist, dass sie sagen.
Das bringt jetzt einfach mehr.
Sie kriegen irgendwie 8hundert Flugabwehrsysteme, irgendwie 9.000 Panzerabwehrsysteme, dazu noch Handwaffen, 20 Millionen Schussmunition und so, das sind allein die offiziellen Ankündigungen und das betrifft nur die USA.
Also da läuft grad eine ganze Menge, aber ich denke, ist auch ein gutes Stichwort, dass wir sagen jetzt vielleicht.
Ein bisschen tiefer in die militärische Situation in der Luft einsteigen oder? Und dann das Thema sie ja äh oder wollen wir wollen wir tatsächlich noch, weil das ist kurz.
Vielleicht erstmal Luft.
Ja. Okay. Was mir durch jetzt verschiedene auch Berichte
Podcast so von wirklichen Experten, die das studiert haben, ähm das Unterrichten an an Hochschulen oder 20 Jahre lang auf einem Flugzeug.
Träger hm praktisch damit zu tun hatten.
Also solche Leute hm ja schildern halt die die Situation und da habe ich jetzt,
wirklich verstanden zum ersten Mal, wo denn die ganzen Probleme jetzt liegen in der in der Luft eigentlich und was man da tun müsste.
Vielleicht mal gut zusammenzufassen. Das Problem ist erstmal Planung. Und die ganze, der ganze Einsatz konnte.
Nicht gut geplant werden wegen auch der der Geheimhaltung ja haben dann einige Truppenteile eben erst sehr sehr spät davon erfahren, aber.
Selbst die Planung hätte nur ein bisschen geholfen, weil was es eben auch braucht ist noch eine entsprechende Kommunikation und.
Die Freundfeind-Erkennung so so lange ich jetzt nicht.
Ja Lufthoheit habe, sondern der der Gegner noch in der Lage ist, sowohl mit Luft.
Abwehr wie auch mit eigenen Flugzeugen irgendwie was zu tun, muss ich natürlich zwischen Freunden und Feinden unterscheiden können und zwar auf beiden Seiten.
Was den Russen ja zum Beispiel auch grade gar nicht so leicht fällt, weil sie diese Kommunikation nicht äh ordentlich hinbekommen haben.
Können viele Lufteinsätze nicht geflogen werden, weil sie einfach Angst haben müssen, dass sie von ihrer eigenen Flugabwehr abgeschossen werden.
Exakt das ist das ist das Ding auf auf russischer Seite, ähm dass sie sagen auch.
In bestimmten Höhen nicht fliegen können wegen der,
gegnerischen Luftabwehrraketen, wenn sie dann aber tief genug äh fliegen, dann kommen sie dann auch teilweise in die Reichweite der eigenen auch schultergestützten Luftabwehrwaffen und äh.
Abwehrsysteme und normalerweise,
wie das funktioniert, hm so mit mit Lufteinsätzen ist hm.
Da gibt's eine einen eine Lagezentrale, die hat die hat einen
bilden einen Einsatz, einen Einsatzführungskommando, würde das jetzt bei der bei der Bundeswehr äh heißen oder äh so, die haben halt das das gesamte Lagebild jetzt.
Und wissen genau, wo welches eigene Flugzeug ist und wo welches andere ist und wo welche sein sollen und dieses Lagebild
geht nicht nur an alle eigenen Flugzeuge und eigenen Luftabwehrstellungen, sondern auch äh ja an die Bodentruppen bis hin zu den Leuten, die da mit Schulter gestützten äh Waffen,
die Gegend laufen und dann kann man halt auch das Ganze gezielt,
einsetzen, weil man dann ähm sagen, das ist das ist dann quasi Planung. Es gibt natürlich dann außerdem noch äh sogenannte IFF Identification Friend of How, also diese,
elektronische, freundfeind Erkennung, die halt im Prinzip ja teilweise wie Transponder auch auch arbeiten und.
Alle Waffensysteme kennen das eigentlich auch, zum Beispiel auch so eine Stinger oder so, äh die weigert sich dann auch äh
Flugzeuge oder eigene Flugzeuge abzuschießen, die dann äh so was ausstrahlen, aber dieses elektronische IFF ist sagen nur.
Allerletzte Sicherheit. So wie jetzt.
Bei. Es ist in der in der äh zivilen äh Luftfahrt halt dies äh äh Kollisions.
Erkennungs äh System gibt, Teasers.
Äh was dann wo dann im Cockpit der beiden Flugzeuge auf einmal dann Warnungen und sich das System dann elektronisch einigt, okay du du jetzt
sinken, du jetzt steigen und so und da gab's ja diesen berühmten auch äh Zwischenfall mit dem russischen Frachtflugzeug, was halt
auf die Fluglotsen gehört hat und die andere Schweizer äh Maschine oder über der Schweiz war's
die äh dann gefolgt hat und deswegen die wenn halt beide,
gehört hätten, dann wäre das auch nicht passiert. Ja, aber trotzdem nur, weil wir haben
verzichten wir nicht auf Fluglotsen und dasselbe gilt halt jetzt für diese militärische Freund-Feind-Erkennung oder Einsatzplanung und so wie die Russen das jetzt machen, wenn die.
Einsatz fliegen wollen irgendwo, dann müssten sie allen Truppen, die irgendwo unterwegs,
auf dem auf dem Flugpfad sich befinden und möglichen Luftabwehrstellungen. Ähm.
Ihr müsst dann sagen, okay, also zwischen 16 Uhr,
und 16Uhrdreißig schießt jetzt bitte auf nicht, was sich in der Luft befindet, weil das da könnten auch unsere dabei,
sein. Ja, das ist sozusagen dieses dieses Level, auf dem grade die russische Einsatzplanung basiert.
Das machen sie unverschlüsselt im analogen Funk.
Genau.
Was dann die Ukraine auch selber abhören kann.
Mhm. Das kommt dann äh kommt dann eben auch dazu. Und wenn du weitere Problem ist.
Wenn du jetzt außerdem auch noch äh Luftunterstützung geben willst für deine Boden.
Einsatz müssen nicht nur die Bodentruppen wissen, dass du da oben bist, sondern die Flugzeuge müssen auch wissen, äh was denn jetzt eigene und fremde Bodentruppen sind. Das heißt, hm
die Russen haben können eigentlich aus der Luft auch keinen, wie es so schön heißt, close air Support oder C A S so richtig
geben, weil sie dafür auch äh ja nicht die Kommunikation so richtig haben.
Teilweise oder oder oder überwiegend und es ihnen außerdem auch noch an Präzisionsmunitionen fehlt. Das ist das.
Nächste Ding, das hm die,
NATO-Truppen äh hat seit dem Jugoslawienkrieg halt keine dummen Bomben mehr,
geworfen haben im im Krieg, da waren wir im Jugoslawienkrieg, einmal äh noch gemacht. Das war dann nicht so gut auch und seitdem machen sie das gar nicht mehr während bei den Russen neun
Prozent nicht präzisionsmunition sind, sondern einfach pumpen, die dann irgendwo landen.
Auch die Flugzeuge, wenn sie denn überhaupt irgendwas treffen oder bombardieren äh wollen, halt ziemlich tief fliegen müssen.
Und damit natürlich dann auch wieder ein tolles Angriffsziel sind für die ganzen Men Pads.
Und zusätzlich außerdem noch in der Höhe in in niedriger Höhe im Tiefflug äh auch noch die Flugzeuge natürlich.
Ziemlich viel Sprit verbrauchen, das heißt die kommen jetzt
auch gar nicht so so richtig weit mit den Flugzeugen. Das trifft natürlich vor allem auch äh für die Ukraine zu, wo ich jetzt gehört habe, dass die so fünf bis zehn Einsätze pro Tag fliegt jetzt. Äh.
Luftwaffe im ganzen Land insgesamt, also was nicht wirklich viel ist, aber Sie, Sie tun's, so. Aber äh ja, ähm das ist so auf auf,
relativ niedrigen Level das Ganze. Und ja.
Hm und vor dem Hintergrund.
Ist jetzt auch so Frage äh nach NoFly Sohn, was was was wird denn das eigentlich jetzt jetzt bedeuten ähm vor dem Hintergrund so so wie das hier gerade gerade aussieht.
Würde man jetzt,
sagen am als erstes würde man dann für eine für eine No-Fly so und das was sich Seed nennt oder SEAD ähm ähm,
was äh für äh äh ja Search and Elimination of R Defences.
Genannt wird.
Kenne die Definition of Anime Air Defen.
Ah okay äh ähm okay dann noch nochmal ja also jeden jedenfalls ausschalten.
Der Luftabwehr und das würde bedeuten, dass man ja Flugplätze und
Depots und
Nachschubwege bis ungefähr 100 Kilometer nach Russland hinein, also auf russischer Seite, zerstören müsste, Flugabwehrsysteme bis zu dreihundert, 400 Kilometern hinter der Grenze.
Mhm. Also die haben so 350 Kilometer Reichweite und deswegen willst du die halt auch ausschalten und.
Und.
Außerdem natürlich auch dann Radiosender und sonstige Kommunikationsanlagen, Befehlsstände in Russland auch für die Drohnen und
das große Problem daran äh ist dann auch es es gibt.
Dann auch Langstrecken Flugabwehrraketen, die also jetzt RTOR, die von Flugzeugen.
Geschossen werden, die gerade auch zum Einsatz kommen, aber äh die werden halt vor allem von der TU fünfundneunzig,
aus verschossen, die Jule Use ist und auch zur strategischen Bomberflotte gehört. Das heißt, die müsste man jetzt
auch anfangen zu dezimieren, äh wo wahrscheinlich die Russen dann auch nicht so begeistert werden, dass jetzt Teil ihrer
nuklearen äh Abschreckungsstreitkräfte oder zumindest die Flugzeuge davon äh jetzt auch noch dezimiert
äh werden.
Außerdem müsst man auch noch die Bedrohung von unten so aus dem Schwarzen Meer, die die die ganzen Schiffe, die da sind, also wahrscheinlich müsste man dann auch noch die äh Schwarzmeerflotte versenken und weil ich nicht nur nach Russland, sondern auch die ganzen Militärbasen auf der Krim und wahrscheinlich dann auch die Seebrücke zur Krim äh nach Russland,
unterbrechen und ja das ist so ungefähr das Szenario, was man halt professionell tun müsste, um.
Eine No-Fly Zone äh einzurichten und zu halten.
Ja, das ist vor allem dann auch nicht mehr nur eine No Fly, so ein dass es dann einfach auch schon das aktive Verjagen der Russen von ukrainischem Gebiet.
Das ist full on. Also das ist dann sozusagen, da ist man dann einfach mit dabei. Das ist, ich glaube, es gibt oft so die Vorstellung No Fly so und das wäre so, ja, das wäre so ein Feature.
So einschalten kann. Ne, da fliegt man so ein bisschen mal rüber, dann ist da Ruhe. Ähm so einfach ist es halt nicht.
Also natürlich müsste man jetzt nicht diese ganzen Dinge sofort
von äh auf einmal äh tun, so aber man müsste bereit sein, all diese Dinge zu tun. Ja, also da könnte es dann hinkommen und ganz klar äh
Also sobald dann ja die NATO anfängt.
Amerikaner anfängt, Ziele tief in Russland zu bombardieren und zu zerstören und die Atombomberflotte äh außer Gefecht zu sitzen und ähm.
Die Kommunikationsfähigkeiten der russischen Armee äh dermaßen zu hm beeinträchtigen Plus, dass wenn diese Armee dort zerstört wird.
Auch der Großteil tatsächlich überhaupt der russischen Armee
Toast, das heißt der Weg nach also in russischer russischer Sicht wäre dann der Weg nach Moskau frei und die Armee zerstört und da bleibt den Russen praktisch nur eine nukleare Antwort,
also insofern
ist äh sagen wir mal, ist eigentlich fast ein direkter Weg in die nukleare Eskalation oder
man hat gewisse äh Opfer ähm dann selber auch zu beklagen äh und,
warum es jetzt nicht nur Feigheit ist, da kommen wir dann denke ich auch beim beim beim Politischen.
Nochmal dran. Ja, aber können wir können wir den den Ukrainern jetzt nicht wenigstens Flugzeuge liefern, denn damit die selber ihre da aufrechterhalten oder oder einrichten können?
Polnischen ja.
Das wird auch fleißig diskutiert und geht hin und her und äh,
Ja äh in der öffentlichen Darstellung macht es so den Eindruck, als ob es an dem Widerstand der Amerikaner äh scheitert, aber auch die Polen äh nicht bereit sind, das äh alleine zu machen. Die Frage ist, ob's wirklich was bringen würde.
Und da gibt es auch die Expertenmeinung zu, dass diese MICN zwanzig.
Sowieso nur etwas kurzfüßig ist, äh wie es genannt wird und nur 30 Minuten Ausdauer hat.
Und das wiederum umgerechnet, wenn du das sowieso nur im Tiefflug äh alles bestreiten kannst, läuft darauf hinaus, dass dein Einsatzradius von so einer MIC neunundzwanzig,
mal bei 25200 bis 250 Kilometern um den Flughafen, wo das Ding startet rumliegt so und wenn du also jetzt hier mal überlegst, dass die Ukraine tausend.
2hundert fast 1300 Kilometer breit ist, je nachdem wo misst und mit Krim 850 Kilometer hoch, dann.
Ist klar, dass du sagen mit diesen Mick neunundzwanzig, wenn du die im Westen stationierst, gar nicht an die Fronten äh bis bis dahin gar nicht rankommst so. Das heißt, du hast da eben auch,
äh einfach nur einen etwas eingeschränkteren Nutzen.
Was heißt denn? 250 Kilometer Einsatzradius, also das kann schon irgendwie 2fuffzig hin und wieder zurück. Das schafft sie schon, aber da da ist dann sozusagen Schluss, ne.
Mal grade äh geguckt, wie der sich das so darstellen würde, würde solche Flugzeuge zum Beispiel in äh Levi äh stationiert werden, dann würden sie es halt grad mal ja dann würden sie grad mal die halbe Strecke nach
Kiew äh erreichen. Würden sie jetzt ähm Bike da in der äh Angriffszone zum Einsatz kommen sollen
dann sehe ich jetzt so ausm Stand äh überhaupt gar keine größere äh Stadt in der Nähe.
Von der aus man so also wo man sozusagen die stationieren,
Könnte. Also sicherlich mag es irgendwo noch kleine Flughäfen äh geben, aber keine Ahnung, inwiefern dann die sonstige Logistik ausreicht, um solche Flugzeuge dort ähm.
Zu betreiben.
Die müssten zumindest irgendwo landen können und auftanken können oder normalerweise machen das per Luftbetankung, aber solange du keine
Lufthoheit hast, kannst du jetzt auch keine Tankflugzeuge über der Ukraine fliegen lassen, ja? Also das ist äh sagen, dass das das andere äh Ding,
Und äh ja dann sagen ist es wohl auch so, dass die Entnatizierung äh,
Dieser Flugzeuge natürlich auch nicht nicht so einfach ist plus dass die Ukrainer auch nochmal.
Andere Systeme haben, was die ganze Waffenbedienung und so angeht, also auch noch mal andere als die Russen.
Was was was eigenes gemacht und außerdem ist nach Experteneinschätzung, wenn man sie die Flugzeuge denn jetzt
an die Front
kommt so im Schnitt, dass sie wohl nur vier bis fünf Tage im Fronteinsatz überleben würden wegen Luftabwehr und Beschuss mit äh ja mit kleinen Waffen und mit was da sonst noch so alles ist.
Und äh ja deswegen
sagen westliche Experten und Politikmeinung, das ist eine heiße Kartoffel äh die halt nicht viel bringt und lieber Luftabwehrsysteme und und Drohnen,
liefern. So ja und da da haben wir ja jetzt auch ein passendes Bismarckzitat dazu, mh.
Ja das was vielleicht nicht hundertprozentig passt, aber fast. Nämlich sagte er, ich habe das Wort Europa immer im Munde derjenigen Politiker gefunden, die von anderen Mächten
verlangen, was sie im eigenen Namen nicht zu fordern wagen. So, das,
als wenn er das geahnt hätte, dass äh irgendwie die Flieger ja mit Polen, ja, wir geben die gerne aber bitte hier Amerikaner äh äh macht mal und ähm.
Ja aber gefragt okay.
Das klingt jetzt alles sehr überzeugend und erklärt jetzt, warum wir die jetzt tatsächlich nicht,
liefern so die Flugzeuge, aber äh habe mich dann gefragt, wie würde ich das denn sehen, wenn ich jetzt Ukrainer wäre, weil Ukrainer haben wir ja gesagt, her mit den Flugzeugen.
Und so wenn man sich dann einmal sagen versucht nur in ukrainische Sicht so von einem General.
Zu versetzen, nämlich erstmal denken, okay,
mehr Flugzeuge sind besser als weniger Flugzeuge, ja? Weil die eigenen nutzen sich ja auch ab äh die die ganze Zeit. Das werden ja auch weniger äh so durch ja eben,
die Kampfeinsätze, die gehen auch ganz schön aufs Material und dann, wenn ich angreifen möchte, dann ist es natürlich auch irgendwie erstmal geiler, wenn ich mehr Flugzeuge habe als weniger und,
was die ganzen Umbau bedenken angeht.
Westen sagen na ja gib mal her die Teile, den Umbau, machen wir einfach selber. Wir haben ja schließlich auch unsere eigenen Flugzeuge umgebaut und äh mehr rollenfähig gemacht und.
Es gibt da doch gar kein entweder oder so gibt uns die Flugzeuge und natürlich die Luft der Abwehrsystemen und Drohnen nehmen wir auch. So wo ist das Ding?
Ich könnte mir jetzt gut vorstellen, dass hm.
Ja die Dinger äh in Kisten verpackt werden und über die Grenze geschafft werden am Ende des Tages und dann,
sagen als als Teilespender.
Verwendung finden oder einfach so umgebaut werden und dass die dann vielleicht jetzt nach und nach irgendwo verschwinden.
Und dann dann in den Einzelteilen.
Dann wieder in der Ukraine auftauchen. Also würd mich nicht wundern wenn das wenn das passiert aber es ist auch nicht ganz ganz ohne so ein so ein so ein Kampfflugzeug. Die sind natürlich auch alle registriert und eigentlich,
also so die so einfach verschwinden und auftauchen zu lassen, ist dann auch auch nicht nicht ganz einfach.
Zumindest könnte dann jeder sagen, oh äh wir haben wir haben nichts nicht gar nicht gemerkt, dass dass die jetzt dass die jetzt weg sind.
Zumindest gibt's das jetzt klare, aufzählbare Gründe, warum man das unter Umständen für eine schlechte Idee halten kann. Die können ja dann auch in der Bewertung so weit gehen, dass sie sagen,
Klar, ihr würdet euch jetzt über äh zusätzliche Flugzeuge freuen und mehr sind besser als weniger. Ja und lasst uns doch mal machen.
Mag er auch sein, aber äh für uns ist das dann auch irgendwie eine Kostenabwägung, ne, weil,
Wir opfern dann diese Dinger quasi für sehr geringen Nutzen und wir sehen einfach sehr viel bessere Verwendung in der Gesamtbereitstellung der Mittel, die ja auch nicht.
Im eigentlichen Sinne unbegrenzt sind, ja, dann dann werfen wir dieses Geld lieber äh auf Sachen, von denen wir eben glauben, dass sie effizienter sind.
Plus ähm was natürlich auch ein ein gutes Argument ist und das das haben einige andere Länder aus äh
Polen äh äh gebracht, äh die auch äh
ja Flugzeuge, sowjetischer Bauart haben gesagt, nee, brauchen wir jetzt selber. Ihr könnt euch uns gerne auch noch moderne Kampfflugzeuge dazu liefern, aber wir haben die Piloten, die sind
einsatzbereit.
Sind NATO fixiert äh gerade und äh ja die setzen wir jetzt doch oder die die halten wir doch einfach für den Fall zurück, dass es mit,
Russland dann direkt nochmal heiß wird und dann fliegen wir die halt selber in den in den in den Kampf. Das ist eben auch.
Die die andere Ratio, glaube ich, gerade dahinter bei bei vielen Ländern. Bau äh warum die Polen jetzt gesagt haben
gut okay, super. Wir geben die Dinger ab und äh ihr liefert uns stattdessen jetzt F 16. Äh die eigentlich für Taiwan bestimmt waren äh und so äh ja.
Ich glaube, die Polen haben ihre ihre Luftflotte ohnehin schon in Richtung amerikanische Modelle äh angefangen umzustellen
Und dann wäre das sozusagen so eine kostenlose Beschleunigung dieses Prozesses an der Stelle,
Davon ausgehen, dass sie dann eben auch die Piloten dafür haben. Stimmt natürlich, ne. Ich meine, Piloten kannst du nicht mal eben heute an das Flugzeug und morgen in das Flugzeug setzen. Das ist äh nicht zu machen.
Also die fliegen zu können, braucht jetzt nicht so viel Training, aber du musst mit denen auch nochmal dann dann kämpfen,
können und das ist dann nochmal 'nen ganz anderes Ding dann auch nicht nur das Ding in der Luft zu halten, sondern eben dann auch ja ähm.
Ziele zu erreichen.
Ja deine deine Mission genau deine Mission zu erfüllen äh.
Luftabwehr äh aus dem Weg zu gehen, Raketen auszuweichen, ähm dann dein
äh an ins richtige Ziel zu bringen oder äh gegebenenfalls ja Luftkämpfe zu gewinnen, so dass das
ist dann nochmal ähm ja eine Nummer schwieriger. Das ist vielleicht dann ein bisschen auch so der Unterschied zwischen ja ich kann reiten und ja ich kann auch Polo spielen so.
Okay, dann äh
nochmal ein Blick auf die Situation mit den Drohnen. Die Drohnen spielen ja in diesem Krieg eine besondere Rolle. Wenig überraschend ist eine definitiv so eine dieser Technologien, die im militärischen Bereich ohnehin aufm aufsteigenden Ast sind.
Interessanterweise haben die Ukrainer äh mit den Bayracta.
Drohnen ziemliche Erfolge zu feiern. Das geht ja sogar so weit, dass sie da jetzt schon so Lobeslieder äh im Internet ähm verbreiten.
Schon fast ähm wirklich bemerkenswert. Dabei sind die Dinger total langsam im Vergleich zu anderen.
Es sind eigentlich ja sind die wie wie im Grunde genommen wie leichte Sportflugzeuge, wie so eine wie so eine so eine oder eigentlich sogar noch kleiner,
die bringen halt 650 Kilo Gesamtgewicht auf die Waage und äh haben 15 Kilo Zuladung. Das.
Glaube ich gerade so ja ultraleicht Flugzeug äh oder so ähm und deswegen.
Auch.
Jetzt keiner angenommen, dass die so wirksam äh sein würden, weil normalerweise sind die für eine ernsthafte Luft,
wer jetzt keine große Herausforderung ja weil du schon richtig sagst,
Dinger halt relativ langsam äh sind und auch nur ja 150 Kilometer Einsatzradius haben von der von der Funkstation
ausgesehen und du ja die die normalerweise würdest würdest du die also die sagen die die Verbindung.
Zwischen Bodenstation und und der Drohne außer Gefecht setzen mit mit
Funkstörungen, ähm ja die Kommunikation unterbrechen und dann
ist die Drohne auf ihrer, ich nenn's mal, eigene Intelligenz angewiesen. Die werden zwar auch immer ein bisschen intelligenter, aber ähm
Ja äh normalerweise sagt in dem Moment, wenn du die Funkverbindung verlierst
so intelligent sind die Dinger dann doch nicht von sich aus.
Und das Problem ist nur, dass die Russen eben äh das nicht machen konnten, weil wenn sie dann ihre
ihre eingesetzt hätten in ihrer eigenen Truppen auch nicht funken
können, weil die eben keine vernünftigen Funkgeräte haben, die jetzt trotz Jamming dann noch funktionieren würden, sondern wegen Korruption halt so eine umgelabelte Chinascheiße äh gekauft haben, ja.
Sieht zwar dann von außen wie moderne Funkgeräte aussehen, aber eigentlich halt äh ja, weiß ich nicht, äh halt jetzt im Grunde genommen fast zivile Technik
äh äh sind und äh unverschlüsselt ja und so
kommt halt eben eben eins zum anderen. Also deswegen äh.
Sollte man jetzt diese Baractas auch nicht überschätzen und die Russen haben sich da jetzt auch ein bisschen äh dran gewöhnt äh einmal oder oder hm
ja passen sich der der Strategie natürlich auch an aber äh,
so komplett scheinen sie noch nicht in der Lage äh zu sein, diese Drohnen,
Gefecht zu ziehen, sondern die scheinen immer noch äh eine ziemlich unangenehme Waffe zu sein, gerade in der Situation für die Russen.
Amerikaner haben jetzt auch eine sehr unangenehme äh Waffe ähm angekündigt, dass sie die jetzt liefern würden, der der Ukraine.
Sogenannten Switch Blade Drohnen und das sind halt im Prinzip so totale Kamikaze Waffen, also.
Fernsteuerbare, Flugzeuge mit Kameras, die aber auch selber einen Sprengkopf haben und sozusagen direkt ins Ziel gelenkt werden können. Und die können, glaube ich.
Können die so in der Luft bleiben, halbe Stunde, 15 Minuten.
Ja, also die es gibt da jetzt zwei Modelle so, man weiß nicht genau, welche jetzt geliefert werden. Es gibt einmal die ältere Switch Plate dreihundert.
So ähm die.
Ist eher ja wird eben von den Amerikanern als Flying Shotgun äh bezeichnet. Also im Grunde genommen ja einen einen fliegendes Schrottgewehr. Die ist wirklich für,
nicht nicht für Einsatz gegen Panzer gedacht, sondern tatsächlich.
Wie das so schön heißt.
Gegen eher weiche Ziele oder auch gegen Tanklaster oder oder normale äh
ähm Autos im im Prinzip eine fliegende Handgranate. Ne, so kann man sich das ungefähr vorstellen ähm,
Ja und die Dinger kosten halt auch nur 6000 Dollar des Stück und.
Fliegen halt ja wie so ein Modellflugzeug, können halt hundert,
Kilometer pro Stunde im im Crew äh fliegen und hundert160 Kilometer pro Stunde dann im Endanflug. So ist jetzt nicht superschnell, verglichen mit anderen äh Raketen, aber na ja.
Musst du auch erstmal treffen.
Ja ja musst du erstmal treffen und die Dinger können auch nur ja am 15 Minuten ungefähr fliegen äh
und aber immerhin kann man dann Ziele bis zehn Kilometer Entfernung
angreifen, aber die Dinger sind auch super leicht, zweieinhalb Kilo das Ganze, das heißt das ist eigentlich
eher so ein so ein Ding zum Umhängen, ja wie so ein wie so ein Köcher, wie so ein wie so ein Köcher mit mit Pfeilen nur, dass da halt einer drin ist, den du dann ähm
aber steuern kannst und dann gibt's auch so verschiedene Standardkonsolen mittlerweile die zwischen verschiedenen Waffensystemen dann auch geschert werden und.
Mit äh ja so einer Standardkonsole lässt sich da lässt sich diese Switch Plate dreihundert dann.
Auch äh ja ins ins Ziel lenken und ist dann eher so für Attentate äh äh sage ich mal kannst du dann auch durch ein offenes Fenster irgendwo dann in den Raum schicken, aber
sagt die, bei 2,5 Kilo, mhm ist äh von dem Gesamtsystem ist der Schaden, den das jetzt jetzt anrichten kann eher begrenzt.
Aber die Switch Plate 600 wiederum,
Ähm ja, die ist noch mal eine eine ganz, ganz andere Nummer. Die wiegt halt statt zweieinhalb Kilo, wiegt das Ding in 5undfünfzig Kilo.
Und hm ist aber, dass dasselbe Prinzip auch einen Modellflugzeug.
Hast du gesagt, wie schwer das Ding ist? Nee, die ist nicht 5undfünfzig Kilo, die wiegt dreiundzwanzig, die wiegt 50 Pfund, also amerikanische Pfund, 23 Kilo wiegt das Ding.
Okay, dreiundzwanzig Kilo, ist aber okay, ist aber trotzdem dann zehnmal äh rot gut zehnmal so schwer wie das dreihunderter Modell. Und über den Preis,
konnte ich jetzt nix rausfinden außer, dass es billiger sein soll als eine von den die kosten.
Nach 2019er Preis, 174.000 Dollar das.
So, da habe ich mir natürlich auch gefragt ähm,
so für 174.000 Dollar äh kriegt man natürlich auch einen wahrscheinlich guten russischen, gebrauchten Kampfpanzer so. Ja also billig, billig ist das nicht, diese diese Javelins, aber.
Ja gut, aber ich meine auf dem Feld dann äh irgendwie zu sagen so hey was willst du für deinen Panzer? Ich kann dir 174.000 Dollar zahlen.
Ob das so zielführend wäre.
Ach ich ich glaube, wenn das möglich wäre, solche Transaktionen jetzt glaubhaft äh so glaube, äh die würden sich dann äh ja.
Müssen wir nachher eh noch mal drüber reden, welche anderen Methoden es noch gäbe, äh die Russen unter Umständen vom Kämpfen abzuhalten.
Ja ja, aber nur um.
Bei der genau um die sechshundert, weil wir sie jetzt äh haben nochmal um die nochmal fertig zu machen. Da kann aber lustigerweise so ein Sprengkopf angebaut werden. Das heißt, die sind dann,
im Prinzip
haben die dann dieselbe zerstörerische Wirkung oder zerstörungswirkung wie jetzt so eine ähm haben auch eben gewisse Teilegleichheit
sind ein bisschen schneller, aber nicht viel, hundertdreizehn KMH Crews hundertfünfundachtzig,
Kilometer pro Stunde Maximalgeschwindigkeit, können aber 40 Minuten in der Luft bleiben. Und die Idee
Typischerweise, dass man halt ähm.
Sich das so aufteilt dass man die ersten zwanzig Minuten ans Ziel fliegt, das schafft die dann 40 Kilometer zurückzulegen in zwanzig Minuten wohl äh ungefähr und dann
man so 20 Minuten lang noch über dem Ziel kreist und guckt und erkundet, wo man
denn dann jetzt wirklich äh rein will und dann äh ja äh halt die bekämpft oder
Wenn man jetzt eine größere Reichweite haben will, kann man eben bis zu 80 Kilometern in 40 Minuten zurücklegen mit den Dingen
Und dann wird's wohl mit der Funkverbindung schon ein bisschen knapp, aber dafür gibt's da noch einen Data-Link-Verstärker, mit dem man über 90 Kilometer weit kommt. Und das ist natürlich dann schon nochmal auch krass, weil du kannst dann mal mit einer.
Eigener Schulter gestützten äh Waffe oder mit einer leichten Infanteriewaffe kannst du dann halt schon in bis zu 80 Kilometer Entfernung Panzer zerstören. Das ist natürlich schon so ein bisschen fies.
Wenn man sich jetzt anschaut, wie die Situation um Kiew ist
Ähm das Problem ist ja äh die Stadt wird belagert. Sie ist ja Gott sei Dank noch nicht umschlossen, aber die Truppen stehen halt äh im Norden und halt auch im Nordwesten.
Ungefährer Abstand.
Derzeit würde ich sagen zwischen fünfundzwanzig, 30 Kilometer so in der Größenordnung und dort haben ja dann die Russen vor allem auch ihre Raketenwerfer äh stationiert. Also da ab da noch bisschen weiter.
Und die sind natürlich gerade äh die größte Bedrohung.
Weil sie ja damit quasi die Stadt selber und die ganzen Wohngebiete vor allem beschießen können und das ja auch tun
Würde man also jetzt mit diesen Switch Plate 6hunderts die Sache äh angehen und von der Front aus.
Abschießen, dann hätte man eigentlich die Möglichkeit
die komplette ähm Raketenangriffsgerätschaft äh ins Ziel zu nehmen damit.
Das ist natürlich gerade dieses, ich meine, das ist ja eine sogenannte Leutering äh Weppen, ne? Da muss man vielleicht mal kurz da was dazu sagen, so bestimmte Kategorie von Waffen, die eben dazu gedacht ist oder speziell von Drohnen, die ihm dazu gedacht ist, wie du da sagtest, so sie kreist dann quasi, die ist
dafür gebaut, einfach irgendwo so in der Luft erstmal abzuhängen. Man startet die und die hat nicht sofort ein Ziel, also sie hat
irgendeine Richtung und fliegt erstmal irgendwo hin. Aber dann,
ist sie vor allem erstmal dazu gedacht zu gucken so okay was ist denn jetzt hier? Und dann so ah da ist ja ein schönes Panzerchen
Da fliege ich jetzt mal rein und das wählt man dann eben mit dem Bedienerterminal aus und sagt so, ja gucke mal hier, der, den nehmen wir doch und diese äh Springkopffunktion bedeutet ja im Prinzip,
dass man dann ähm
das Ding anfliegen kann und speziell diese haben ja die Eigenschaft dass sie das Ziel nicht so auf direktem Wege anfliegen sondern so dreidimensional dann auch verorten dass sie das zwar
anfliegen, aber,
so einen Flugweg nehmen, dass sie das Ziel von oben treffen und das ist halt speziell für Panzer gedacht, weil die eben beim Angriff von oben am
verwundbarsten sind. Man sieht es viele viele Bilder von äh entsprechend angegriffen und zerstörten Panzern, wo dieses ganze Topteil, was sich dreht.
Weiß gar nicht, wie man's nennt, korrekt. Äh der Turm, okay, äh einfach abgesprengt ist,
Ne, er ist einfach einfach weg und äh die Wahrscheinlichkeit äh bei so einem
Aufprall auch das innewohnende Munitionslager zu treffen und dann eben auch noch mal für so eine sekundäre Explosion zu sorgen, ist auch nicht gering. Also auch das wurde schon öfter gesehen, auch so Videos.
Also mit anderen Worten, das, was die Amerikaner jetzt hier im Angebot haben, was auch immer dann die Menge wäre, die sie da bereitstellen
das ist schon was mit dem die Ukraine sehr viel Schaden erzeugen könnte.
Also die Switch Bake 300 ist würde ich sagen aber mehr so für Häuserkampf gedacht oder für.
Wie gesagt, äh ist eher so antipersonal und die Switch Plate 600 wäre, glaube ich, dann auch noch.
Eher was, mit dem sie dann die schweren russischen Waffen äh bekämpfen könnten, aber beide sind natürlich sind natürlich.
Kombination gut.
Und und ganz schön demoralisierend äh natürlich, also das ist dann dann halt schon, ja, was was wir jetzt sehen
Schon teilweise dieser Krieg, den wir aus Science Fiction früher kannten so mit allen möglichen Smartwappens, die sich dann erstmal ans Ziel anschleichen und das Ziel erkunden und dann plötzlich.
Kommen gegen ja.
Ich sage mal zwanzigstes Jahrhundert oder wie sagen neunzehnhundertachtziger oder teilweise auch noch noch davor ja brutale Feuerkraft äh der der Russen einfach nur,
irgendwie ein Ziel anvisieren und dann gib ihm gib ihm gib ihm und äh ja da treffen jetzt
auch gerade zwei
völlig, glaube ich, verschiedene Welten äh zusammen, wobei es nicht so ist, dass die Russen jetzt nicht auch vergleichbare Waffen hätten, aber ich kann mir tatsächlich nicht vorstellen, dass sie das dann so in der
in der Anzahl äh äh wirklich wirklich haben und äh vielleicht Spezialtruppen.
Vor allem haben sie ja nicht die gleichen Ziele. Ja, also während während die Russen dort eben einfach eingegraben sind, jetzt in ihre Stellung, in ihre Raketenwerfer ja auch nicht die ganze Zeit von links nach rechts äh verschieben, nachdem sie irgendwie was
abgeschoben haben, wobei das weiß ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht, vielleicht tun sie das schon, aber in gewisser Hinsicht sind sie ja auch nicht so mobil. Ja, also sie sind zwar
portabel, aber sie sind jetzt nicht hochbeweglich und ähm dementsprechend sind sie ein einfacheres Ziel, als es jetzt bei Ukraine ist, die halt im Wesentlichen,
sehr bewegliche Truppen, kleine Truppen, die durch die Wälder schleichen sind so, ne? Da hätten sie einfach gar nicht dasselbe Äquivalent von Ziel.
Ja, also ich glaube, soweit hätten wir jetzt die Situation äh in der Luft äh glaube ich.
Jetzt hinreichend äh beleuchtet äh denke ich mal und.
Ja und ich rechne deswegen damit, dass das auch hm.
Ja, so bleibt in der in der in der Luft, dass der der Luftraum weiter umstritten bleibt und dass keine Seiten wirklich die.
Lufthoheit erlangen wird äh und die Russen haben eben zwar jetzt zwar schon Luft Überlegenheit angeblich, aber selbst das wird von Experten äh bezweifelt, sondern es ist halt eher im im Moment,
können sich Flugzeuge beider Seiten über der Ukraine nicht so richtig aufhalten äh ohne Gefahr ausgesetzt zu werden von der gegnerischen Luftabwehr.
Äh ähm abgeschossen zu werden.
Das bringt uns zur Situation auf dem Wasser. Wasser gibt's zwei, also es gibt das Asowschem Meer.
Glaube ich nicht so eine große Rolle derzeit, sondern eher das Schwarze Meer, wo halt die Russen ihre Schwarzmeerflotte versammelt haben, uns vor allem natürlich, weil das ist eben der einzige Teil, den sie jetzt in dem Sinne noch nicht
äh unter Kontrolle haben äh kriegen können, ist halt äh die die westliche,
Das westliche Ufer des Schwarzen Meers, der Ukraine, also da, wo auch Odessa liegt. In der Mitte.
Und da es ja so, dass.
Am Anfang ähm erstmal ja die Ukraine eigentlich sogar ihre ihre Kampfschiffe selbst versenkt hat, damit sie nicht in die Hand der Russen fallen, also wenn man sich.
Dann äh anschaut so jetzt wer welche Verluste jetzt,
hat äh an an Schiffen dann stellt man fest, ja die die Ukraine eine ganze Menge, also die die Russen jetzt mit äh äh wirklich mit mit Sicherheit.
In dem in dem aktuellen äh Konflikt eigentlich wohl nur ein Schiff bestätigt. Ukrainer sagen in Wirklichkeit drei.
Und auch wohl Russian Warship scheint wohl doch nicht äh äh erwischt worden zu sein. Äh so hörte man. Das das.
Äh sei wohl trotzdem noch noch unterwegs, aber äh ja ähm wird man am am Ende,
sehen. Ähm am meisten allerdings äh sind zivile Schiffe in Mitleidenschaft gezogen worden und zwar von allen möglichen Nationen und wie zwei2 russische und.
Ein türkisches und dann ja ein ukrainisches ja also.
Ah okay, wurde wohl auch äh okay, die wurde jetzt mitgezählt, sieacht, die der ukrainische Mechaniker auf Mallorca äh halb versenkt äh hat. Die zählt wohl auch.
Als ähm ja ähm ziviles äh äh Schiff, was da beschädigt wurde und.
Ja und das große Problem ist aber wohl äh jetzt, dass äh alt ganz ganz viele Schiffe äh gerade jetzt dort auch gestrandet sind grade im Schwarzen Meer und äh im,
mehr und ja jetzt wohl angeblich irgendwo zweitausend Seeleute auf über 100 verschiedenen Schiffen da grade.
Fest
hängen und äh ja auch einen Evakuierungskorridor fordern, weil normalerweise sind die auch da, um das ganze Getreide abzuholen und andere Agrarprodukte und überhaupt ähm.
Und da droht jetzt natürlich auch noch mal.
Gerade einen einen echtes Problem, dass dort der Handelsschiffverkehr auch im Schwarzen Meer jetzt so in Mitleidenschaft gezogen wird.
Also es ist wohl mindestens ein Getreide Schiff auch wirklich angegriffen worden.
Und äh ich weiß nicht, ob's gesunken ist oder nur äh beschädigt wurde. Aber das ist natürlich jetzt auch so generell, muss man vielleicht auch noch mal separat drüber sprechen.
Dass andere Dinge also abgesehen davon, dass die Russen halt mit ihrem.
Totalen Zerstörungskrieg in so Städten wie Mayo Pool, einfach den totalen Horror äh.
Aufrufen und sagen, ja das habt ihr nun davon, dass ihr uns gegen uns stellt, weil wir kennen einfach keine moralischen moralischen Grenzen.
Ballern einfach alles tot und hauen einfach alles äh äh kurz und klein bis bis ihr klein beigebt so. Seht doch, wo ihr bleibt.
So ein bisschen so dieses Bullitum, ne, was da
gezeigt wird gegenüber der Ukraine und gegenüber der Welt ist es halt jetzt auch die Sache mit dem Getreide, weil eben so Länder wie Ägypten et cetera einfach das Problem haben, die beziehen halt einfach einen Großteil ihres
Brots quasi aus äh der Ukraine und jetzt wird auch noch diese Schifffahrt.
Irgendwie überhaupt da im Wesentlichen nur weg will, auch noch mit angegriffen.
Genau der und in in Deutschland ist das Öl ausverkauft überall.
Sonnenblumenöl.
Ja, äh alle alle Sorten von jetzt
normalen Pflanzenöl, also zumindest hier in der Umgebung äh habe ich jetzt von niemandem gehört, äh also ich war jetzt auch einkaufen und konnte das mit eigenen Augen bestätigen. Ähm.
Kein Öl und äh ja in in.
Allen Supermärkten, wo ich war und das Personal meinte dann auch, es kommt jetzt auch erstmal keins nach. Keine Ahnung, wer da jetzt wieder bunkert, war so schnell, kann das jetzt auch nicht nicht gehen.
Doch das geht sehr schnell. Das hatten wir ja schon bei Corona mit dem Klopapier. Da gab's ja eigentlich auch nie eine Versorgungsknappheit.
Es gab halt einfach nur einen ähm schlecht ausgelasteten, schlecht optimierten Lieferweg.
Weil erstens Großteil des Klopapiers war halt einfach für Delivery ins Gewerbe in die Büros gedacht. So und dann haben die Leute halt einfach sich zu Hause aufm Pott äh gesetzt.
Und äh ja Homeshitting is Killing äh The Lieferkette.
Also dadurch, dass die Leute halt einfach so einen erhöhten Privatbedarf haben und dann auch noch in so eine Panik geraten sind und,
ist halt einfach äh klar, also ja Klopapier kommt bei uns immer nur Montags und bis das dann halt einfach mal umdisponiert wurde und so, da hat's einfach gedauert und jetzt werden die Leute einfach
zwei äh Flaschen Olivenöl eingepackt haben und noch mal drei Flaschen Sonnenblumenöl, weil man weiß ja nicht, was kommt
dann ist der Supermarkt halt leer, weil der eben normalerweise eben genau so viele Produkte vorhält, ne, so just in time
mäßig äh wie eben normalerweise gemacht werden, sonst muss es ja irgendwo zwischenlagern, dann brauchst du wieder Lagerfläche für welche Produkte machst du das, kannst du ja vorher nicht wissen,
zwei Supermärkte dahinstellen, der eine nur zum Verkaufen, der andere nur zum Zwischenlagern und deswegen bricht so was dann eben auch schnell zusammen, wenn du so eine Unruhe drin hast und das ist natürlich das, was jetzt hier durch diese Situation im Schwarzen Meer erzeugt wird.
Ja und äh sollte man aber auch im Hinterkopf behalten, wenn man jetzt die Nachrichten aus Russland hört so von den leer gekauften Supermärkten.
Das muss jetzt auch nicht auf reale Mängel hin äh deuten, Versorgungsmängel hindeuten, sondern kann auch.
Eben daran liegen, dass auch in äh Russland jetzt das Hamstern eingesetzt hat, beziehungsweise bei bei Zucker und so kommt man das ja beobachten und bei anderen Dingen wiederum, wobei.
Hm einige Bilder aber aus Supermärkten da war dann nicht nur der Zucker leer gekauft, sondern das sah nochmal hm doch eine Rolle äh bedrohlicher.
Es ist beides, aber es ist zum Beispiel beim Zucker ist es halt so, der Zucker ist teurer geworden.
Das ist ja bei uns gab's ja in dem Sinne keine Preiserhöhung. Das Sonnenblumenöl war ja jetzt nicht dreimal so teuer und die Leute haben's deshalb gekauft. Beim Zucker, der auch in der russischen Küche auch noch mal eine nochmal mehr Bedeutung hat als bei uns.
Der wurde halt um zwölf Prozent teurer und das hat dann eben dazu geführt, dass die Leute so solche Hamsterkäufe gestartet haben.
Plus natürlich, weil dort die Inflation äh so in die Höhe gegangen ist, dann äh findet natürlich auch ein Run auf alles Mögliche statt, von dem du weißt, dass es nicht verderblich ist, was weiß ich, Salz.
Nudeln und und äh Mehl und,
andere äh Grundnahrungsmittel, von denen man sich auch für wenig Geld jetzt eine ganze Menge hinlegen kann. Also man wird sich sicherlich jetzt, wenn man nicht gerade Ulli Garch ist, wenn man sich jetzt nicht Rinderfilets oder so äh ähm.
In Tonnen hinlegen. Ja.
So sind wir glaube ich durch mit der militärischen äh äh Situation.
Wenn wir zu den Schiffen keine weiteren Anmerkungen haben, also man kann man müsse schon noch sagen, also.
Ist natürlich als Hafenstadt eben auch gefährdet vom Meer aus angegriffen zu werden. Das hat bisher so noch nicht stattgefunden.
Ähm der.
Angriff über Land, der ist halt zunächst einmal zurückgeschlagen worden, da ist es den Russen einfach noch nicht gelungen die ukrainischen Barrieren und dann vor allem eben diese,
relativ großen Flussmündungen zu überqueren,
und deswegen gräbt sich Odessa derzeit einfach ein. Also die Bilder aus Odessa sind wirklich unfassbar. Ja, die haben im Prinzip die ganze Stadt und die ganzen Vorstädte natürlich auch.
So eine mehrschichtige Abwehrstellung umgewandelt. Die sind einfach die ganze Zeit dabei überall
einfach Abwehr, Abwehr, Abwehr zu bauen. Sie äh schleppen tonnenweise Sandsäcke an und und äh äh begraben ihre Statuen unter solchen riesigen Sandsack.
Türmen.
Mal gesehen hast, also es gibt da so diverse Monumente, die sie einfach dadurch äh schützen wollen, dass sie da nicht zerstört werden in irgendeinem Vor-Ort-Krieg, in dem sie das halt so machen und graben sich natürlich äh einfach generell,
ein. Auf der Seeseite ist es so, dass sie halt sowohl,
ähm den Strand als auch eben vor allem auch den äh Meeresbereich mit Seemin vermiet haben und damit eben die Russen irgendwie fernhalten wollen. Gab's irgendwie so eine lustige Anekdote, wo auch irgendjemand.
Hotel in gefragt hat, ob denn der Strand offen wäre. Man soll der Strand wäre schon offen, aber sie würde jetzt nicht so empfehlen, da hinzugehen, weil es halt alles vermient und.
Kann man nur hoffen, dass dass diese Stadt nicht auch noch vom Krieg betroffen sein wird. Aber es sieht derzeit so aus, als ob da.
Zumindest äh die russische Armee so weit weggehalten werden kann, dass Odessa erstmal noch mit einem blauen Auge davonkommt.
Ja.
Da müssen wir uns mal so ein bisschen um die politische Lage kümmern. Ja also.
Was sagt denn Bismark irgendwie zu der politischen Lage? So ähm und äh ja würde Bismarck wohl sagen irgendwie,
man kann Vorsicht, Feucht, man kann Mut leichtfertigkeit nennen so irgendwo da spielt sich das äh zwischen.
Ab irgendwie zwischen Vorsicht und Furcht und Mut und Leichtfertigkeit, ja.
Das ist so ganz ganz gute Beschreibung des Seelenzustands ähm.
Ich kenne das ja auch, wenn wenn ich jetzt so ins persönliche Gespräch gehe mit Leuten.
Und du hast ja im Prinzip beide, ne. Du hast auf der einen Seite so die Leute, die sagen, ja äh hier so und das muss jetzt hier alles passieren und äh überhaupt und ähm ne oder auch
Gas äh Lieferung, das muss alles sofort eingestellt werden, weil wir finanzieren halt den Krieg.
Das sind dann eben so Maximalforderungen, wo man dann eben auch sagen kann, so hm ja ich verstehe deine Motivation, aber ne äh das könnte uns ja eben auch schaden.
Nicht nur schaden, sondern gerade ich sage mal mit dem Energieding äh das kann man natürlich auch so umdrehen, dass man sagen, aber wir brauchen halt die russische Energie
Lieferungen, damit unsere Industrie das Geld verdienen kann und die Waffen bauen kann, mit denen
wir äh euch jetzt versorgen in der Ukraine. Also sozusagen das das ist halt zwei.
Seit ich des des des Ganze so das geht in beide Richtungen und man kann jetzt natürlich sagen okay wir
das, dann haben die Russen weniger Geld für Waffen und wir haben weniger Geld für Waffen äh so, aber leider sind's dann eben nicht auch nur die Waffen und äh sondern
da kommen wir dann später auch nochmal zu, sondern wie lange hält welche Seite eigentlich auch durch und der ganze Krieg, wenn man mal sagen, sieht jetzt so aus, als würde es wohl etwas länger
dauern. Ich meine, die Kruten haben sich ohnehin für ein Jahr.
So äh verpflichtet, aber wir haben ja auch gesehen, dass auch in so Ländern wie Afghanistan äh so, je nachdem, die Russen waren zehn Jahre da, die NATO war 20 Jahre da. So, also das kann
jetzt auch eine Weile dauern. Ich glaube zwar nicht, dass es jetzt 1 oder 20 Jahre gehen wird, nicht bei der Intensität, äh die das Ganze jetzt hat.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz können wir doch könnte das schon äh auf Jahre hinauslaufen. Wenn wir Pech haben.
Also man kann Vorsicht, Furcht und man kann Mut leichtfertigkeit äh Kalt nennen. Das ist völlig äh schöne Überschrift so, weil ich mich dann halt auch eben gefragt habe, ist unsere Vorsicht nicht vielleicht auch einfach Furcht?
Diese ganze Debatte dreht sich ja auch gerade viel um,
Okay, was ist denn jetzt hier mit Putin und dem Rest der Welt irgendwie äh droht der nur? Und muss man den einfach mal hart rannehmen, weil wenn eine andere Sprache kennt der nicht, ja? Ist unsere Vorsicht nicht dann auch wieder äh verlängertes? Also das ist so ein ziemliches Hin und Her und vor und zurück und
Kann irgendwie ähm alle Positionen äh gewisser Hinsicht nachvollziehen, weiß aber dann auch noch nicht unbedingt was äh.
Passiert. Aber vielleicht schauen wir einfach erstmal so ein bisschen da drauf, was so generell äh passiert ist. Also ähm.
Russland ist jetzt aus dem Europarat ausgetreten ähm und ist damit aber, glaube ich, auch nur ihrem Rauswurf äh.
Vorgekommen, wenn ich das richtig äh mitbekommen habe. Damit sind sie dann auch an die entsprechenden Menschenrechtskonventionen.
Die darin verbürgt sind nicht mehr gebunden es wird auf allen Seiten ähm ermittelt.
Bezüglich Kriegsverbrechen. Das klingt jetzt erstmal so ein bisschen na ja, das klingt so ein bisschen,
das wird's Ihnen aber zeigen so dachte du du du ne ja hier mit eurem Krieg so jetzt ermitteln wir aber gegen euch jetzt müsst ihr aber Angst haben,
klar, dass die das jetzt derzeit nicht beeindruckt, ist klar, aber wir müssen ja auch langfristig äh denken und das ist halt zumindest die klare Ansage und es ist einem auch die klare Ansage für.
Kleinere Staaten, die vielleicht hin und her gerissen sind.
Die so ein bisschen schwach dastehen, die nicht wissen, ob sie nicht vielleicht irgendwie von Russland auch noch mal ausgetrickst werden können, entweder sofort oder in naher Zukunft.
Wenn sie sich jetzt politisch falsch verhalten aus Russlands Sicht
dann von denen später bestraft zu werden und äh nicht von irgendjemand anderes gerettet zu werden äh in dem Moment, wo aber die UN sich halt klar aus äh.
Wo war's die UN? Also irgendein Gerichtshof jetzt grad nicht so ganz zusammen aber es gibt zumindest diese diese Feststellung so. Okay also der Krieg ist ganz klar von Russland ausgegangen.
Hier wird einfach Völkerrecht äh gebrochen und das ist halt einfach illegaler Krieg und fettig.
Ja, es gibt dann entweder irgendwie den den ICJ International Court of of Justice. Der ist dann so für völkerrechtliche Fragen äh zuständig und dann gibt's noch den ICC. Das ist der international kriminal äh Court.
Wo dann eben auch so konkret dann auch Kriegsverbrecher so.
Ja ähm dann angeklagt und äh verurteilt werden, wobei dem ähm.
Eben dem ICC auch die USA ja nicht beigetreten äh sind oder.
Haben. Sie erkennen den nicht nicht an. Ähm man man wird sehen äh aber äh das das Ding war ja auch dann mit mit,
wo Joe Biden gefragt wurde, so ist es ist ja jetzt ein Kriegsverbrecher oder nicht Putin und gesagt hat.
So ja, ich würde Ihnen schon einen Kriegsverbrecher nennen, ähm,
daraufhin wurden gab's dann eine ganze Menge Nachfragen so auch bei den offiziellen Weißen Haus und dann war die Antwort na ja.
Also jetzt die Meinung, die persönliche Meinung des Präsidenten so und äh und offensichtlich ist er ja auch ein Kriegsverbrecher so, wenn man sich das das anguckt, aber.
Das Justizministerium
ermittelt und ähm versuche das jetzt sozusagen dann nicht nur nach Bauchgefühl äh sondern dann jetzt nochmal konkret nach gesetzlicher Grundlage und da hat die USA natürlich so ein bisschen die Zwickmühle
Ähm es gibt natürlich keinen sauberen Krieg und auch die USA äh hat natürlich ganz, ganz viele
Menschenrechtsverletzungen und auch Kriegsverbrechen begangen und ist deswegen dann, was so die offizielle Haltung äh angeht. Äh da glaube ich ein bisschen zurückhaltend, weil ähm
Ja sie da auch nicht ganz sauber oder auch nicht wirklich sauber dastehen, was so Kriegsverbrechen angeht und
müssen sie also irgendeinen Weg finden, wie das auf Putin zutrifft und äh jetzt aber auf Amerika nicht ähm so na ja.
Gut, aber in dem Fall ein Angriffskrieg äh und so und also äh für also für jeden
auch ohne rechtlichen Hintergrund äh Grund
äh so kann man denke ich schon sehen, dass da auch Kriegsverbrechen einfach passieren, insbesondere jetzt Bombardierung von Zivilbevölkerung, aber es gibt natürlich immer zivile Opfer und dann kommt äh der der Vorwurf, na ja, die haben äh da haben sich
eben dann auch Truppen äh drin äh befunden oder die haben wurden dann als menschliches Schutzschilde äh benutzt und deswegen war waren
äh äh dort legitimiert, aber ja ähm damit kann man kann nicht wirklich argumentiert werden, glaube ich. Wobei.
Auch wieder jetzt nur neutral auf die Sache guckt äh trotz der wirklich.
Sehr hohen zivilen Opfer.
Gehe ich auch äh ja über 100 Kinder und vermutlich ja fast auch irgendwo an die zehntausend Zivilisten, die da jetzt getötet äh worden äh sein könnten, ist das.
Im
Vergleich, wenn äh ja von von größeren Konflikten oder das, was noch noch draus werden äh kann, hält sich das halt auch noch in Grenzen. Aber es wird halt schlimmer.
Ja also politische Aktivitäten natürlich auch allen äh.
Ebenen. Ähm ich hatte äh glaube ich in einer letzten Sendung angekündigt, dass jetzt dran gearbeitet wird, das europäische Stromnetz, mit dem der Ukraine zu verbinden, das.
Stattgefunden. Das ist dann auch ähm wie ich dann erfahren habe nix äh außergewöhnliches dahingehend, als dass das ohnehin geplant war.
Allerdings war das erst so fürs nächste Jahr geplant. Und das haben sie halt jetzt einfach äh beschleunigt und das ist wohl.
Hat jetzt wohl stattgefunden. Das heißt, Strom.
Kann in das Netz gegeben werden von der EU. Ich bin mir jetzt gerade nicht sicher, wo da die Übergangspunkte sind, ob das äh Rumänien, ob das Ungarn äh ist, ob das Polen ist oder alle vielleicht, keine Ahnung.
Aber äh das ist halt auf jeden Fall auch so eine äh Aktivität, sprich ich erwähne das jetzt auch nur, weil das eben auch so eine,
politischer Move ist, ne? Also ein politischer Move, der eben auch eine Stärkung,
des Landes bedeuten kann und auch hier eigentlich auch ein Zeichen der Integration ist, ne. Ja, aber vor allem hat Selenski ähm sehr durch internationale Ansprachen vor Parlamenten,
viel Aufmerksamkeit erzeugt. Ich meine, er ist ohnehin jemand wir haben ja ganz zu Anfang schon von ihm gesprochen.
Was das so für eine bemerkenswerte Geschichte ist, die jetzt hinter ihm steht, aber bisher hatte er auch nicht nachgelassen und meine Wahrnehmung ist die,
Dass er jetzt als Typ und in dieser äh Rolle.
Nicht im Sinne von Schauspielerrolle, sondern dieser dieser Rolle als.
Erste oberste äh verantwortungsvolle Person dieses Landes, ja? Also wirklich als Präsident, das auch voll annimmt.
Und so als Vorbild.
Für alle und als Motivationsvorbild für alle auch agiert und das auch bewusst angenommen hat und und alles dafür tut so. Das heißt er legt das jetzt einerseits in die Waagschale. Er hat.
Durch diese Position, in der er jetzt gekommen ist und nicht nur die Position des Präsidenten an sich, legalerweise, sondern einfach.
Dieses Kriegspräsidenten, der der sich einsetzt.
Wo sich das Volk hinter ihm versammelt, aber eben auch nicht nur, weil Krieg ist oder weil er in seiner Art und Weise, wie er äh die Ukraine hier vertritt, einfach für hohe Motivation sorgt.
Und diese Strahlkraft, die er dadurch gewonnen hat, versucht er jetzt auch zu nutzen und spricht eben mit der Politik. Und wenn wir uns halt anschauen.
Er noch vor wenigen Jahren von Trump hintergangen wurde und einfach niemand wirklich bereit war, der Ukraine wirklich groß zur Seite zu springen.
Hat sich das jetzt komplett verändert und das hat sich dann ziemlich deutlich gezeigt in diesen Ansprachen in den drei Parlamenten. Er war halt im britischen Parlament. Er war im äh hat vor dem Kongress der USA gesprochen.
Ich glaube das war dann sozusagen beide Häuser.
Und auch im Bundestag, ne? Das war dann auch mit Abstand, dass am wenigsten kurioseste äh Ereignis, weil die Deutschen es geschafft haben, da diesen historischen Moment dann gleich zu irgend so einer Impfdebatte,
anschließen zu lassen. Das war alles ein bisschen peinlich, aber gut, ist halt Deutschland. Interessant fand ich allerdings, wie er.
Das angegangen ist. Also er hat vor dem britischen Parlament natürlich irgendwie.
Auf die britische Seele äh äh gedrückt, sich immer für alles bedankt, aber er hat dann halt in seinen Formulierungen die äh berühmte Beaches Rede von Churchill aufgegriffen.
Ja, also wir wir werden sie an den Stränden bekämpfen, wir werden sie auf den Feldern bekämpfen und so weiter und hat das äh so äh in ähnlicher Fasson eben aus der ukrainischen Perspektive benutzt dieses.
Das ist natürlich auch nicht unbemerkt gewesen. Dann war er.
Äh in den USA vor dem Kongress und dort hat er dann eben Pearl Haber und Nine Eleven.
Als Vergleich herangezogen, ja, also um einfach den Amerikanern klarzumachen so,
was hier bei uns passiert, das ist so das, was diese Ereignisse mit eurem Land gemacht haben und das war ja so transformative Kriegs- und Terrorereignisse, muss man ja gar nicht weiter betonen.
Und oben drauf hat er dann eben auch noch Martin Luther King äh zitiert, äh die I have a Dream äh Rede, indem er halt so eine Formulierung gewählt hat, mit dass er irgendwie einen Traum hat
das und das äh passieren könnte. Also hat schon sehr offensichtlich versucht, so sehr auf das spezifische.
Ähm würde ich sagen, die Gefühlsduseligkeit des jeweiligen Landes anzusprechen
sondern auch in Deutschland probiert, ne, nur da sind wir ja nicht ganz so gefühlsduselig, da hat er dann eben äh an die Mauer angespielt so und nach dem Motto ja hier äh
tervicewall downmäßig so ja bitte hier äh verhindern Sie das hier irgendwie eine Mauer gebaut wird,
oder dass die Mauer zur Freiheit irgendwie eingerissen werden muss. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie seine Formulierung jetzt war. Aber das war dann sozusagen so äh das Ding.
Des Landes hat er eine Steuerreform verabschiedet. Wir machen jetzt irgendwie Umsatzsteuer weg und so weiter und äh.
Wollen halt irgendwie quasi das, was von der Wirtschaft jetzt noch verblieben ist, was noch funktioniert äh das irgendwie hochdrehen, damit es irgendwie funktioniert, ja und ähm.
Bringen halt diese Steuerreform raus und äh es gibt halt keine Einkommenssteuer und es gibt kein äh VIT mehr.
Sondern sie nehmen irgendwie nur zwei Prozent vom Umsatz und äh akzeptieren so Simply Fight Accounting, also sie stellen sozusagen in so einen Kriegsmodus um, sagen so, Leute, ihr sollt euch nicht mit Buchhaltung beschäftigen.
Wir wollen, dass hier irgendwie der Laden läuft, ja, gibt uns 2 Prozent voll Umsatz, fertig.
Und ihr müsst auch nicht hier groß irgendwie tausend Formulare und Elsa online und so weiter, sondern schreibt das uff.
Gibt uns das Geld, wir kämpfen hier und ihr macht Business und die Sache muss äh laufen, ja. Und wenn wenn ihr es nicht äh.
Wenn ihr's nicht bezahlen könnt, wenn ihr die Kohle nicht habt, dann zahlt sie nicht und wir werden auch nicht nachfragen.
Das das ist sozusagen die Ansage.
Es ist mal eine irgendwie
eine völlige Umkehrung, äh sagen dieses Prinzips, was da früher in der in der Ukraine äh herrschte. So nach dem Motto ja ähm also.
Bitte äh zahlt die Steuer. Ihr ihr müsst nicht, aber ihr seht ähm es ist für einen guten Zweck äh so, also
ähm kann ich mir sogar vorstellen, dass es funktionieren kann äh in dieser in dieser Situation, ne, dass die Leute sagen.
Sie trotzdem zahlen, obwohl obwohl klar ist, dass sie nicht müssen.
Ja, das denke ich allerdings auch, dass das funktioniert. Es geht ja noch weiter, ne? Also da machen auch noch so eine Deregulierung ähm sie sagen sie sie äh es gibt keine Inspektion mehr.
Für alle Betriebe niemand wird jetzt irgendwie überprüft. Ja ähm.
Wir wollen einfach, dass ihr erarbeitet. Wir wollen, dass irgendwie Leute beschäftigt werden. Wir wollen, dass das in den Städten äh was passiert und und und dass das einfach maximale wirtschaftliche Aktivität stattfinden.
Kann. So, wir halten uns jetzt nicht einfach mit Kleinkram äh auf, ne? Und das Einzige, was sie halt äh.
Sichergestellt sehen möchten ist, dass sie einfach äh sich auch drum kümmern, dass ihre ihr Business läuft.
Und äh dass ihr euch irgendwie im im Rahmen des der Gesetze äh bewegt. So, aber ihr müsst euch jetzt selber drum kümmern, ne und das sind jetzt so zwei erste Schritte, die sie machen.
Aber sie sagen das, damit ist es auch noch nicht getan. Also äh sie sind jetzt nicht nur in so einem Kriegsmodus, sondern sie sind eben auch in einem, es gibt unser Land auch noch und äh wir stellen jetzt auf Kriegswirtschaft um quasi, ne.
Was man auch immer leicht vergisst oder woran man nicht denkt eben ist, dass das Land natürlich trotz Krieg auch irgendwo noch Leute weiterarbeiten und weiter produzieren und weiter auch ihre Felder äh bestellen zumindest in
in Teilen äh in den meisten Teilen des Landes, wo eben gerade nicht gekämpft.
Äh wird so und äh insofern ist das natürlich auch jetzt wichtig und macht Sinn bis hin zu äh wo eben auch nicht drüber geredet wird.
Ähm.
So dass die Ukraine natürlich selber auch an Waffen und Munitionsproduzent ist und dass ich hoffe und davon ausgehe eigentlich, dass dort auch die Waffen und Munitionsfabriken auf Hochtouren laufen gerade.
Ja.
Jetzt müssen wir mal ein bisschen vielleicht mal auch raus aus dem Westen schauen, weil da ist die Situation in gewisser Hinsicht.
Klar ja? Man versucht das Maximale äh an Sanktionen rauszuholen. Das Maximale an Waffenunterstützung rauszuholen und politische Unterstützung ohnehin.
Ähm andere Länder,
andere Realitäten. Also Israel zum Beispiel gehört zu den Ländern, die sich eben noch nicht an diese Sanktionen angeschlossen haben. Und die haben ja auch relativ enge Verbindungen mit Russland
Es sind sehr viele Juden aus Russland in äh Israel eingewandert. Das heißt, sie haben da einen sehr hohen Anteil.
Und also jetzt nicht Flüchtlinge, sondern halt ne Leute, die.
Eine Million.
Langer Zeit sind. Eine Million ist das. Das ist für israelische Verhältnisse.
Insgesamt aber nicht halt alles nicht nur Russen, äh sondern eben aus allen Ländern der ehemaligen Sowjetunion und deswegen der Botschafter auch nicht
ja hat dann auch mal betont ja nicht nur Russen, sondern auch Ukrainer äh wohnen und leben bei uns. Ganz viele und
aber äh nun mal auch äh einen Haufen äh Oligarchen. Äh so, die haben die Oligarchen haben sich halt auch überall noch
Pässe geholt in aller Welt, jetzt nicht nur in Israel, aber dort war's natürlich besonders einfach, wenn man irgendwie jüdischer Abstammung äh.
Und so kam's dazu, dass irgendwie ich glaube 19 mindestens 19 Oligarchen je nachdem wie man zählt halt auch einen israelischen Pass haben.
Und äh insbesondere eben auch hier
äh der dann auch erstmal aus England dann nach Tel Aviv geflogen ist mit seinem Privatjet und sich dann aber weiter auf dem Weg nach Russland gemacht hat. Also der ist jetzt in Russland angekommen, weil.
Ja, das war dann halt doch nicht so einfach. Außerdem hat Israel ein Bombardierungs äh
eine Bombardierungserlaubnis für Syrien. So ähm und,
mit einer äh oder ja äh da gibt's einen Deal zwischen Israel und Russland, äh dass äh Israel eben in Syrien halt,
bestimmte Ziele bombardieren äh darf und die Russen sich nicht einmischen.
Dort und das war eben jetzt auch so ein so ein so ein Ding, äh wo die Israelis äh halt um ihre Bombardierungs erlaubt
für Syrien, dann äh sich fürchteten. Ich weiß nicht, wie sich das jetzt entwickelt hat. Es gab dann eben auch gerade wieder neue Bombardierungen ähm
wo ähm
aber äh ja das ist halt auch noch so ein Problem unter russische Truppen stehen eben bei Israel auch direkt an der Grenze. Da sind die wohl auch ein bisschen nervös. Also in Syrien jetzt vor allem.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall Israel ist äh da auch im Konflikt mit den USA, ne, weil sie quasi jetzt auch so ein bisschen safe,
helfen sind, da sind sie auch nicht alleine, äh auch so die Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate, Dubai, et cetera, die sind da auch auf jeden Fall mit dabei.
Und ja nehmen da so eher eine neutrale Stellung ein und sind sicherlich auch Abwurfzone für russisches Geld.
Gar keine Frage. Na ja und ähm für Israel ist es natürlich besonders schwierig finde ich.
Weil sie ja nun auf der anderen Seite es mit der Ukraine eben auch eine der Regionen äh in Europa ist, wo einfach sehr viele Juden noch leben. Ich meine, sogar der Selensky ist Jude.
Und.
Wobei gut, er war jetzt wohl nie äh äh wirklich jetzt besonders mhm religiös.
Nein, das nicht. Äh ist jetzt nicht der tief religiöse, aber das ist jetzt, sagen wir mal, für für Israel jetzt auch nicht so unwichtig.
Ja und tatsächlich hörte ich das auch, dass
sagen in der Ukraine jetzt nach Ende der Sowjetunion wohl das jüdische Leben besonders aufgeblüht
ist, sodass dort äh ja quasi so eine Art äh
ja Renaissance der jüdischen Religion auch gegeben hat und viele Gotteshäuser da gebaut äh worden sind und so,
das war eben auch so ein so ein Punkt, weswegen ich eigentlich davon dachte, dass Israel da doch die Ukraine viel, viel stärker unterstützen äh wird, weil die äh der.
Die diverse ähm israelische Ministerpräsidenten waren auch in der Ukraine und und so und haben da auch äh sehr viel unterstützt, aber im Moment sind sie nicht mal bereit Helme
und hm um Schutzausrüstung, also Westen.
Zu liefern, sondern äh stattdessen haben sie sich rein auf humanitäre Hilfe beschränkt, also in dem Fall wohl äh
halbe Krankenhäuser oder so, äh Feldlazarette, glaube ich, geliefert.
Aber äh sozusagen nichts Militärisches und erst also nicht mal nicht mal Schutz aus militärische Schutzausrüstung und erst recht keine Waffen.
Und da waren eben ja in den USA wurden dann so Stimmen äh laut natürlich von wegen ein ganz schön wieder mal ganz schön undankbarer Verbündeter, das kam in der Vergangenheit schon öfter
mal mal auf, wenn Israel nicht so äh mitzog mit den
USA und äh gerade würde man denken, gerade bei bei Israel, die ja nun die Situation kennen, wie das ist, wenn man so plötzlich vom Nachbarn überfallen wird und Panzer da reinrollen und
wie dringend man dann auf Waffen angewiesen ist und wie dann eben schon auch immer äh vor allem.
Natürlich westliche Länder und vor allem allen voran die USA dann geholfen haben, so auch äh ja im
so schnell wie möglich Waffen und Nachschub zu liefern und dass die dass Israel äh sich sich da jetzt so einen
so einen schlanken Fuß macht an der Stelle wurde halt speziell in der in der USA
nicht so gut aufgenommen bis hin zu den Forderungen von einigen Senatoren und auch Kongress äh Abgeordneten man möge doch dann jetzt die Militärhilfe
und die Waffen, die für Israel vorgesehen sind, doch äh in die Ukraine umlenken.
Ja, also das ist gefährlich, grad eine gefährliche Situation für für Israel gerade.
Schwierig nachzuvollziehen, was sie ähm da jetzt eigentlich äh treibt. Ich meine, sie haben natürlich die Russen auch direkt vor der Nase, aber sie sind halt klarer Unterstützer äh von Assad und das ist ja nun mal der Erzfeind,
Israelis, also einer der Erzfeinde, wir haben ja eine ganze Menge davon, ähm.
Sicherlich wird es in irgendeiner Form so ein Paket der Gesamtabwägung sein. Ich äh.
Mich aber nicht in der Lage nachzuvollziehen, wie da die Gleichung aufgestellt ist.
Schwer zu sagen, aber äh so aber Israel ist natürlich auch ein relativ korruptes Land oder zumindest äh ich.
Ja es ist dort Korruption deutlich verbreiteter als in in vielen anderen Ländern und äh das spielt dann vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen
eine eine Rolle
da auch einfach durchaus russischer Einfluss über die Oligarchen und das Geld äh tatsächlich auch noch eine Rolle spielt an der Stelle
würde ich jetzt äh auch nicht ganz äh ähm ausschließen, dass das dort Erpressungspotential auch noch gibt auf politischer Ebene.
Äh weil äh dann äh ja die wissen, also sozusagen Russland und die Oligarchen wissen, wen sie da alles in Israel möglicherweise geschmiert haben.
Ähm oder unschöne Geschäfte gemacht haben.
Gut, aber im Mittelpunkt und Blickfeld der internationalen Politik ist natürlich vor allem China. Weil.
China wird zumindest von vielen als einer der Schlüsselplayer in diesem ganzen Konflikt gesehen, weil.
Die Frage ist, wie positioniert sich eigentlich China? Wie positioniert sich China.
Sicherheitsrat, wie positioniert sich äh China an sich ja, unterstützen Sie jetzt die Rosten, lassen Sie links liegen, was jetzt eigentlich grade die Position von.
China. Und das ist ähm auch noch nicht so hundertprozentig klar. Man kann ja davon ausgehen.
Dass China im Prinzip profitiert von einem geschwächten Russland.
Ja, also Energielieferung und so weiter können die immer gebrauchen und Russland steht halt jetzt quasi mit runtergelassenen Hosen da, wirtschaftlich und wird einfach von China extrem äh.
Abhängig sein,
Das ist halt einfach ähm etwas, das läuft sozusagen auf sie zu. Andererseits haben wir ja hier auch schon mehrfach angesprochen. Ist jetzt dieser Krieg natürlich jetzt für China auch nicht so geil, weil sie jetzt mal ganz unabhängig von solchen Konflikten wie Taiwan
ähm einfach eher.
Doch in den letzten Jahren eine Politik der langfristigen, sehr langfristigen Planung.
An den Tag gelegt haben. Ja das ist so andere Länder überfallen und irgendwie
schnell mal irgendwo Fakten schaffen, das ist nicht das, was China in den letzten Jahren gemacht hat, sondern China hat einfach gesagt, wir wollen in 30 Jahren in diesem Sektor da und da sein und jetzt äh
rollen wir aber auch mal alles aus, was in irgendeiner Form uns diesen Ziel näher bringen kann.
Und das ist ja für Sie auch, muss man sagen, gut gelaufen. Letzten 30 Jahren ist China von.
Potentiell könnte mal eine Menge passieren zu dominiert extrem viele internationalen Lieferketten und Produktionsstandorte et cetera. China ist
oder lässig geworden und alle haben Angst äh wenn China hustet, dass dass der Rest halt eine Erkältung kriegt.
Und ähm in dem Zusammenhang kann ihnen wiederum dieser krasse Konflikt, der dann so eine totale Destabilisierung und damit eben auch so eine also eine unvorhersehbare Verschiebung der.
Mächte und der Einflüsse irgendwo auch nicht so recht sein.
Aber dann wiederum ist es halt auch woanders aufm Planeten. Also es ist sehr schwierig einzuschätzen.
Ja, ich würde dir sagen, was heißt zwei Dingen widersprechen, aber äh äh zumindest ähm also die.
Letzten, ich würde sagen, die letzten zehn Jahre lief's eigentlich nicht so gut und speziell die letzten fünf Jahre. Also ähm wir haben da auch
den Chinesen, glaube ich, unterm Strich ähm mehr Plan unterstellt
als sie wirklich haben so. Äh zum Beispiel dieser massive Infrastrukturausbau äh der da erfolgt ist und dieser massive Immobilienboom der ist nicht nach Plan.
Verlaufen, sondern da wurden halt bestimmte Weichen gestellt, also Immobilien Boom ist Folge äh der Schwierigkeit anderswo Geld sicher
anzulegen. Es ist sozusagen die
Anlagemöglichkeit gewesen und weil in China eben auch äh so eine hohe Sparquote hatte, muss das Geld irgendwohin, das kannst du nicht in der Bank lassen
äh äh und deswegen ist da ganz, ganz viel in Immobilien geflossen und die Infrastrukturausgaben am Anfang erstmal ein guter Schritt, aber die haben die dann so organisiert
Das äh sowohl dann auch die Abgabe von Immobilien in China,
also von Grundstücken so rum. Dort gehört ja alles dem Staat und wird nur auf 99 Jahre Erbpacht an.
Abgegeben, dass sich dann äh daraus die Provinzen auch finanziert haben, indem sie Baugrundstücke zur Verfügung gestellt haben ohne Ende.
Dann teilweise ja dreißig, 40, 50 Prozent des des Haushalts äh aus,
eben diesen Immobilien bestritten haben oder aus den aus den aus den Grundstücken, die sie ausgewiesen haben.
So und der Infrastrukturausbau ist dann so explodiert, weil sie dafür wiederum spezielle Finanzkonstruktionen geschaffen haben, die es ihnen ermöglichte, quasi Schulden in beliebiger Höhe,
aufzunehmen und äh damit dann auch nochmal mhm Löcher zu zu stopfen beziehungsweise,
dadurch, dass dann so viel Geld in die Infrastrukturausbau geflossen ist, hat es natürlich auch die Einkommen und und und alles, aber das war eben auch sehr viel auf Pump und sie,
sind auch weit über den Punkt hinausgeschossen, wo sich das jetzt rechnet und und lohnt, so die ganzen ähm also
schon mal die ganzen Schnellbahnen, eigentlich hätten sie besser drangetan, dass die normalen Eisenbahn erstmal zu fixen äh so und die
äh äh weil Fracht und so die diese ganzen Nebenstrecken sind in einem furchtbaren Zustand und die Straßen sind auch teilweise in einem furchtbaren Zustand. Also wir sagen,
die Allokation dieser Mittel äh weil die Wirtschaft auch überhitzt war
ist jetzt teilweise in der Art und Weise erfolgt, wie es nicht nachhaltig ist
nicht auf Dauer finanzierbar. Also die weil teilweise sind jetzt die laufenden Kosten schon äh so hoch von einigen Schnellbahnstrecken, dass sie den Betrieb kürzen müssen und und so. Also.
Ja, da muss man jetzt eben auch auch genau genau hingucken. Äh gut, unterm Strich der chinesische Boom hat halt ganz, ganz viele Leute aus der Armut geholt in China, aber es ist da auch nicht alles Gold, was.
Okay, aber das ist ja jetzt eine äh eine chinesische innenpolitische Perspektive, die du jetzt präsentierst. Mir ging's um die außenpolitische Perspektive. Wie
interagiert jetzt China mit anderen Ländern wie positioniert sich da geht nichts schief oder so das das ist nicht.
Nicht das, worauf ich hinaus wollte, aber wenn du dir anschaust, wie China jetzt über
Jahrzehnte strategisch in Afrika investiert hat, wie sie in allen Ländern, wo sie potenziell irgendwie ihre Ressourcen in Zukunft mal bekommen können.
Platziert haben, dann ist es halt keine
Strategie der Machtdemonstration, die sind da nicht reingegangen und haben irgendwelche Länder überfallen oder irgendwelche Regierungen ähm
gestürzt oder oder sonst irgendwie was, wie das die Amerikaner gerne mal gemacht haben, sondern sie haben einfach ihre Softpower eingesetzt. Sie haben einfach gesagt, so
Ach, ihr braucht Geld, ihr habt zu wenig Straßen. Ihr braucht mal ein paar Schulen. Ihr braucht mal ein paar Turnhallen. Ihr braucht mal ein paar Fabriken. Ja, dann ähm ähm
ne? Bauen wir euch, äh unterschreibt
mal hier diesen Zettel, das Kleingedruckte braucht ihr nicht zu lesen und so haben sie sich eben einfach schrittweise reingezogen, während wir also immer über Entwicklungshilfe schwadroniert haben und hier mal eine Straße gebaut haben, da mal eine Straße gebaut haben, haben sie einfach diverse afrikanische Länder, damit de facto,
quasi übernommen, weil sie dann den Handel dann irgendwie da in den Handel eingestiegen sind. Die haben einfach äh das, was die Länder importiert haben, das haben sie dann einfach geliefert.
Dafür haben sie dann eben Zuschlag auch für die Ressourcen-Exportation bekommen, et cetera. Also das ist sozusagen ihr Modus,
Auf so einer internationalen Ebene und der basiert eben da drauf, dass diese Systeme auch stabil bleiben.
Absolut absolut äh ja äh also die Chinesen jetzt ganz verkürzt und ich weiß, das ist dann auch wieder so ein so ein Klischee, aber
Ähm glaube, es hat auch was mit Konfuzianismus äh zu tun und mit Harmonie äh Gedanken, dass die Chinesen eigentlich eher Gewaltkonfliktscheu sind, was.
Jetzt bin ich aber enttäuscht, dass du kein Zitat von Otto von Bismarck zur Hand hast.
Ja also was auch immer es ist, aber es ist halt einfach China.
Chinas Außenpolitik basiert nicht auf Zerstörung der Strukturen, sondern sie nutzen die äh aus und brauchen halt irgendwie Stabilität und äh.
Das müssen wir auch noch mal diese Situation mit dem Weizen anbringen. Weizen, ich meine wenn man in China denkt, denkt man an Reis.
Aber dort hat sich halt in den letzten zehn, 20 Jahren auch das kulturelle Leben.
An bestimmten internationalen Gepflogenheiten angepasst und der Weizenverbrauch. Also das Essen vom Brot et cetera und all der Produkte, die man damit herstellen kann, Mehl.
Ist extrem gestiegen, ne, was da so eine neue Mittelschicht und die äh ist halt anders.
Mit anderen Worten, China ist auch ein extremer Weizen äh Importeur. Ich glaube.
Weizen anbauen, aber ist halt äh vor allem ähm importieren sie halt viel und haben auch extreme Lager aufgebaut.
Ne und sie haben einfach ein Interesse daran. Wo kommt der Weizen her? Ukraine und Russland sind halt zwei.
Der größten Weizenproduzenten auf diesem Planeten. So und äh das erwähne ich halt jetzt, weil auch hier natürlich die Disruption.
Der Weizenproduktion in der Ukraine hals auf dem Spiel steht.
Plus äh ja die China gehören glaube ich zwischen fünf und zehn Prozent der Anbauflächen in in der Ukraine auch da,
auch gefragt. Ja ja äh also vor
vor zehn Jahren, weil sich wir haben die fünf Prozent überschritten äh gehabt. Aber äh,
nochmal einigen äh ganz, ganz kurz zu dieser ganzen Auslandsgeschichte äh
Ähm auch das ist alles läuft grade nicht nicht nicht super und
ähm was eben auch dafür spricht, dass China da nicht so gerne in Gewaltkonflikte reingeht, ist, dass sie äh dort
nachdem es nicht so gut gelaufen ist an verschiedenen Stellen äh und jetzt die Bevölkerung dort,
macht und es zu Aufständen kommt, hm schickt China aber keine Truppen oder Sicherheitsleute, sondern da müssen sich die Leute vor Ort selber drum kümmern, halt auch wieder so ein chinesischer ja äh Fuck.
Äh also das machen dann mal die anderen Sorgen dann wenigstens für ordentlich Security, aber selbst da kümmern sich die Chinesen da nicht drum, weil sie jetzt,
äh eben nicht nicht so gut sind im im Plan und und dann ihre Soft Power dann doch äh
glaube ich nicht so geübt darin äh sind, sondern mehr halt ja wenn's wenn's dann etwas mehr als Korruption äh sein sein soll, dann wird's da offenbar dann auch auch ein bisschen schwierig beziehungsweise
haben Sie nicht unbedingt jetzt das Wohl der einheimischen Bevölkerung jetzt mitgedacht bei bei dem Ganzen, sondern äh und das fällt Ihnen jetzt langsam auf die Füße.
Gut, aber trotzdem, also ich sage ja nur
Position ist jetzt wichtig und äh die Frage ist, was was hat China zu verlieren? Natürlich hat China auch Angst vor Sanktionen. Jetzt ist es natürlich klar
Man kann China also erstmal besteht ja gar nicht die ähm die Legitimation dafür ja aber selbst wenn man auch nur sagen würde so wenn ihr jetzt nicht mit uns hier gegen diesen Ukrainerkrieg vorgeht, der für den Westen jetzt einfach mal das größte Desaster seit dem zweiten Weltkrieg ist
Ja, dann haben wir euch nicht mehr so lieb.
Diesen Liebesentzug, den äh bezahlt ihr jetzt mit und dann wird's schwierig überhaupt Sanktionen zu finden, die nicht den Westen stärker treffen, auch weil ja äh China auch zurückschlagen kann.
Als äh als in irgendeiner Form bezweckt. Nichtsdestotrotz haben sie aber auch jetzt,
sind sie glaube ich nicht auf so einer Position, wo sie sagen, ja was wollt ihr denn eigentlich, wir sind doch sowieso größer als ihr. So funktioniert auch nicht.
Passen da jetzt auf und ich meine beiden,
war jetzt auch gerade äh in der in der Woche äh oder die haben eine längere Videokonferenz glaube ich gehabt Biden und äh chi Jing. So,
Ähm und da hat äh gut die war jetzt nicht öffentlich äh oder so äh
Aber äh beide haben natürlich hinterher dann Erklärungen abgegeben und hm beiden war da wohl ziemlich sehr direkt
äh hat also hat also wirklich gesagt also China
pass auf, wir gucken ganz genau hin, äh was ihr macht und wir werden das nicht dulden, dass ihr da irgendwie jetzt ähm ja unsere Sanktionen unterlaufen, ne, das,
war wohl schon sagen äh keine höfliche Ansprache und dann man sich natürlich fragt okay, was hat denn.
Äh darauf geantwortet und.
Der hat eigentlich nur irgendwie die das selbe wiederholt, was was China die ganze Zeit sagt, so nach dem Motto wie ja, wir.
Finden wir nicht gut und wir sind für Frieden und ähm
Ja ähm so das war's. Äh dann so ungefähr und das Ding ist äh aber man kann halt auch
den offiziellen Aussagen der Chinesen, die dann in der Presse so kolportiert werden. Hier kann man nicht glauben,
So, weil das ist alles äh im im Prinzip genauso wie wie bei Putin ist das halt komplett reine Propaganda äh was, was da verlautbart wird.
Wenn man wissen will, was China tatsächlich glaubt oder die chinesische Führung, die KP tatsächlich glaubt, muss man sich eigentlich chinesische Propaganda angucken, sprich ähm
was äh ja worauf was zeigen Sie jetzt dem dem dem Volk? Was zeigen Sie jetzt in den in den Medien?
Und äh was was oder was zeigen sie nicht, was wird was wird wegzensiert so das ist das das ist der eigentliche Maßstab und,
da bestätigt sich aber
auch, dass Sie na ja äh äh schon durchaus Bilder jetzt auch im chinesischen Staatsfernsehen gezeigt
haben und das Wort Krieg verwendet haben im chinesischen Staatsfernsehen und ukrainische Opfer und so. Also insofern äh ja mhm.
Ähm ist China da grade wirklich ein bisschen ambivalent und wie wir beim letzten hm Podcast, wie ich
auch da schon mal erwähnt hatte. Sie sind natürlich auch ein bisschen schockiert von der schlechten militärischen Performance äh der äh so wird
Union und ähm ich habe jetzt aus verschiedenen anderen Quellen von anderen Experten auch gehört, dass äh China wohl nach dem, was sie gesehen haben.
Invasion von Taiwan, falls Sie einige plant hatten, doch jetzt erstmal bis auf Weiteres zurückstellen.
So das war ja am Anfang auch die Panik, wird wird China das jetzt nutzen?
Die Situation äh so alle sind mit insbesondere die USA, sind jetzt mit der Ukraine beschäftigt. Da können wir ja jetzt in Taiwan.
Mittlerweile sind aber alle da äh komplett entspannt geworden, so was Taiwan angeht, weil die alle sagen, nee also
Das äh war jetzt eher ein Dämpfer für für China. Die Gefahr bestand jetzt vielleicht in den ersten Tagen so.
Aber äh ja, jetzt ähm wird China erstmal abwarten und ähm.
Wird wird dann auch erstmal erstmal zusehen. Und da habe ich jetzt ein Bismarckzitat äh äh für dich,
äh ja. Genau, die die Fähigkeit zu warten, während die Verhältnisse sich entwickeln, ist eine Vorbedingung praktischer Politik und.
Ich denke, ja, die Chinesen warten jetzt erstmal, wie die Verhältnisse sich entwickeln, bevor sie sich da eindeutig festlegen und machen praktische Politik gerade.
Den Eindruck hat man auch von Deutschland ähm Deutschland wird viel äh kritisiert dafür, dass sie sich wenig bewegen oder vor allem natürlich, dass äh sich vor allem der Bundeskanzler wenig äußert. Das scheint ja auch irgendwie.
So ein Ding zu sein mit dem Scholz, ne, dass der irgendwie die ganze Zeit smally aufmacht. Also der ist ja irgendwie kaum zu sehen und äußert sich irgendwie zu gar nix, nur wenn er muss.
Oder wenn er meint, dass er muss. Ehrlich gesagt, ich weiß noch nicht so ganz genau, was ich davon halten äh soll. Auf der anderen Seite habe ich jetzt auch ein Problem mit Leuten also Politikern.
Die sich auch zu jedem Scheiß immer sofort äußern müssen und man nichts Gefühl hat, dass sie mal vorher drüber nachgedacht haben, ja, was weiß ich, Herr Söder oder irgendwie sowas, immer irgendwie einen Text äh am Start haben und keine Kamera auslassen.
Ähm aber natürlich ist Deutschland halt auch irgendwie unter Druck und Deutschland ist irgendwie unter Druck ähm.
Auf vielen Ebenen, ne? Wir haben zunächst einmal haben wir so eine Flüchtlingssituation.
Nicht zu unterschätzen. Natürlich ist es klar in der Slowakei wahrscheinlich auch Tschechien und in Polen äh und ich vermute auch Mollau.
Rumänien kommen wahrscheinlich sehr viel mehr ukrainische äh Geflüchtete unter als in Deutschland. Trotz alledem sind jetzt schon drei Millionen, glaube ich, geflüchtet offiziell.
Ähm ich kenne jetzt keine Zahlen für Deutschland, aber viele tausende kommen täglich an.
Äh mehr als in der sogenannten Flüchtlingskrise von 2015 und äh natürlich ist das,
für uns eine Belastung, das belastet die äh
öffentlichen Gelder, es muss alles organisiert werden. Es äh ist natürlich auch für die Wohnungssituation in Deutschland alles nicht förderlich. Ich meine, da kann man jetzt viel klagen, angesichts der Situation in der Ukraine
braucht man da eigentlich gar nicht drüber reden. Das ist natürlich klar, dass wir da äh handeln müssen. Nur wissen wir ja, wie gut Deutschland da drin ist, zu handeln. Also gerade so jetzt hier in Berlin. Da gab's ja die Situation mit.
Mit den äh Schulen, es kommen natürlich auch viele Kinder so, Kinder müssen irgendwie in die Schule, ist klar, so ja Berlin, ja was was nicht in der Lage ist für die eigenen Kinder irgendwie in den zehn Jahre vor Planung ausreichend äh Schulen bereitzustellen,
sieht sich jetzt auf einmal so eine Inflation der Schülerzahlen gegenüber und das Interessante ist.
Hat sich die Ukraine gemeldet zu dem Thema. Also hier wurden dann schon so Willkommensklassen gegründet, also.
Eine Schule, wo meine Tochter ist, äh habe ich auch gehört, die hätten jetzt irgendwie schon zwei Willkommensklassen, wie das so schön heißt, also wo dann quasi nur die ukrainischen Kinder äh unterrichtet werden sollen von entsprechenden Lehrern, wo er auch sie immer dann äh bekommen sollen.
Und das ist halt irgendwie so äh drin und so Ukraine meint so, hm na ja.
Das wäre Ihnen jetzt eigentlich gar nicht so recht. Ja, weil.
Erstens, wir können das ja alles online machen. Ja, also Ukraine sieht überhaupt gar kein Problem damit,
Die ganzen Kinder irgendwie online zu unterrichten, weil die Lehrer haben sie ja irgendwie im Land und und und Internet, das können die halt äh wir machen das halt einfach alles online. Sie hätten halt auch generell.
Vorbehalte gegenüber dem Schulsystem in Deutschland, weil da würden ja die Kinder nicht so viel lernen.
Mhm. Verstehe, ja.
Gut, ich würde ich würde ja ich würde sagen, ich also ich sehe das, ich sehe das irgendwo ich sage mal in der Mitte äh klar
Es äh besteht natürlich dann auch die die Hoffnung äh äh so ein bisschen, dass äh dann auch eine ganze Menge bleiben oder dass sie hier
eben auch auf eine Art und Weise geprägt werden und äh auch ja dann eine Vorstellung von der Gesellschaft,
äh erhalten, die sie dann dort auch in der Ukraine sehen.
Wollen, so dass sie natürlich dann auch ja äh kulturell jetzt beeinflusst äh werden äh und so
insofern wäre mein Standpunkt man muss das eine ja kann das eine ja tun und muss das andere nicht nicht sein lassen und ich habe
äh bin ja auch nach Deutschland äh gekommen im Alter von dreieinhalb Jahren und.
Würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass mich jetzt äh ich sage mal da ein deutscher Kindergarten und deutsche Schulen jetzt irgendwo dann von der tschechischen Kultur entfremdet haben, weil du hast halt dann immer noch Eltern
die natürlich einen massiven Einfluss äh auf dich ausüben und ich denke, das ist nur äh gut und auch äh ich sage mal, wenn Sie dort mit einfach,
dann persönlich mit schlecht anderen Flüchtlingskindern zusammenkommen und zusammentreffen und dann sagen auch gemeinsam sich besprechen können, wie ist das denn in diesem neuen Land und so und also ich ich bin da so ein bisschen
sie ist sie ist sie ist so ein bisschen beides als.
Okay, ich wollte gar keine klare Meinung machen. Ich habe nur nur diese Meldung gesehen und äh musste natürlich ein bisschen äh grinsen. Äh letztlich der Punkt war.
Ist eine Belastung für Deutschland und Deutschland übernimmt halt jetzt auch einfach eine zentrale Rolle.
Europa. Das ist jetzt ganz klar und zwar auch, was das außenpolitische betrifft.
Ich wollte noch kurz kurz was äh eher zur zur äh sozusagen auch noch zu persönlichen äh Situation dann oder oder
jetzt in in Berlin, was vielleicht interessant ist, so ein paar Details. Noch also zum einen ist es gerade nicht ganz einfach, Hotelzimmer in Berlin zu kriegen, weil die Verwaltung ähm ja große Hotelkontingente für Flüchtlinge gebucht hat
dann äh war's ja,
Bahnhof teilweise so voll, äh dass äh eine Sperrung drohte, weil äh ja, der der Durchsatz teilweise nicht ausreicht, die hier in Berlin
von Berlin aus werden ja ganz viele Flüchtlinge dann weiter verteilt ins ins ganze Land äh und äh da gibt's wurde auch
teilweise der Flüchtlings äh.
Unterkünfte wurden ja riesige Strukturen geschaffen, um das zu tun. Die Sozialämter sind ansonsten auch noch überlastet. Ja, das ist das war's so ungefähr, was mir jetzt aufgefallen äh ist, ansonsten.
Läuft aber alles.
Ja klar, ne, aber die Rolle von Deutschland ist jetzt halt auch einfach international gefragt und ähm.
Noch vor zehn Jahren, bevor Großbritannien aus der EU ausgetreten war, da war das halt immer so, A internationale Krise,
äh äh redet mal besser keiner mit den Deutschen. So, die Deutschen haben alle gesagt, so okay, wie viel Geld braucht ihr? So und die Franzosen und die.
Briten haben sich dann irgendwie über ihre diplomatischen Kanäle äh um das Problem gekümmert. Das hat sich dann eben mit der Zeit geändert. Es hat sich auch schon.
In der Ukraine das erste Mal geändert, ja wo.
Merkel ja dann letzten Endes in den Verhandlungen saß, hat jetzt nicht viel gebracht, äh muss man sagen, langfristig, aber äh immerhin, das hat sich abgezeichnet und jetzt sind wir natürlich.
Jetzt sind wir natürlich an so einem Punkt, wo es irgendwie klar ist und alle alle schauen irgendwie auf Deutschland und.
Ich glaube, dass das jetzt auch für Deutschland so ein Punkt gekommen ist, wo wir dann sehr über unsere eigene Rolle und unser eigenes Selbstverständnis nachdenken müssen, ne? Grade in dieser Frage mit, wo wir irgendwie helfen können.
Weißt du, was Bismark dazu gesagt hätte? Setzen wir Deutschland in den Sattel. Reiten wird es schon können. Ja.
Ja, eine sehr optimistische äh Blick, ob Deutschland davon immer so überzeugt war, ne, ist eine andere.
Deutschland ist gar nicht davon überzeugt jetzt. Ich sage nur, das wäre halt jetzt was äh sozusagen Bismarck dazu gesagt hätte, aber ja ich ich denke nicht, dass Olaf Scholz einen Biss mag.
Ist so, was vielleicht auch ganz gut ist, so in mancherlei Hinsicht, aber äh ja ähm in solchen Zeiten, so merkt man plötzlich, dass
Leute, die man eigentlich in normalen Zeiten nicht am Ruder sehen will, dann plötzlich doch vielleicht einen gewissen Nutzen entfalten oder auch Notwendigkeit in einem bestimmten historischen Phasen so.
Wird sich zeigen. An der Stelle ähm kann ich auch noch mal ein Hinweis ähm auf einen YouTube äh Video und TED Talk.
Hm oder halt zumindest ein Interview. Ich würd's mal eher ein Interview nennen, was im Rahmen von Ted gelaufen ist, ist nicht wirklich ein TED Talk, sondern es ist irgendwie TED macht jetzt auch Interviews, keine Ahnung, machen alles mögliche. Sehr interessantes Gespräch.
Mit das ist ein Israelischer Historiker.
Der ähm sehr ausführlich und interessant den ganzen Kontext der russischen Invasion und auch die äh Geschichte der Ukraine, des Widerstands ähm,
erzählt hat und äh Bedrohung vor Nuklearmkrieg et cetera und ähm.
Seine, seine Perspektive auf den Krieg, alles sehr interessant an sich, also meine Empfehlung, äh fuffzig Minuten
Sehr interessant fand ich, was er zwischendurch dann eben über Deutschland gesagt hat, das passt jetzt hier irgendwie ganz gut. Und zwar war das so im Kontext der ganzen Geschichte mit, wie geht man denn überhaupt mit Geschichte und geschichtlicher Verpflichtung um?
Und er meint dann so, na ja es ist halt einfach der Blick auf die Geschichte, kann einfach auch.
Problem sein, denn äh er meint dann auch in Israel leiden wir auch da von wir leiden auch unter zu viel.
Geschichte, alles ist von Geschichte gebunden.
Und er meint, Leute sollten sich einfach auch befreien von der äh Vergangenheit und sich nicht damit aufhalten, diese Geschichte die ganze Zeit immer wieder auch zu wiederholen und dabei irgendwie keinen Schritt äh.
Voranzukommen, sodass man sich auch von den Erinnerungen des Zweiten Weltkriegs in gewisser Hinsicht trennen muss, um einfach den nächsten Schritt machen zu können. Man sieht das ja jetzt auch in Russland, wie,
ne, dieser ganze Nazigespenst, was,
Putin da aufzieht, das ist ja auch im Prinzip eine Weitererzählung eben dieses vaterländischen Kriegs und der Widerstand und wir haben ja die Nazis besiegt und das wird dann jetzt eben einfach verwendet, um dann eben diese erfundenen Geschichten über die Ukraine äh.
Aufzieht. So ja jetzt sind die Nazis wieder da, jetzt müssen wir da zuschlagen und alle alle glauben es sind alle sind so verfangen auch an diesen dieser äh nicht enden wollenden geschichtlichen äh Erzählungen. Er meinte aber das das gilt halt für die Russen, aber es gilt auch für die Deutschen.
Und wenn der halt auf Deutschland äh schaut, so dann meint er dann auch so, ja wenn mir irgendein Deutscher zuhört irgendwie jetzt gerade irgendwie so, hört mal zu so, äh möchte ich euch sagen so äh Leute.
Wissen, dass ihr keine Nazis seid. Ihr müsst es nicht die ganze Zeit immer wieder beweisen irgendwie so, was was was wir jetzt von Deutschland brauchen, ist irgendwie, dass ihr jetzt äh aufsteht und einfach mal anfangt äh zu führen,
Einfach äh hier äh den Freiheitskampf einfach auch anleiten müssen, euch nicht die ganze Zeit hinter eurer eigenen Geschichte verstecken sollt so und ähm.
Ihr habt immer Angst, so wenn wenn ihr laut redet oder irgendwie eine Waffe in die Hand nimmt, dass jeder sagt so, äh oh, jetzt hat er die jetzt seid ihr wieder die Nazis so und dann meinst du und so, nein, wir wir werden das nicht denken.
Fand es sehr interessanter Blick von außen, weil das ist ja jetzt auch keine Erzählung, die man jetzt als Deutscher aufnehmen würde.
Ja, du kannst ja nicht nicht sagen so hey, kein Problem, irgendwie äh wir greifen da jetzt äh ein in den Konflikt und dann dann wird schon jeder geil finden.
Kannst du halt irgendwie nicht bringen und die Dinge äh ändern sich schon.
Ja ja, ich habe ich habe das ja im persönlichen Leib erlebt. Äh ich hatte immer einen etwas anderen
Blick auf die deutsche Geschichte so. Ich ähm ja so ich ich war halt.
Aber auch deswegen bei der Bundeswehr
So habe ich ja auch auch schon mal erzählt als als Fallschirmjäger und ich musste mir da eine ganze Menge auch aus meinem Freundes-und äh vor allen Dingen aus meinem Freundeskreis
anhören, wieso ich nicht verweigert äh habe und äh wie ich denn überhaupt und mit äh irgendwie einmal bin ich dann sogar aus
Protest dann in Uniform auf einen Geburtstag gegangen. Das war dann überhaupt der der der Skandal. Da war ich dann auch erstmal fast der der Nazi und Melitarrist und und Kriegstreiber.
Ähm ja äh und ich habe
aber immer so sagt bei meiner Lebenserfahrung halt andere waren so mit äh ja 68 Invasionen und dann äh so einer meiner Großväter.
Glaube ich auch im letzten Podcast schon äh äh schon erwähnt,
äh so ist halt am letzten Kriegstag im Aufstand von Prag, von SS Truppen.
Erschossen worden, die halt sich nicht an den Waffenstillstand gehandelt äh ähm gehalten haben und dann auch Teile der Bevölkerung
äh als Geiseln, als menschliche Schutzschilde genommen haben so
Und äh ja der andere Großvater ist dann am äh nächsten Tag äh wiederum von russischen Truppen gefangen worden, weil er halt der deutschsprachigen Minderheit äh
Angehörte und deswegen als Wehrpflichtiger in der Wehrmacht war.
So. Beide waren irgendwie nie in Deutschland geboren, aber der ist dann erstmal zwei Jahre im Kriegsgefangenenlager äh verschwunden. So ja also,
Teile äh meiner Vorfahren hatten dann zwischendurch ganz schön die Arschkarte gezogen und irgendwie zwischen äh ja Russen und
äh Deutschen so äh dann ja.
Sagen zerrieben worden, aber aber hatten dann halt keinen Spaß und das erinnert mich dann schon jetzt auch an die Ukrainer, die jetzt grade zwischen eigentlich Russland und der NATO äh äh gerade irgendwo des des dasselbe
erleben oder oder erlebt haben.
Also Deutschland ist auf jeden Fall ähm.
Im Konflikt mit sich und im Konflikt mit dem Konflikt und äh ich habe so den Eindruck, dass das schon auch äh transformativ sein wird. Ich habe bloß noch keine Ahnung, wohin uns das transformiert.
Er kann er kann Deutschland reiten, wird Deutschland reiten so wird es in den Sattel kommen, äh so.
Wir sind jetzt, glaube ich, schon in den Sattel gesetzt worden und jetzt äh wird sich zeigen, ob Otto Recht hatte oder nicht.
Ja ja gut äh es ja.
Gut. Wir müssen jetzt aber auch noch mal über Putin äh sprechen.
Weil diese absurde Situation da in dem Stadion, das wisst ihr ja sicherlich auch mitbekommen haben, es gab da so einen Propaganda äh Treffen, wo er.
Wo Leute zusammengetrommelt wurden muss man auch sagen, es gab ja eine ganz interessante Bericht. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das gesehen hast von ähm Fernsehteams, die dann äh.
Vor dem Stadion mit Leuten gesprochen haben. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob bevor sie reingegangen sind oder ob sie wieder rausgekommen sind.
Und die gefragt haben, wo sie denn so herkommen und warum sie denn da so sind.
Auf auf der Propaganda-Veranstaltung, wo Putin halt rumstand und irgendwie halt wir seinen ganzen Sermon von äh den Azifizierungen äh der Ukraine und alles läuft super und äh toll und Z und die ganze Veranstaltung war einfach sowas von aus dem Playbook
äh von von von den von den Nazis ist einfach äh unfassbar die die Parallelen.
Und die Leute, es war ganz interessant. Die ganz viele Leute wollten überhaupt nicht mit denen reden. Die sind einfach weggelaufen.
Merkt das so richtig, denen war das so peinlich. Weil was da nämlich passiert ist, ist, das sind alles Leute, die im Staatsapparat arbeiten, die.
Auch dich aus Moskau waren, sondern die aus irgendwelchen vorgelagerten Städten teilweise relativ weit weg äh rangekarrt wurden, denen vorher auch überhaupt nicht gesagt wurden, woran sie teilnehmen, sondern es war nur so, hier du arbeitest hier.
Sagt, Veranstaltung, Event, was auch immer, Konzert oder so, unterschiedlich.
Erzählt worden und dann sind die halt irgendwie alle in Bus weil
Hat gesagt, alle müssen in Bus und sind da hingekarrt worden, sind dann vor diesem Stadion ausgespuckt worden und wussten dann erst vor Ort, dass es hier sich hier um so eine Propaganda-Veranstaltung mit Putin handelt.
Und na ja, was dann halt irgendwie äh passiert ist und vielen war das wohl sehr peinlich.
Einfach nur genau erst mal diese diese Fakten so erzählt. Ah, merkt ihr so, es gab kaum welche, die wirklich.
Da waren wegen dieses Events ja und deswegen dort ähm mit Begeisterung die Sache unterstützen.
Ja
Wobei sie so so eine Konzertnummern.
Hat Putin auch schon früher eingesetzt, umso von Oppositionsveranstaltungen äh abzulenken und den Zulauf ähm.
So zu reduzieren. Ähm das war so im letzten äh Wahlkampf äh glaube ich oder ähm ja ähm.
Und da fühlten sich dann auch einige Musiker dann etwas missbraucht, als sie das mit äh kriegten äh dass äh da eine Konzert veranstaltet
wird nicht zehn, 20 Kilometer Entfernung von wo die Protestveranstaltungen äh waren, aber andere sagten auch, wieso ist doch nett. Man kann ja irgendwie auch protestieren und dann äh Musik äh und so und warum nicht, aber andere.
Ja äh waren waren da waren da nicht so nicht so begeistert. Insofern passt das
auch so ein bisschen da rein, dass vielleicht viele gar nicht wussten und dann einfach nur gesagt kriegten, ja hier äh schönes irgendwie Musikprogramm, haben bestimmt auch Musik gespielt dann hinterher noch oder?
Ja nee und er ja also wenn man sich das das wirklich anguckt, ich meine
Putin ist ideologisch jetzt kein äh Nazi, weil er ist jetzt kein Rassist
aber eben 'nen Ethnozentrist so und Nationalist. Äh also ist ja eher ein fasches ideologisch äh gesehen, aber bedient sich eben äh ja ähm
aus aus genau dem Playbook äh und ähm äh Populismus ähm ganz vorne und ja auch die DZ-Nummer,
ähm mit den Symbolen und ähm so.
Also ich habe mich dann gefragt, okay wann wann wurden denn das letzte Mal so ähm
auf Militärfahrzeugen Symbole verwendet, die dann außerdem Zivilisten dann noch an ihrer auf ihrer Kleidung getragen haben und äh Truppen
äh auf ihrer äh Kleidung getragen haben und da fiel mir tatsächlich eigentlich auch nur das Hakenkreuz äh
äh so, wobei selbst da habe ich habe ich dann dann geguckt ähm hatte die Wehrmacht, hatte zwar Hakenkreuze dann so klein an ähm äh am
Koppel, also eine eine Gürtelschnalle und so an manchen Abzeichen.
Aber nicht auf Fahrzeugen. Äh ja, das hatte nur die SS hatte wiederum Hakenkreuz äh äh und na ja
ja also äh insofern ja werfen sich jetzt alle gegenseitig äh vor Nazis äh zu sein
ähm der äh wiederum umgekehrt der der russische Verteidigungsmist hatte vor einiger Zeit auch mal wieder um den Engländern vorgeworfen äh,
Nazis äh zu sein. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie das mitgekriegt hattest, weil sie angeblich Wehrübungen veranstaltet haben, wo.
Wiederum die gegnerischen Truppen, also die Roten wohl angeblich mit russischen Uniformen und russischen
Waffen und Panzern äh geübt hätten und das hätten auch zuletzt nur die Nazis äh äh getan, ja und ähm mittlerweile muss man wahrscheinlich sagen einfach ähm so Nazi has jump the Shark
so
Aber so was von und irgendwie ja.
Weil mittlerweile und das das hat
einfach, glaube ich, dann auch was mit einfach eine viel zu liberalen oder äh ja sorglosen Verwendung des des des Nazibegriffs gerade auch von linker Seite äh.
Glaube ich, äh aber nicht nur das, sondern sondern allgemein, ja, es ist der der Nazibegriff einfach jetzt äh taugt nicht mehr für eine für eine wirkliche.
Debatte oder es ist halt komplett entwertet.
Ja aber in Russland leider äh äh noch nicht. Ich meine, was schlechte Vergleiche betrifft ist natürlich auch Boris Johnson ganz weit äh vorne. Ich weiß nicht, ob du's äh mitbekommen hast, wie er verglichen hat, dass ja irgendwie der Kampf der äh Ukraine,
ähm der Freiheitskampf der Ukraine gegen Russland, dass das wäre ja im Prinzip so wie Brexit.
Also womit er sozusagen dann auch schon so im im äh ja im Bereich der schlechten Putinvergleiche gelandet ist.
Genau.
Ja also EU ist da sozusagen so wie Russland oder was so ja.
Genau glaube ich wiederum nur bemerkt ja die Freiheit ist sein Luxus den sich nicht jedermann gestatten kann. Ähm.
Ja. Na ja.
Na gut, dann lassen Sie mal zum Schluss äh ein bisschen noch in die Zukunft schauen, soweit das möglich ist. Was machen wir jetzt?
Ja, ja ich ich denke, wir sind zwar schon jetzt lange und tief drinnen. Eigentlich wollten wir ja heute eine besonders eigentlich eine kurze Sendung,
machen, weil wir so besonders gut vorbereitet sind, aber ich wir wir ich würde sagen, wir wir ziehen das jetzt einfach
durch. Wir wir ziehen's durch. Es gibt ja Kapitelmarken und sonst kannst du vielleicht auch fünf Sendungen draus machen oder so, aber ich würde sagen.
Es gibt Kapitelmagen ist die korrekte Antwort.
Ja so also kannst du noch? Okay gut ja.
Erstmal ganz konkret.
Ein paar äh Dinge so, NATO, was sollten wir tun und äh was sollten wir.
Lassen äh bevor äh sagen wir dann zwei Plots äh entwickeln oder die ich schon mal entwickelt habe ähm wie es denn dann.
Etwas detaillierter weiterlaufen könnte, aber ähm ich denke aus der, sagen wir mal, militärischen und politischen
Lage, äh wie wir sie ja besprochen haben, äh denke ich, sollte klar sein, dass wir
alles lassen sollten, was dazu führt, dass NATO und Russland äh in der Luft oder auf See oder sonst wo direkt aufeinander schießen.
Weil äh in dem Moment, wo das direkte Schießen aufeinander äh losgeht.
So die NATO ist einfach viel stärker und dann ist Russland plötzlich das Opfer. Äh Putin ist
legitimiert und insbesondere so trockenverbände in die Ukraine schicken. Ich glaube, das ist, was Putin jetzt gerne hätte oder oder bald gerne hätte und äh sich überlegt gerade, wir
äh das den äh Kriegen äh soll und das.
Und dass wir eben keine Truppen schicken und keine direkte Konfrontation wagen. So ist nicht, weil wir irgendwie etwa Angst davor hätten, äh sondern weil die NATO eben,
einfach so so viel konventionell stärker ist, äh dass äh ja, dass das.
Einfach dann.
Alles rechtfertigen würde, aber wirklich gewinnen äh können kann die NATO das auch nicht trotz dieser Übermacht, weil natürlich Atomwaffen im im Spiel sind und insofern ist das ein ein Weg, der ähm,
ja nur äh äh Putin in eine bessere Situation bringt. Der
dafür sorgt, dass äh dann auch die Einigkeit in der Welt und in dem im Westen äh zerfallen äh würde, dass äh ja Putin, dass andere Länder, die so jetzt.
Grade sehen, okay Putin ist der klare Aggressor. Äh die würden dann eher sich äh wieder vielleicht auf Russlands Seite schlagen und äh äh Dinge aufweichen. Also ähm,
Ja äh also im Moment äh auf jeden Fall äh so alles lassen, was irgendwie.
Äh direktes Aufeinander äh Schießen bedeuten
würde, aber man muss sagen, das muss jetzt nicht für alle Zeit gelten so, sondern ähm es kann
tatsächlich einfach die Situation plötzlich kommen, dass es Not entweder notwendig wird, reinzugehen oder es keinen Unterschied mehr macht, ob man äh reingeht
oder nicht und ähm die andere Sache ist, dass man auch gerne in die Situation vielleicht kommen möchte, wo man mit dem
Einsatz von NATO-Truppen gegen Russland drohen kann. Ich meine, das tun wir jetzt schon unter Artikel fünf so. Aber ähm.
Es äh könnte sein, dass wir andere rote Linien
beziehen wollen, vielleicht so nicht nur unter Artikel fünf, sondern zum Beispiel dann explizit vielleicht Schweden oder Finnland äh mit
einbeziehen wollen, auch wenn sie keine Mitglieder sind, aber dann ganz klar vielleicht sagen, dass äh auch das jetzt,
den Verteidigungsfall auslösen würde oder andere Dinge, was weiß ich, wenn äh die humanitäre Situation sich so entwickelt, dass man sagt okay, wenn ihr jetzt,
und die Linie überschreitet so, dann ist ist auch Schluss. So, aber.
Dann müsste man halt die Drohung auch wahrmachen, beziehungsweise die Drohungen müssen auch glaubhaft sein, also.
Ich meine, das haben wir ja im Prinzip jetzt schon so mit den mit der Diskussion um chemische äh Waffen und Biowaffen, ne.
Und da droht's ja ohnehin, wenn man sich so die russische Propaganda anschaut, die in der letzten Zeit ja nicht stillsteht, um zu behaupten, dass die Ukrainer ja irgendwie biologische Waffen haben.
Ja viele, dass das auch schon die propagandistische Vorbereitung darauf ist, dass wenn die Russen das dann einsetzen, das ist sofort der Ukraine in die Schuhe schieben und die russische Bevölkerung sagt so, erdest
haben wir ja gleich gesagt. So, jetzt seht ihr das ja.
Genau, zumal äh das aus früheren Kriegsgebieten auch in Syrien oder anderswo bekannt ist, dass es eben auch die die Horrorvorstellung so ein bisschen, dass die Russen, auch wenn sie jetzt eben auch mit zerbomben nicht weiterkommen, dass sie dann
anfangen eben mit chemischen Waffen äh versuchen dann ähm ja die Menschen einfach umzubringen, die.
Die sich dann äh ja in in Stellungen in den Ruinen befinden, so oder eben dann auch eine humanitäre Kapitulation.
Zu zu erzwingen und deswegen ist es auch ganz wichtig, äh dass das Verein eine ganz gute Strategie auch von den USA
eben genau all diese Dinge, all diese Erkenntnisse sagen auch vorher zu sagen, okay äh Russland, ihr habt das und das vor. Wir haben euch schon mal gesehen, wie ihr das gemacht habt und wenn ihr das tut,
nicht, ja.
Deswegen ja alle alle Truppen mobilisieren und zusammenziehen, um irgendwie glaubhaft abschrecken zu können, um ein Drohpotential haben zu können und weil es unvermeidlich sein könnte, aber,
eben auch ganz klar,
Wenn es zu dem Punkt kommt, so dann ist das schlecht für uns, dann ist das nicht gut und nicht weil wir dann auch Opfer zu beklagen haben, sondern weil das Putin politisch in die Hände spielen würde.
Ähm ansonsten euch noch äh würde ich.
Alles an Waffen liefern. Ich würde da jetzt auch äh.
Wenn's sein muss auch ja oder was heißt sein muss, ich würde auch Flugzeuge und Artillerie und Panzer und schwere Kampfdrohnen äh eigentlich ich würde.
Alles. Ich ich würde von mir aus würde ich der Ukraine sogar U-Boote.
Äh liefern, ja, wenn wenn sie welche gebrauchen, äh kann, weil ich glaube nämlich nicht, dass Waffenlieferungen jetzt irgendeinen äh großen Unterschied,
machen und die Ukraine braucht das so. Ähm das ist ist wichtig und ich glaube an irgendeinem Punkt wird's auch dazu kommen und vielleicht passiert es auch.
Aber äh ja, ich würde bei Waffenlieferungen mir keine Gedanken darüber machen, was Putin denkt oder oder wie er das sieht, weil das macht jetzt aus meiner Sicht,
null Unterschied, null Unterschied.
Sollen die Ukraine jetzt eine U-Boot-Besatzung herkriegen?
Na ähm ich meine das Problem ähm wie man das löst, äh hatten die USA und äh Russland in den letzten zehn Jahren
gezeigt, das nennt sich halt Outsourcing, äh ja, in Afghanistan und Irak haben dann auch mehr seltener gekämpft und
die Russen haben wiederum die Wagner Group in Libyen und in Syrien äh wo die halt auch mit Kampfflugzeugen durch die Gegend, also es gibt halt Söldner,
mit Kampfflugzeugen, beziehungsweise du kannst dir halt, ja, Söldner, für alle, ja, ja, die, die, die Wagner Group äh so fliegt,
äh Kampfflugzeuge mit 29 Jets äh und so. Also da gibt's jetzt keine Grenzen und warum äh sollte jetzt nicht die,
Ukraine äh ja äh sich auch äh entsprechender privater Sicherheitsunternehmen äh bedienen, äh die,
dann äh ja, nicht nur Waffen, sondern auch die notwendigen ausgebildeten Besatzungen äh dafür zur Verfügung stellen für keine Ahnung. Hm? Ja?
Nicht, also ich habe ja, ich habe jetzt noch nicht ich weiß, U-Boot ist jetzt wirklich ein bisschen äh äh nur so sagen.
Bisschen over the top äh ja, aber.
Auch meinen, aber okay, gut, äh ich verstehe deinen Punkt, hm.
Kampfpanzer äh und Kampfflugzeuge und Artillerie und Drohnen und all das äh ja ähm.
Das kannst du sagen auf dem freien Markt dir ja einkaufen so.
Ja und ja wie gesagt ja fehlt nur noch okay U-Boote, Schlachtschiffe und Flugzeugträger sind halt jetzt noch nicht auf dem Markt aber.
Aber kann noch, kann noch kommen. Also es kann könnte jetzt auch niemand äh jetzt den Westen,
daran hindern, ein neues privates Sicherheitsunternehmen äh zu gründen und was ich hier die ganzen großen Internetkonzerne könnten sich locker irgendwie einen einen Sicherheitsunternehmen,
was irgendwie mit fünf Flugzeugträgern oder so sind ja fit, also weiß ich nicht, dreißig, 40 Milliarden.
So ein paar hundert Milliarden kannst du da schon ordentliches Sicherheitsunternehmen mit Flugzeugträgern und so aufbauen
Ich der Trend geht dahin, ne? Ähm also noch sind wir nicht da. Ich hoffe allerdings äh tatsächlich
dass das Umgekehrte passieren wird nach dem Krieg, nämlich dass endlich ähm sagen auch diesen Sicherheitsunternehmen diesen großen Söldner Firmen
eigentlich eher das Handwerk gelegt wird. Da gibt's ja das
Montroe-Abkommen, aber das funktioniert so richtig nicht und der eigentliche Punkt ist, dass dieses Gewalt Outsourcing natürlich äh.
Ja Krieg wahrscheinlicher macht und Kriegsverbrechen wahrscheinlicher macht, weil weniger Kontrolle und weniger Widerstand zu Hause brauchst eigentlich nur Geld und äh.
Ansonsten war's das und so
also so das das kann können Staaten nicht außer Kontrolle laufen lassen oder die Weltgemeinschaft, dass der dass die Reichen sich da einfach Kriege kaufen können. Da müssen wir müssen wir weg von.
Ja amerikanische Flugzeugträger, ich habe grad mal geguckt, wo die eigentlich so sind. Und ähm.
Es gibt nur einen, der derzeit sich in Europa befindet, also einer ist an der Pazifik äh also vor weiß nicht, Los Angeles oder so, einer ist vor
New York. Dann ist äh der Harry Astronan,
Flugzeugträger, der befindet sich irgendwo bei Sizilien im Mittelmeer.
Und dann gibt's noch drei, die sind alle so bei Japan und so.
Ja, eher Flugzeugträger braucht's natürlich auch vor allem, wenn du in der Nähe keine Militärbasen äh hast. Äh so und,
in Europa äh haben wir natürlich genug Militärbasen und.
Flugzeuge und Flugplätze und so, dass äh ja ähm müsste jetzt eher gucken ähm wo jetzt einzelne Einheiten jetzt grade äh.
Hin verlegt wurden ja Estland, Lettland, Litauen äh Dänemark.
Polen, andere NATO-Länder.
Na gut, lass mal ein bisschen mehr auf die Zukunftsszenarien
äh kommen. Also Söldner könnte man mit reinnehmen. Ist natürlich so ein bisschen macht keinen guten Ruf irgendwie. Die benehmen sich ja in der Regel jetzt auch nicht so geil so. Die sind ja dann auch im Irak irgendwie vor allem äh für Kriegsverbrechen dann auch bekannt geworden.
Auf der anderen Seite, ja es ist das immer so ein so ein so ein Ding, ich meine es gibt nunmal keinen sauberen Krieg und Kriegsverbrechen passieren auf allen Seiten und nicht, dass man das jetzt verharmlosen oder
dem entgegenreden sollte, aber ich finde so einen Krieg zur Verteidigung der Heimat von einem Aggressor ist nun mal gutes Recht und es ist auch der einzige,
Krieg.
Der nicht erlaubnispflichtig ist. Also ansonsten darfst du noch Krieg führen mit Erlaubnis der UN so, also mit UN-Mandat, äh aber äh äh verteidigen darfst du dich auch ohne UN-Mandat, ja.
Äh äh aber alles andere ist halt ist halt verboten und auf der anderen Seite sind wir jetzt nun mal mitten äh drin oder die Ukraine, die Ukraine ist mittendrin und hm ja,
Ehrlich gesagt ja,
fallen mir jetzt, also wäre mir Bomben auf den Kopf fallen würden, so, dann äh ja.
Würden ja auch die absurdesten Ideen kommen, ja.
Ja dann würde ich auch seltener mit U-Booten Schlachtschiffen und Flugzeugträgern anheuern, wenn ich das könnte.
So. Ja äh gut zu den Szenarien. Okay, also die sind jetzt ja überwiegend auf meinem Mist,
äh gewachsen, aber auch auf Basis von den vielen, was wir hier hier äh diskutiert haben und ich habe mir für diese zwei Szenarien habe ich mir so ein paar Prämissen gemacht, weil es kann natürlich alles mögliche passieren.
Erstmal mir gesagt, okay.
Keine Überraschungen, die jetzt alles auf den Kopf stellen kann. Deosex-Machinga äh oder äh keine unvorstellbaren Dinge wie zum Beispiel,
dass jemand auftaucht und.
Ähm ja, alles auf den Kopf stellt. Also das äh passiert jetzt nicht äh noch wieder in den in den äh weil das sind einfach unvorhersehbare oder super unwahrscheinliche,
Dinge so und die werden wahrscheinlich passieren oder können passieren, aber die kann man in Szenarien nicht wirklich also die machen dann Szenarien einfach absurd,
Dachte ich mir, okay, das muss mir realistisch erscheinen und muss irgendwie in der Macht der jeweiligen
Akteure sein und muss auch im Charakter mit den jeweiligen Akteuren sein.
Und es ist also mehr als dann irgendwie nur einen Adachter Plot mit mit Fantasie.
Und was mir dann aufgefallen ist, im Nachhinein, dass ich gar nicht so viel Fantasie entwickelt habe, sondern dass es
auch unglaublich viele historische Präzedenzfälle gibt, die ich da eingebaut habe, ähm,
fast fast unbewusst so.
Und beiden Szenarien, so ich mir überlegt habe quasi obere und untere Fehlerkurve, wenn man so will, einmal in Best Case für Putin und einmal einen best case für die Welt.
Und beide laufen erstmal eine Zeit lang gleich. Da gibt es erstmal keinen Unterschied und.
Insofern kann man diesen Teil jetzt auch nehmen als jetzt so bisschen Prognose, ähm die so oder so kommen
wird die einfach
nichts mit Zufall zu tun hat, sondern da stehen sich halt zwei Armeen gegenüber und da gibt's bestimmte Gesetzmäßigkeiten und äh da passieren Dinge und wir sehen das jetzt seit
vier Wochen und können deswegen jetzt mal eine gewisse Extrapolation.
Vornehmen. Ja und wir haben ja schon gesagt, der Krieg wird sich erst mal weiter festfahren, so dass das sehen wir ja auch an dass dass das passiert ist,
So und wird halt mehr zu einem Stellungskrieg äh werden oder mit Bewegung hier, Bewegung da, aber äh generell so die Dynamik, also kein,
kein es ist kein Blitzkrieg mehr so. Ja,
aber äh was wir dann auch sehen werden, glaube ich, mehr Einsätze von Spezialtruppen hinter den jeweils feindlichen Linien oder vor vor der Front oder wie auch,
immer. Das wird wird glaube ich unschön werden, so Sabotageeinsätze und äh andere Dinge. Ja und.
Ähm Kampf über die Luft,
Überlegenheit wird halt mit weiter mit einer relativ geringen Zahl von von Einsätzen weitergehen. Beide Seiten werden sich nicht so richtig massiv in den Luftraum
über der Ukraine hin äh reintrauen und so schnell wird auch keine Seite jetzt Lufthoheit
bekommen äh und in der Lage sein, die Luftabwehr des anderen und auszuschalten und die Luftwaffe des anderen und so
Ja und dann, was wir auch gesehen haben vorhin schon, Russland wird weiter mehr Bahnlinien instand setzen, mehr Pipelines verlegen. Insgesamt die Versorgung verbessern, mehr Truppen und Material ranschaffen. Und dabei wird.
Aber äh sich sich rausstellen, dass es eben äh weiter Versorgungs
Engpässe gibt oder neue entstehen an allen möglichen Stellen, dass es eben an Nachschubgerät Ersatzteilen, Betriebsstoffen und an Personalmangeln wird, den Kram zu reparieren. So das ist glaube ich auch,
dass da jetzt nicht plötzlich irgendwo ähm ja die die nagelneuen äh.
Kriegsgeräte vom Band laufen und und alles jetzt jetzt anfängt zu schnurren, sondern ich glaube im Gegenteil und das wird natürlich auch die Moral der russischen Truppen nicht verbessern, die,
schon auch als Sklavenarmee äh bezeichnet äh werden, ganz so schlimm ist nicht, aber viele sind da nicht wirklich freiwillig oder aus Begeisterung äh so oder aus ja.
Wussten vor allem überhaupt nicht, dass sie in einen Krieg ziehen.
Ja, ja, ja, und äh die hohen Verluste äh werden.
Weiter äh gehen, ja? Es wird wird weiter sehr sehr äh blutig äh werden leider für beide Seiten so auch zivilbevölkerung.
Wird sich der Trend fortsetzen, dass die Russen eben weiter brutaler kämpfen werden, was man.
Nicht notwendigerweise auf Befehl von von oben oder weil man das sozusagen von oben gerne so hätte, sondern weil sie nicht anders können. So und ähm.
Weil äh ja.
Sie eben ja äh nicht gut genug sind, um es äh präziser äh zu machen oder oder so zu machen, dass es mit weniger äh Opfern äh geht.
Sie haben auch einfach die Mittel äh überhaupt nicht dazu, also ihre ihre Waffen sind halt einfach auch so aufgestellt. Raketenwerfer, 30 Kilometer Abstand, irgendwie, da wird nicht groß gezielt. Ja, wir haben vorhin schon die Situation im Luftkampf
besprochen, warum es auch da an Präzision fehlt, weil sie halt einfach die die Munition dafür einfach überhaupt
äh haben. Das Ganze natürlich aber auch gepaart mit einem Auftrag mit äh ist uns eigentlich auch scheißegal, macht einfach.
Ja, also beziehungsweise Druck eben auch haben wir auch gesehen, dass dann Generäle nach vorne geschickt wurden, die dann auch die Truppe jetzt motivieren und anpeitschen äh sollten, von denen jetzt glaube ich aber auch dann fünf getötet äh wurden an der an.
War schon bei fünf. Ich habe nur noch vier im Kopf.
Ja ja, ja. Also ich habe habe von Fünfen äh gehört, aber gut.
Sie haben glaube ich jetzt im Süden bei ähm äh dem Überfall des Flughafens, den ich vorhin erwähnt hatte, da haben sie wohl noch mal irgendwie einen weggesnipert.
So, das heißt ähm es wird einfach.
Dann auch irgendwann materiell eng äh werden, weil das wird wohl erstmal weniger der Sektionen äh geben, weil sich auch,
die Fronten so ein bisschen verhärten, weil man dann länger mit den.
Kameraden im Einsatz ist und sich dann irgendwie dran gewöhnt, aber äh trotzdem äh wird's halt weiter hohe Ausfälle äh geben.
Ja werden viele getötet, verwundet werden oder einfach Erschöpfung äh auch. Du kannst halt äh auch nicht ewig da irgendwo
im im Kampf äh bleiben und vor allen Dingen ja so als frustrierter Sklave
sage ich mal, ist dann die Motivation auch nicht so hoch, beziehungsweise die Versuchung
auch dann durch durch eine Verwundung oder durch auch Sabotage äh des des eigenen Materials oder wie auch immer irgendwie aus der Situation dann dann rauszukommen so.
Und ähm bisher.
Ist es so, dass das äh Putin jetzt noch keine allgemeine Mobilmachung der Reservisten angeordnet äh.
Hat, äh aber er wird irgendwann an dem Punkt kommen, wo es einfach so eng wird, dass er jetzt nicht sagen kann.
Ähm also dass er nicht mehr drum rumkommt, dass er jetzt irgendwie jetzt richtig,
Krieg machen muss und richtig das Land jetzt quasi zum Krieg aufrufen und sagen muss, wir machen jetzt hier Kriegswirtschaft, wir sind im wir sind im Krieg, wir kämpfen jetzt um unsere Existenz.
Das ist aber natürlich
sagen wir mal und sagt okay und das ist deswegen, weil unsere Spezialoperation in der Ukraine auseinanderfällt äh so, das wäre natürlich eine Peinlichkeit äh ohnegleichen und da würden die Leute natürlich auch nicht mit
gehen, sondern ähm da muss eigentlich Putin jetzt versuchen und das wird er versuchen, denn die NATO eben zu provozieren. Äh und äh,
eben dann zu Hause zu sagen, ich würde nicht um dann zu sagen, ist nicht wegen der Ukraine, sondern halt weil die NATO uns jetzt,
greift grade. So und das wird er versuchen äh das deswegen durch sagt auch
dann weiter brutale Angriffe auf die Zivilbevölkerung, vielleicht Einrichtung von Konzentrationslagern, dann Terrorakte und Sabotage so,
oder.
Von ihm kennen, fingierte Terrorakte in Russland, so weil das wäre ja für ihn ungefährlicher äh so äh und er hat ja damals auch schon äh damit ja gewählt wird,
halt äh diese ähm ja tschetschenischen Attentate auf russische Wohnblocks rund um Moskau fingiert, davon bin ich mittlerweile absolut überzeugt.
Dass er das war und wird eben auch durch den Einsatz von chemischen Waffen bis hin vielleicht sogar, was ich nicht hoffe, aber es ist auch nicht ausgeschlossen, dass er taktische Atom äh Waffen.
Einsetzt wenn die NATO nicht nicht will so aber.
Ich glaube erstmal, viele der Versuche werden nicht so laufen, äh wie er sich das vorstellt, so oder so und er ist quasi auch beschränkt.
So einen feinen Grab zu wandern, wo es eben nicht zu direkten Gefechten zwischen Nato und russischen Truppen kommt, aber,
fast so, aber fast so. Also diesen diesen Grad, aber dass die NATO trotzdem.
Was tut und tun muss, was aber ja eben nicht zum dritten Weltkrieg äh führt und,
Ähm im ersten Szenario, also sozusagen in beiden Szenarien äh wird es halt an den Punkt kommen, wo Putin irgendwas versuchen wird und versuchen wird, die NATO.
Rein äh zu ziehen. So und im Ersten sagen für Putin positiven Szenario schafft das jetzt erfolgreich die Mobimachung zu rechtfertigen in dem NATO-Truppen.
In die Ukraine gezogen werden und er dann sagen kann, hier.
Seht ihr, die äh Nato ist in die Ukraine einmarschiert und äh deswegen müssen wir jetzt Generalmobil machen, weil äh übermorgen sind sie in Moskau ähm so,
Und äh ja, in Wirklichkeit aber weil er dann wahrscheinlich nicht in der Lage sein wird, äh wirklich diesen Krieg weiter zu zu kämpfen oder zu gewinnen, ähm.
Wird er dann ernsthaft um einen Waffenstillstand äh verhandeln und äh wird dann damit begründen können
sagen dauerhaft russische Truppen in der Ukraine zu lassen, weil da stehen ja auch schließlich auch NATO-Truppen jetzt in der Ukraine und ähm das Ergebnis könnte dann so ein bisschen sein, ja wie Ost und,
Deutschland, dass wir dass die Ukraine in Ost und West geteilt wird, in einen von der NATO und in einen von,
Russland besetzten Teil und wir dann einen neuen eingefrorenen Krieg haben mit einem Vulkan äh äh drunter.
Und äh Putin das aber alles zu Hause als erfolgreichen, heldenhaften Sieg äh verkaufen kann. Wie
er dann doch erfolgreich äh den den Angriff hm
der zehnfach überlegenen NATO äh Truppen, deren Feigenangriff, deren Vormarsch auf Russland in der Ukraine gestoppt hat und
ja setzt dann einen treuen Nachfolger ein und sich zur Ruhe und äh ja das,
äh wäre dann sagen das Beste, was was was Putin glaube ich rausholen könnte jetzt für für sich.
Mit einem besetzten Donbass und mit einer weiterhin besetzten Krim und vielleicht eben auch noch mit äh diesem Streifen am Asowschen Meer, was noch mit dazu gekommen ist.
Aber ohne ohne.
Und wie gesagt er würde das halt damit rechtfertigen dann die Truppenpräsenz mit der Truppenpräsenz der NATO. Ja wenn ihm das aber nicht gelingt.
Warte mal ähm du hast ja vorhin gesagt hier so äh Konzentrationslager einrichten.
Als mögliche äh Eskalationen ne. Es gibt ja jetzt Berichte über Entführung aus Maropol, dass Leute irgendwie dort äh eingesammelt wurden und nach Russland überführt wurden. Habe ich jetzt noch nicht so viel ähm.
Bestätigung dazu gelesen, aber das das ist sicherlich auch etwas, was so in diese Tendenz äh gehen kann jetzt sozusagen auch noch durch Entführung dieses Leid äh weiter zu steigern.
Plus. Das ist eine Plus natürlich dann Aufstandsbekämpfung.
Halt, ja, in den, in den Teilen jetzt, die da jetzt besetzt sind, äh so äh könnte es halt auch sein, dass sie irgendwann feststellen, ja, nee, wir müssten irgendwie
jetzt Teile der Bevölkerung äh einfach mal in Lager packen, äh um halt äh Ruhe herzustellen oder Ordnung herzustellen.
Gut, aber dann schauen wir jetzt da noch mal, ob's nicht vielleicht auch noch ein best case für äh the World gibt irgendwie, wo wir ein bisschen besser äh davon kommen.
Ne, genau, in den best case, wo wir auch keine keine Wunder brauchen, ja.
Ja äh wie gesagt, der würde erstmal ähnlich ablaufen äh bis zu dem Punkt äh wo es äh um die Frage der.
Generalmobilmachung äh in Russland geht und komplette äh ja Umstellung auf auf Krieg und Kriegswirtschaft und äh ja Ebenmobilisierung aller äh Reserven um.
Wirklich zugucken. So und ähm das Szenario,
läuft bis zu dem Punkt, wo sich dieses Problem stellt im Wesentlichen ähnlich ab, aber äh in dem.
Für uns positiven Szenario passieren zwei Dinge und für die Welt auch positiven Szenario, wie ich glaube.
Ist, dass der Krieg paradoxerweise mit höherer Intensität und Geschwindigkeit geführt wird.
Also mal, was man ja auch sieht, ist die Natolinder und allem voran die USA wirklich
voll aufdrehen und mit der zehnmal größeren Wirtschaft die Ukraine mit allem, was sie zur Kriegsführung braucht, wirklich Vollpumpen
und das gleichzeitig ja über einen Zeitraum von jetzt sechs Monaten oder so
Immer mehr Freiwillige in der Ukraine militärisch ausgebildet und bewaffnet äh werden. Die Organisation äh nochmal verbessert wird äh auch Kommunikationssysteme und so und das
ukrainische Militär könnte also in den nächsten sechs Monaten auf bis zu eine Million Soldaten anwachsen, glaube ich.
Zahlen dazu gibt's nicht. Das ist jetzt meine persönliche
wie gesagt, Schätzung, aber na, irgendwas zwischen fünfhundert, tausend und eine Million äh äh denke ich ist eine ist eine realistische Zahl, wo in einem positiven Szenario
man das herstellen könnte, also halte ich für realistisch und.
Oder im Mindestfall bleibt das ukrainische Militär halt gut organisiert, gut versorgt, hoch motiviert und wird eben schwer
bewaffnet und ausreichend bewaffnet in der Zeit. Die Russen werden natürlich auch nicht stillstehen und werden dann äh zu dem Zeitpunkt in sechs Monaten
ja 250.000 bis 400.000 Soldaten in der Ukraine im im Einsatz haben.
Und hm ja äh und dann.
Aber plötzlich dann äh die die Situation, die Ukraine tritt dann quasi mit einer zweifachen personellen Übermacht und mit
um einfach mehr mehr Waffen und mehr mehr mehr Reserven äh dann auf die russischen Soldaten, die,
Aber dann weiter durch Versorgungsmängel und Verschleiß und schlechte Moral. So weit geschwächt sind, dass sie einfach dem Ansturm
nicht gewachsen sind.
Und die russische Armee dann äh praktisch ja zurückweicht an den meisten Fronten und dass das Ganze eben so schnell verläuft und so katastrophal,
ist äh ja das das Putin irgendwie auch nichts tun kann äh so richtig und ähm dass die Ukraine,
Prinzip die Kontrolle über den Großteil des Landes äh wieder zurückgewinnt und
viele Kriegsgefangene macht und der Rest äh ja bis unter Zurücklassen äh Großteil äh.
Der der der Waffen und und allem einfach äh zusieht, äh dass sie irgendwie über die Grenze nach Russland kommen oder sich auf die Krim,
retten oder in die besser befestigten äh äh Gebiete und so.
Ja äh und wie gesagt, das geht eben alles so schnell, dass Putin halt keine Zeit bleibt oder es eben nicht schafft, seine Eskalationspläne äh äh.
Umzusetzen und äh er wird dann aber versuchen natürlich erstmal mit Säuberung und weiteren Einschüchterungen den Apparat unter Kontrolle zu halten, so wie das ist.
Aber so der Schock und die Scham in Russland von irgendwie diesem.
Ukrainern, die ja keine Russen sind, sondern äh ja eben Ukrainer und aus Sicht der Russen.
Äh kann und darf so was nicht sein, dass sie jetzt plötzlich von diesen Ukrainern dann dann geschlagen werden und sagen die und die Führungsschicht,
die ich so auf zwei oder drei Millionen schätze in in Russland. Das sind so diejenigen, die dazugehören äh.
Den Rest manipulieren und unterdrücken, aber und eigentlich die Macht äh in der Hand halten, dass diese zwei bis
drei Millionen, äh dass die dann eben auch so schockiert sind und so beschämt, dass sie dann erstmal durchsickern lassen äh durch die Propaganda, dass.
Ihre Kanäle das Putin einfach ist,
weil äh einen erfolglosen Angriffskrieg geführt hat, weil ja die vielleicht sogar die Krim oder zumindest Ostteile der Ukraine wieder verloren hat und halt Schande über das Land gebracht hat und Putin.
Wird das irgendwann merken, denn das seine Zeit gekommen ist, wenn das passiert so.
Und wird dann versuchen im Deal mit wem auch immer als Nachfolger zu machen, so wie äh Jelcin äh einen Deal mit ihm äh gemacht hat und äh äh,
irgendjemand sein, der halt äh mächtig loyal und skrupellos genug ist oder von dem Putin das glaubt,
eben den Deal auch einhalten kann, derjenige und ähm ja und auch dazu bereit ist so.
Aber in diesem positiven Szenario schafft das nicht, seinen Deal rechtzeitig einzufädeln und er leidet einen Herzinfarkt.
So ein abspannenden Landschaften haben, ne? Mhm.
Naja wir sind noch nicht längst nicht am Ende.
Das Szenario es geht ja dann geht's jetzt dann geht's überhaupt erst richtig richtig los, weil ähm ja dann ist ja erstmal ja hat Putin jetzt einen Herzinfarkt, aber
Äh er wird dann als Held Russlands feierlich beigesetzt und dann gibt's Präsidentschaftswahlen so zweitausendvierzehn.
Und bei den Präsidentschaftswahlen treten dann verschiedene durch Oligarchen unterstützte Kandidaten an, aber auch andere.
Auch Ultrarechte und Neopinisten und so, also wird dann eine etwas.
Neo Putin.
Unübersichtliche wird dann.
Wird dann halt äh so eine so eine so eine ziemlich unruhige Wahl und auch der Wahlausgang, wenn sich dann alle Kandidaten Wahlfälschung und Wahlmanipulation und Bestechung
vorwerfen und ja aber am Ende wird mehr schon gesagt haben äh wird dann
äh eine äh der kandidierenden Frauen äh gewinnen. So eine, die auch ein bisschen schon Regierungserfahrung hatte. Da gibt's.
Auch eine gibt's durchaus eine Auswahl, die sagen die ähm.
Ja die die Staatsoberhäupter jetzt der russischen Provinzen oder Federal Subjects äh wie sie heißen äh sind und äh ja wird gewählt also jemand der durchaus Regierungserfahrung hat
Und äh sie wird dann erstmal mit einem unlösbaren Berg von Problemen konfrontiert äh so natürlich alles im Chaos und alles ganz schlimm so,
aber sie erweist sich als hinreichend erfahren und korrupt und
ruchlos, dass sie halt jetzt genug Deals mit den anderen korrupten und ruchlosen Leuten in der Hierarchie macht und
um dann Säuberungen einzuleiten und ihre Leute an die Tröge der Macht zu bringen und wird dabei natürlich besonders Leute ins Visier nehmen, die für den verlorenen Krieg verantwortlich waren, schon mal okay wäre und sammelt damit halt auch
Punkte beim Westen, der dann seine Sanktionen teilweise aufhebt. Aber,
So, das reicht halt nicht. Russland versinkt dann weiter in der Wirtschaftskrise, dass sich Europa von den Energiebelieferungen weitgehend ab
genabelt hat oder auf dem Weg ist und die Kriegskosten.
Und die Investoren das Vertrauen verloren haben und versucht sich dann dem Westen anzunähern und setzt halt Reformen durch und schafft viele von Putins Gesetzen ab und ja vernachlässigt dabei aber ihre Machtbasis immer parat
als schwach befunden, machten einen Deal und tritt bei der nächsten Wahl nicht an. So sind dann wahrscheinlich irgendwo dann bei 2tausendachtundzwanzig oder so,
und äh ja nur ihr ausgemacht.
Soll das jetzt gut sein für die Welt, dass äh diese Person nicht es schafft, Stabilität hinzubekommen.
Äh das ist nicht das ist so ich habe ja gesagt ein realistisches Szenario, ja, eins, was keine Wunder
erfordert. Was jetzt nicht irgendwie plötzlich weiß ich nicht, den russischen Anführer, äh der da äh jetzt aus dem Volk äh äh
äh aufsteigt, was weiß ich, Nawalny und äh plötzlich jetzt alles wird gut, ja. Äh plötzlich setzt die große Demokratisierung,
ein, so alle und äh nee, so wird's nicht laufen. Wie gesagt, das war halt mein Problem. Ich wollte halt.
Ende finden, aber aber man muss ja realistisch bleiben, ja? Man muss ja realistisch bleiben so, deswegen ja so, also.
Sagt sie vernachlässigt ihre Machtbasis im Apparat, wird dann wieder als schwach befunden. Ja, ach so, genau und ihr Nachfolger verliert die Wahl. Aber
so verlieren ja nicht die Hoffnung und stattdessen ähm
gewinnt halt die Wahl ein bekannter Sportler und Buchautor und auch Schauspieler. Also sie hatte eine Autobiografie geschrieben.
Über seinen Kampf im Ukrainekrieg äh so und hat dann in der Serie auch mitgespielt äh die, in der das verfilmt worden ist, wo er dann sich selbst gespielt hat,
und ähm so und ähm so in der Serie, wie gesagt, in dem von ihm geschriebenen Buch äh wie setzt er sich dann.
Als Soldat so der, ich sage mal mittleren Hierarchie äh irgendwo als als Offizier ähm ja
mutig dann gegen korrupte Vorgesetzte und generelle ein und für seine Männer und gegen
eben die ganze Korruption und äh gegen all diese Misswirtschaft und gegen äh ja diesen Wahnsinn, diesen äh und rettet halt natürlich ganz vielen
seiner Männer und Kameraden des des Leben auch also helden heldenhaften äh äh Einsätzen und,
sieht aber natürlich ganz viele seiner Kameraden und besten Freunde auch sterben in den Krieg und schwört sich dann
äh dass diese nicht umsonst gestorben sind und dass ja alles dazu tun wird, äh dass sich äh so etwas nie wieder ereignet und
wenn er dafür Präsident werden.
So ungefähr.
Jetzt muss man aber schon mal irgendwie bei Hans Zimmer anrufen und dann den passenden Soundtrack aushandeln.
Ja, so.
Und äh ja und diese Serie wie gesagt äh ist dann halt auch so ein Erfolg in Russland gewesen, dass sie halt äh ihn tatsächlich dann, als er sich dann wirklich zur Wahl
äh äh stellt äh ja gewinnt gewinnt er die die Wahl.
Und äh ja natürlich finanziert wird das Ganze natürlich auch von einem Oligarchen, wer sonst sollte so einen so einen Quatsch auch finanzieren ähm so,
Und äh ja und äh wird dann eben auch gewählt und
am Tag nach seiner Wahl auf einmal als eines der ersten Gesetze, was er unterzeichnet ist, dass er eine private Sicherheitsgesellschaft
Ähm
autorisiert jetzt ungefähr 10.000 Angehörige der Machtelite zu verhaften und zu verhören und zufällig hat diese private Sicherheitsgesellschaft es ausgestattet mit Dossiers und Beweisen für wie alle möglichen
Taten und und und Verbrechen äh und so und äh ja Bismarck.
Das halt mal geheim irgendwie, ne? Bisschen mal.
Ja
Ja. Äh Solisa ist eine private Sicherheitsgesellschaft. Also woher die das haben, hm äh kann man jetzt darüber äh äh aber ja so.
Und Bismarck würde das wahrscheinlich auch gefallen, weil er hat nämlich auch mal gesagt, ich habe einen Lieblingsgedanken in Bezug auf Friedensschluss. Das ist ein internationales Gericht niederzusetzen, dass die.
Urteilen soll, die zum Kriege gehetzt,
haben ähm und zwar benennt er da konkret Zeitungsschreiber deputierte Senatoren Minister. Also,
er äh ja hätte da äh wie gesagt äh sagen schon ganz gerne damals vor 1500 Jahren noch bevor es überhaupt also er war der Zeit so ein bisschen voraus.
Absolut. Medien und Politik.
Ja, ja. So und äh na ja und äh jedenfalls mhm,
der neue äh russische Präsident und Kriegsheld äh ja,
macht dann also diese Säuberungs-äh Aktion, die offensichtlich gut vorbereitet war und Vermögen und Konten in Höhe von zig Milliarden werden beschlagnahmt. Gut eine ganze Menge davon verschwindet in dunklen Kanälen und
nur zwei Prozent der Verhafteten werden vor Gericht freigesprochen aber die meisten kommen dann doch nach kurzer Zeit frei oder werden amnistiert und viele verschwinden dann nach ihrer Freilassung
äh spurlos äh so, eine Reihe stirbt an Herzinfarkten oder stürzt aus dem Fenster, weil sie Scham nicht irgendwie ertragen oder aus anderen Gründen. So
Es gibt jede Menge Spekulation und Verschwörungstheorien des Putin noch lebt und wer wohl untergetaucht ist oder beseitigt wurde.
Auf der Rückseite des Mondes.
Ja und außerdem.
Mhm.
Mhm. Ja und äh dann die juristischen Auseinandersetzungen um den Schadenersatz äh und den eingefrorenen Teil der Zentralbankeinlagen, der wird dann nach 40 Jahren endgültig entschieden äh so.
Und äh dann wird auch der Rest der Zentralbankeinlagen freigegeben und
Ja, die russische Bevölkerung und Gesellschaft entwickelt sich halt hin so zu mehr Offenheit und Demokratie, aber so ein bisschen mehr auch Richtung
Indien oder vielleicht so irgendwo zwischen Indien und einer weltlichen Demokratie und äh eigentlich das Happy End äh gibt.
Erst dann äh wenn eben die USA und die EU und im Prinzip die weitere,
Länder, die Union of free Nations äh bilden, so im Prinzip so eine EU, nur halt.
Prinzip NATO plus Russland äh ja und bieten halt Russland dann den Beitrag an, die Ukraine ist sowieso schon drin, weil wie gesagt schon da längst äh in der EU und,
Russland tritt bei und äh ja die Grenzübergänge zwischen Russland und der Ukraine werden dann nach Beitritt zu so einer Art Schengenraum äh äh dicht gemacht
und äh ja ähm uns mit äh äh Bismarck äh dann äh zu sagen
äh äh das zu enden die Geschichte. Russland hat eine große Zukunft, seine höchsten Adligen sind intelligent und ehrenwert. Seine Bauern sind die besten Kerls in der Welt.
In der Mitte ist es faul, der Beamtenadel ist ein giftiges Geschwür, welches seine Eingeweide hinwegfrisst.
Passt jetzt. Äh ja, vielleicht nicht hundertprozentig, aber na gut.
Anliegen sind, glaube ich, jetzt auch nicht so geil, aber.
Na ja äh ja äh wobei kommt drauf an, wen man jetzt äh wirklich als höchste Adlige äh heutzutage sieht. Also da sind schon eine Menge intelligente Leute einfach auch in durchaus in Führungsposition. So ist nicht und ich
glaube, es gibt durchaus auch die eine oder andere,
ehrenwerte Person oder die sich unter den richtigen Rahmenbedingungen als ehrenwert erweisen könnte. So würde ich's mal äh äh nennen.
Aber äh ja, aber ich würde sagen, zumindest auf den auf den sozusagen der der erste Satz äh hoffe ich, dass er sich dann unter den Bedingungen wahrheitet, nämlich.
Russland hat eine große Zukunft. Ja aber äh aktuell erstmal nicht. Aber in dem in dem wie gesagt besten Szenario.
Okay, jetzt haben wir ähm.
Wir fangen an. Bis jetzt haben wir sozusagen schon mal das das Drehbuch geschrieben für für den großen Film, der so in zehn Jahren über alles äh.
Erscheinen wird. Boah, jetzt haben wir schon wieder dreieinhalb Stunden äh voll, was was denkst du, müssen wir jetzt zum Abschluss noch.
Noch äh oben drauf gießen.
Ja. Ja, wir wir haben noch ein bisschen was auf der Liste, aber so ich denke, wir sind jetzt im Endspurt halbe Stunde, Stunde maximal. Na ja, dann werden äh sehen. Aber ganz.
Keine falschen Versprechungen machen.
Nee, aber äh ich ich denke noch ein ganz wichtiger Punkt,
ist sich zu fragen, so was ist denn eigentlich am Ende Kriegsentscheidend, wie es so schön heißt, unglaublich, wie viele Metaphern so in der normalen Sprache aus dem Krieg.
Stammen, aber äh ja was ist was ist kriegsentscheidend und hm.
Am Ende äh ist es ein Kampf um die Köpfe. Und es gibt eigentlich zwei.
Ähm zwei Möglichkeiten einen Krieg zu gewinnen, so entweder.
Man nimmt dem Gegner den Willen, weiterzukämpfen.
Oder man nimmt ihm die Mittel weiter zu kämpfen. So, wobei wenn man letzteres tut, äh man ihm in der Regel auch dann den Willen genommen hat, aber ähm so das sind die, sind eben die beiden.
Dinge. So die beiden sagen Gewinn äh Konditionen äh jetzt und.
Die militärische Situation hatten wir ja vorhin schon dargelegt, dass.
Militärisch wir nicht gewinnen können oder die NATO äh nicht gewinnen kann.
Weil Atomwaffen.
Russland kann aber auch nicht gewinnen, auch nicht nur weil Atomwaffen, sondern weil äh ja USA zehn fünfmal höheres Rüstungsbudget oder zehnmal so, also.
Keine Chance am Ende des Tages hm.
Das heißt, es muss der anderen Seite jeweils dann der Willen äh äh genommen werden äh weiter.
Zu kämpfen und das geht geht halt in in beide Richtungen und hm interessanterweise kann aber die Ukraine.
Eben gewinnen gegen Russland äh die NATO aber nicht äh obwohl die NATO viel stärker ist, weil eben der Sieg in den Köpfen errungen wird und wenn die.
Kleine, schwache Ukraine äh den.
Dass Russland äh militärisch ja selbst nur Einhalt gebietet äh oder es ist dann ja sogar vertreibt,
äh so ähm wird das Russland äh einfach auch so demoralisieren, äh dass äh ja es es keine weiteren Abenteuer äh äh irgendwo unternehmen wird während,
äh einen Einsatz, der
der NATO, also wenn die NATO versucht, das jetzt zu erzwingen, dann stärkt es Putin, dann stärkt es Russland, die Moral äh dort und äh
Ja, so dass es halt halt jetzt die die Gleichung, das heißt eben der Kampf äh findet äh in den Köpfen und um
die Kämpfe äh statt und wie eben auch Bismark schon so schön äh bemerkte. Es wird niemals so viel gelogen wie vor der Wahl während des Krieges und nach der Jagd.
Und.
Ähm ja äh und Medienmanipulation eben war auch damals äh schon einen einen Thema. Also hm.
Auch so ein Bismarckzitat äh so er lügt wie gedruckt. Es wird vielleicht auch noch dahin kommen zu sagen er lügt wie telegrafiert. So,
und das geht jetzt dann noch weiter äh das Zitat und das geht aber im Prinzip darum, äh dass dass Erdogan.
Beklagt, dass äh so es Leute gibt, die halt,
Geld haben und in drei bis vier Sprachen äh übersetzte Tendenzlügen,
in verschiedene Weltstädte telegrafieren
und äh sagen, nur dabei sind Zeitungen durchzuleasen, zu gucken, handelt es sich um eine Alarmnachricht, wie er das des des des nannte damals, also
ein Aufreger und wenn's keinen gibt, dann wird da halt einer gemacht und dann eben an.
Und Telegrafiert so als aufregendes Symptom an verschiedene ausländische Blätter wie,
sagte, kommt einem irgendwie auch sehr bekannt vor äh gerade äh so, was sich im Internet äh äh tut. Also war offensichtlich auch vor 15 Jahren schon beim Aufkommen des äh äh,
Telegram äh ja äh war das eigentlich schon schon Gang und Gebe. So und mit anderen Worten.
Wenn sich da eigentlich entscheidet äh die die die Zukunft also in in den Köpfen, äh dann geht es einmal natürlich darum, dass wir unsere Köpfe.
Davor schützen, korumpiert zu werden und auf der anderen Seite,
hm die Wahrheit in die Köpfe in äh Russland hineinbekommen, so das sind sind eben diese beiden Ebenen.
Auf denen sich das Ganze abspiel.
In die Köpfe in Russland.
Ja, also mit anderen Worten, ähm dass das Problem ist ja, dass.
Russland natürlich ja gerade viel Zensur, Staatsfernsehen und ganz viele Leute hm.
Ja wundern sich gerade nur, glauben halt dem dem Staatsfernsehen und ich denke, die Wahrheit ist grade eine der schärfsten Waffen, die.
Ja der der Westen hat so. Ähm.
Auch auch wieder äh glaube ich auch einen einen,
Bismarck, den ich aber jetzt hier gar nicht stehen habe, sondern nur jetzt aus dem Kopf äh haben muss. Äh so äh äh der ist sinngemäß so, wenn du dein Feind äh wirklich,
treffen willst, so sagt die Wahrheit. Ja
und äh in insofern ist das ein Punkt und da sehe ich noch nicht, dass da allzu viel organisiert gemacht wird jetzt die Wahrheit nach äh Russland hineinzubekommen. Klar
ist es schwierig, aber wir wir sind wir sind halt gerade im Krieg. Und die andere,
ist natürlich, dass Russland jetzt genau dasselbe versucht und natürlich versucht sagen uns zu demoralisieren oder unsere Durchhaltekraft.
Zu reduzieren oder hier bei uns. Jetzt Streit äh in der in der Gesellschaft zu verursachen oder die NATO-Länder und die Welt
auseinander zu treiben und ja wie siehst du denn das? Jetzt zum Beispiel äh mit der,
Zensur und äh beziehungsweise ja als Zensurabschaltung jetzt von äh äh Russia Today,
bei bei uns, die ja jetzt diskutiert wurde und gewisse Sperrungen äh von von
Internetseiten, glaube ich, auch in Russland wiederum.
Das äh sehr problematisch, ne? Denn diese DNS-Sperren, die da äh durchgesetzt werden. Ich glaube, das machen auch nicht alle Provider äh gleich.
Ausgedacht nicht so eine totale einheitliche Befolgung, ob das eher ein Problem äh des Widerstands ist oder ob da irgendwie unklare Ansagen gemacht werden oder was weiß ich, keine Ahnung, aber ist ja jetzt auch erst mal egal.
Na ja, na ja, die Frage ist natürlich prinzipiell, ich meine, auch bei den Piraten oder auch jetzt jetzt natürlich CC äh,
so und wir waren natürlich immer für
Ja äh Gegenzensur. So gegen jede Art von Zensur und das Freie Internet äh gehört ja auch zu einer freien Gesellschaft, ja also ähm
Das ist irgendwo also Zensur ist ja erstmal etwas äh höchst problematisches, aber hm.
Ich muss sagen, in dieser Situation, in der wir uns jetzt gerade befinden, bin ich mir nicht sicher oder.
Glaube äh, dass wir ganz ohne äh auch nicht nicht wirklich auskommen. So, also ich bin von meiner.
Extrem Position abgekommen. Wie ist es dir da ergangen?
Ich bin mir noch nicht so sicher, ob ich da eine Position schon gefunden habe, aber ich sehe das Spannungsfeld, ja, weil de facto befinden wir uns ja im Krieg.
Viel Dauer diskutieren und wir haben ja jetzt hier auch schon ganz viel darüber diskutiert. Ähm
in welchem Maße wir jetzt eigentlich eingebunden sind und ab wann äh quasi unsere Beteiligung
hier äh jetzt quasi wirklich als Kriegsbeteiligung gilt und äh wer definiert das überhaupt und es ist sozusagen jetzt alles nur in den Augen von
Putin oder gilt es erst, wenn wir das selber von uns behaupten so oder so.
Handelt es sich ja hier um eine Situation, die quasi die Sicherheit, das Sicherheitsverständnis.
Und das will jetzt nicht Gefühl sagen, aber den.
Die Bewertung unserer Sicherheit nachhaltig getroffen hat und im Wesentlichen.
Sehen es alle als eine unmittelbare oder zumindest auch als eine mittelbare Bedrohung. Je nachdem, ob man jetzt vielleicht die Ukraine schon.
Uns in Anführungsstrichen dazuzählt oder nicht. Ich meine, die EU hat sich jetzt geradezu darin überschlagen
äh bekannt zu geben, wie toll man doch jetzt die Ukraine findet und wie
schnell das ja jetzt irgendwie möglich sein soll die Ukraine in die Uhr aufzunehmen wo ich mir schon so ein bisschen die Augen gerieben habe und gedacht habe so aha.
Auf einmal geht das ganz schnell, so war da nicht irgendwas mit Standards angleichen und Pipapo und der ganze Prozess und der macht ja auch Sinn.
Ist nicht auch schon die ganze Osterweiterung der EU.
Vielleicht schon Funken zu schnell gegangen so, ne, weil.
Bestimmte Dinge sich vielleicht erstmal anpassen müssen an andere passen sich vielleicht dadurch auch erst an, das ist immer so eine Abwägung, aber äh wo was ich ja nur sagen will ist,
im Prinzip ist innerhalb kürzester Zeit die Ukraine so per Akklamation Teil unseres Kulturraums geworden.
Mit uns meine ich halt jetzt so irgendwie so der Westen.
Das wurde sicherlich von manchen auch teilweise vorher schon so gesehen, aber man kann jetzt auch nicht unbedingt sagen, das ist jetzt der totale Konsens war.
Ich war auf meine eigene Bewertung schaue, da bin ich dann auch wieder bei der Aussage, die ich hier ganz am Anfang dieser kleinen Serie äh getroffen habe.
Kenne die Ukraine nicht. Ich war nicht in Russland, ich war nicht in der Ukraine und ich habe im ganzen Slawischen Raum.
Wenig Berührung gehabt bisher. Ich verstehe das nicht, verstehe die Sprache nicht, verstehe die Kultur nicht.
So ich habe auch nichts dagegen keine Negativaussage, ist nur so ich habe relativ wenig.
Erfahrung äh damit und kann von daher auch wenig darüber sagen wie es ist. Aber nichtsdestotrotz gibt's auf einmal so ein Wir-Gefühl.
Einerseits was die Ukraine betrifft, aber eben auch so ein europäisches Wir-Gefühl und man fühlt sich jetzt bedroht. Man fühlt sich jetzt angegriffen, man sieht die Gefahr unmittelbar auch in diesen.
Krieg mit äh reingezogen zu werden durch all die ganzen Szenarien, die wir jetzt hier rauf und runter schon äh mehrfach diskutiert haben oder eben am Ende auch durch.
Eigene Entscheidung, ne, die.
Roten Linien, die jetzt irgendwie neu äh gespannt werden und die wir vielleicht auch neu spannen müssen, weil wir auch festgestellt haben.
Bisherige Politik ist total gescheitert. Wir stellen jetzt einfach fest, so wir sind nicht stark genug aufgestellt, wir sprechen nicht ausgerechnet mit einer großen,
einer einheitlichen Position wir haben Putin falsch eingestellt, wir haben Russland falsch eingeschätzt, wir haben äh sowohl ein positiver als auch in negativer Hinsicht, ne, also ähm haben sie irgendwie.
Viel zu,
stark eingeschätzt, was jetzt sagen wir mal militärische Bedrohung äh angeht, aber es reicht halt für die Ukraine noch total aus. Auf der anderen Seite haben wir ihnen auch bestimmte Sachen überhaupt nicht zugetraut, die sich jetzt einfach gezeigt haben.
Das ist das Ton so und natürlich darf das irgendwie keinen Meter weitergehen und jetzt ist man eben in so einer Situation,
wo man schnell handeln muss, um Gefahr abzuwenden und das ist ja immer dieses,
Argumente Gefahrenabwehr ist ja äh im politischen Prozess, was so Sicherheitsfragen Sicherheitspolitik an sich und äh entsprechende Gesetze vor allem betrifft, immer so ein ganz schwieriges Ding, ne. So die Polizei möchte gerne alle Demonstranten
untersuchen können, weil Gefahrenverzug und möchte die Polizei in Bayern, möchte sie auch dann gerne mal 14 Tage einfach mal so einsperren. Wenn die das dafür angemessen halten.
Das Bedrohungspotential ist ja, aber der hat ja gekifft. Das ist natürlich etwas, was nicht geht.
Wiederum bewegt sich das aber auf so einem Level, wo ich sagen würde, jetzt ist es wahrscheinlich sogar geboten nicht zu viel.
Ähm wie soll ich das jetzt richtig.
Nicht zu viel drüber nachzudenken, hm? Ja was man jetzt hier für äh Grenzen äh verletzt weil die Konsequenzen daraus schlimmer sein können.
Ja es sind sind natürlich ja zwei ähm ich sage mal zwei wichtige Grundbedürfnisse so bedroht.
Wo dann plötzlich viel Aktivität äh entfaltet wird und man auch bereit wird.
Ist eine ganze Menge anderer Dinge erstmal zurückzustellen, nämlich einmal das Grundbedürfnis nicht zu sterben äh so und das äh auch das,
Bedürfnis so ähm nach Selbstbestimmung, nach einem gewissen Grad von Autonomie, so Freiheit im Grunde genommen.
Wobei ähm.
Ja ähm was mir dann auch noch einfällt auch wieder so ein schönes Bismarck äh Zitat so wäre ein ebenbürtigen Gegner überlebt wird entdecken
ihm was fehlt und ganz offensichtlich fehlte der Welt äh so ein bisschen was, nachdem jetzt die,
Der Kalte Krieg vorbei war oder uns, fehlte plötzlich ein ebenbürtiger Gegner äh irgendwo, der dann natürlich
ja zu auch Uneinigkeit und Sorglosigkeit äh geführt hat und jetzt plötzlich scheint ein ebenbürtiger Gegner
aufgetaucht oder wieder äh aus der Versenkung äh auf äh erstanden zu sein
und äh ja äh und das hat uns vielleicht auch gefehlt. So könnte man's äh vielleicht vielleicht auch ausdrücken. Wobei ich darauf
verzichten können, wie wahrscheinlich alle, aber äh ja, mein Eindruck war, äh eben immer auf wirklich wirklich.
Ganz, ganz äh lange, dass ich mir dachte, mein Gott, so hier in Deutschland sind viele Leute, aber wirklich naiv.
So was so die Weltbühne angeht oder wie es irgendwie zwischen anderen Ländern oder in anderen Ländern äh so so umgeht und
Diesem Luxus konnte man sich auch nur leisten, weil erstmal 50 Jahre lang die Alliierten äh äh
alles abgenommen haben mehr oder weniger äh Deutschland, was so außenpolitisch irgendwie wichtig oder entscheidend oder oder kontrovers war und dann.
Eben jetzt Europa, ähm ja, wo man sich dann auch äh wie wir vorhin schon hatten, sich so ein bisschen auch hinter seiner Geschichte natürlich bequem verstecken konnte, aber auch gar nicht,
so richtig außenpolitisch wiederum die Erfahrung äh hatte überhaupt alleine auf diesem Parkett jetzt rumtapsen zu können und äh auch da glaube ich ein bisschen ängstlich war. Da fehlt auch ein bisschen die außenpolitische Kompetenz.
Auch ganz real, weil wenn du das 50 Jahre nur so bedingt praktizierst oder nur in einem eng abgesteckten Feld so ähm ja.
Das ist das ist die, genau, das ist das ist da die die Situation und insofern.
Jetzt bei der Zensurfrage so habe ich mich dann auch eben immer gefragt da gibt's ja hm.
Ähm bei Zensur äh so gehen wir ja grundsätzlich davon aus,
wir können das schon ab. So, eigentlich so die also diese russische Propaganda.
Da sie da da schaue ich durch. Da da blicke ich halt äh äh drüber, das kann ich schon selber erkennen und entscheiden und.
Ich will jetzt niemanden persönlich die Fähigkeit äh dazu absprechen, aber ich.
Sehe das nicht, ich sehe das nicht, ich sehe das bei mir nicht, dass ich da unbeeinflusst bleibe. Ich meine, ich bin schließlich selber
Die letzten fünf oder zehn Jahre ähm
auf russische Propaganda ein Stück weit, wenn ich sagen, reingefallen, aber zumindest hat sie mich insoweit beeinflusst, dass ich mir immer dachte, na ja, ein gewisser Zweifel äh bleibt, war Putin weil jetzt wirklich
hinter dieser Operation hat der wirklich die Giftmörder ausgeschickt oder war das irgendjemand im Apparat, der ihnen diskreditieren wollte? Also.
So, nee, ich ich habe schon mich äh muss ich ehrlich sagen, mich von russischer.
Propaganda äh auch tatsächlich äh davon abhalten lassen äh wirklich hinzugucken oder ähm alarmiert äh zu sein. Ich bin da, bin da eingelullt worden und.
Wenn ich mir dann angucke, was ich so auf Twitter oder generell im Internet.
Abspielt oder auch teilweise in Kommentaren äh überall, so wo wirklich,
plötzlich eine Formulierung, ein Satz, manchmal die Benutzung eines Wortes auf einmal äh Reaktionen,
hervorruft, so wo äh ja ich nicht das Gefühl habe, dass die Leute ihre Emotionen im Griff haben, auch nur ansatzweise, ja, wenn die schon bei so was,
irgendwie komplett ausrasten so da also mit anderen Worten
Äh ich ich halte einen großen Teil äh der der Bevölkerung eben für absolut nicht in der Lage, sondern für Höchst anfällig, ja für alle Art von Manipulation.
So und vor dem Hintergrund, klar, äh gibt's jetzt es gibt jetzt zwei Möglichkeiten.
Wie man solchen Dingen begegnet äh.
Du kannst einerseits dich von der Information abklemmen oder andere von der Information abklemmen,
ziehe eben erst gar nicht zur Kenntnis nehmen oder äh eben eine gewisse Resilienz
aufbauen, um das zu erkennen und eben nicht an sich heranzulassen. Das braucht dann aber auch eine gewisse Coolness und Rationalität und da darf man sich dann auch nicht provozieren.
Äh lassen und nicht irgendwie einfach einfach abgehen. Ähm so
und äh insofern äh ja eine ganz ganz schwierige Frage dann dann hier äh wirklich das Maß äh zu finden und
äh nicht einfach von der von der Idealsituation auszugehen, dass dass alle Leute irgendwie hier super äh gebildet äh sind,
Ja
Und äh gut, ich hätte da jetzt auch einen äh wie gesagt gibt's auch ein passendes Bismarckzitat, aber ich glaube, wir wir haben noch genug. Wir müssen jetzt nicht überall äh äh unterbringen.
Ähm.
Herzlich willkommen bei Sags mit Otto.
Ja und ähm ein Punkt hatte mich jetzt äh äh.
Dahin gebracht, nämlich ein ein Gedankengang und ich weiß nicht, wie es dir gegangen ist, aber mir ist dann aufgefallen, hm.
Also beim Irak habe ich mich irgendwann abgewendet von dem Geschehen dort und in Afghanistan und in Libyen und auch was in Syrien.
Passiert ist. Äh so habe ich irgendwann begonnen äh zu ignorieren und auch irgendwann habe ich mal einen Blick von der Ukraine abgewendet nach dem Maidan und äh so irgendwann äh ja nach
dann zwei, drei Jahre nach der Krimbesetzung äh war das jetzt auch irgendwie kein kein Thema mehr und ähm.
Und auf der anderen Seite ähm wird's gesehen, dass in Syrien sich jetzt äh,
schrecklichste Dinge abgespielt haben, äh wo wir jetzt sehen, ja das passiert jetzt auch in der Ukraine. So Anfang von dem Söldner Einsatz dort von äh äh bis hin das.
Ja äh Russland dort ähm Syrien als,
äh äh Platz genutzt hat, um seine Truppen auszubilden, so eine General meinte wohl sogar angeblich mal
Das sei halt billiger äh die äh die die Truppen in Syrien zu trainieren als in Russland eine Militärübung zu organisieren und es wurde dann auch viel kritisiert auch von
Amerikanern findet man jetzt alles so in der in der in der Presse.
Dass äh ja sie deswegen dort unnötig äh mit unnötig viel Härte vorgegangen sind und unnötig schwere Waffen benutzt haben aus Trainingsgründen im Wesentlichen und nicht
aus äh äh Gründen äh des Einsatzes, weil das halt gerechtfertigt war. So. Aber
ja ich habe irgendwann weggeguckt. Gut, die Medien.
Haben, halt dann auch nicht mehr so vermehrt berichtet aber es war schon alles da. Also man hätte sich genug informieren äh sollen. Wie ist es dir denn so so,
ergangen äh eigentlich mit diesen ganzen Ländern. Wie hast du das empfunden.
Was ich ganz gut nachvollziehen kann ist diese Problematik, dass natürlich.
Konflikt dann auch irgendwann einem einfach einen überdosiert und man äh so ein bisschen die Hoffnung verliert, dass sich dann auch irgendwas verbessern kann. Und ich hatte das ja auch am Anfang dieser Krise, habe ich glaube ich auch erzählt.
Die ersten zwei Tage, da war ich auch mit anderen Sachen schönen Sachen beschäftigt.
War also gerade in so einer ich hänge nicht die ganze Zeit am Internet sondern hatte irgendwie Dinge vor und war unterwegs und äh so weiter und dann schlug halt so diese Nachricht ein und dachte mir halt so, oh nee Scheiße.
Weil ich ja dann auch ausgegangen bin wie glaube ich alle dass das ja nur bedeuten kann.
Unmittelbarer Niedergang und alles ist vorbei. Ja, es war so oh Gott äh bitte nicht.
Es kann nicht kann nicht sein und erst nach zwei, drei Tagen war ich in der Lage.
Mich dem Nachrichtenfluss.
Erst so richtig zu stellen. Weiß nicht ganz genau, wodurch das ausgelöst wurde,
Ob das schon so diese ersten Nachrichten von Widerstand waren, aber ich glaube, es war eher so erstmal so eine Gewöhnungsphase. Man musste sich überhaupt erstmal auf diesen diesen Schock klarkommen. Und ich glaube, das ist dann auch schon ein Schock.
Den viele dann auch gar nicht.
Umzudrehen, Wissen und sich vielleicht generell aus dieser ganzen Berichterstattung auch raushalten.
Also ganz normaler Vorgang, auch so ein bisschen zum mentalen Selbstschutz. Ähm wenn diese Krisen dann länger laufen.
Dann äh klar, Syrien war.
Auch aus dem medialen Wahrnehmung, die ich dann äh gehabt hatte, über meine Quellen.
Irgendwann dann halt auch einfach so, okay, jetzt spätestens nach dem Eintritt äh äh der Russen und dem Niedergang von Aleppo und so weiter ist halt irgendwie alles.
Zurückgeschlagen worden, was dort an an an Widerstand auch sein kann. Assad äh ist weiterhin äh der böse äh Diktator und die Situation,
einfach so fest gekrallt. Dann bricht natürlich auch diese mediale Kette äh.
Ein. Man kann dann dem gar nicht mehr auf dieselbe Art und Weise folgen. Man muss dann äh andere Quellen äh sich recherchieren. Man muss dann irgendwie gucken und man muss natürlich auch schauen, ob man selber noch in der Lage ist, diesem Flow,
standzuhalten, weil das dann eben auch einfach schlimm ist. Es ist einfach, es sind einfach einfach einfach schlimm. Es ist
ist demotiviert, es es reißt einen nieder und man man man kann das dann auch alles irgendwann nicht mehr ertragen, also ich denke, dass man einfach so ein gewisses Maximum hat, was man kompensieren kann.
Durch, weiß ich nicht, Optimismus, andere Informationslagen, äh die man hat oder vielleicht auch durch Abstumpfung.
Durch irgendetwas in seinem Leben äh zuvor.
Ich habe das ja, ich habe das sozusagen auch dann noch mal wirklich reflektiert und mir gefragt, okay, warum äh was ist was ist eigentlich in meinem Kopf
passiert und genau dasselbe wie du jetzt geschildert hast so. Ich kann auch nur ein begrenztes Maß an
Elend an mich äh ranlassen und äh Mitleid habe ich jetzt auch gelernt, ist halt im Kopf
und im Körper sowie eigenes Leid verdrahtet, so dass das führt führt zu denselben physiologischen Folgen, ja so also es ist nicht nicht irgendwas,
völlig anderes, sondern äh ja das führt halt zu denselben auch äh gesundheitlichen Problemen und deswegen schützt sich dann der Körper äh dazu, weil und wenn
gewissen Zeit so eine Menge an konstantem Leid oder Mitleid da ist oder so kommt es zu diesem
würde ich sagen, fast schönen Wort
Verzweiflung und ich bin dem mal nachgegangen wo das denn herkommt und Verzweiflung bedeutet, dass der Zweifel
verloren geht, ja? Ähm und der Zweifel ist sozusagen auch dasselbe wiederum wie die Hoffnung
umgekehrt. Also der Zweifel daran, äh äh dass es dass es so sein muss.
Also man verliert sozusagen den den Zweifel daran, dass es unbedingt so sein muss, wie es sich jetzt gerade darstellt.
Dieses gesunde äh äh Quatsch hier, die verlieren jetzt nicht irgendwie, erzählt mir keinen irgendwie, sie werden.
Mhm. Genau.
Also das ist ja ein an der Stelle was positives okay in Verzweiflung ist dann der Verlust des Zweifels.
Ja, genau. Ja, ja. Und ähm,
sagen und wie sich dann, wenn diese wenn diese Verzweiflung einsetzt oder die Hoffnung äh verloren geht, dann setzt eben Hoffnungslosigkeit ein und
hoffnungslosigkeit führt dann zur Resignation, zur Aufgabe.
Ähm und dann habe ich festgestellt, okay, es gibt eigentlich jetzt zwei verschiedene.
Äh wie man resignieren kann, weil das kennt man so ein bisschen auch so von Mitarbeitern, die nicht mehr mitziehen, die die dann in die äh Signation äh äh hineingehen und
ähm und sagen die Form AR eins der Verzweiflung äh oder der Resignation ist es einfach wegzusehen, sich Scheuklappen
aufzusetzen und äh eben einfach äh ja sagt es auch nicht mehr den Informationen hinterher zu gehen oder eben
die entsprechenden Schlagzeilen oder Links nicht anzuklicken äh ja äh wo man weiß, okay die führen da irgendwo hin, das will ich will ich gar nicht sehen, so das will ich jetzt nicht nicht sehen so. Das heißt,
man nimmt es gar nicht mehr zur Kenntnis. Es erreicht einen einfach äh nicht mehr. Das heißt, man schneidet äh sozusagen dort.
Und die zweite Form äh der Resignation ist, wenn man den Kanal zwar offen lässt.
Äh es noch reinlässt, aber nicht mehr an sich ran lässt, also seine Emotionen herunterriegelt und eben,
kühl bleibt, wenn diese Nachrichten, diese schrecklichen.
Ankommen. Das, was man dann schlicht einfach als Abstumpfung äh bezeichnen kann. Was aber eben dazu führt,
man eben nicht mehr handelt, dass man sozusagen die Kette zwischen äh eben, weil man die Emotionen runter geregelt hat äh wird das, was man sieht auch nicht mehr handlungswirksam so und dann fiel mir ein, dass man,
jetzt äh wenn man jetzt eins und zwei gleichzeitig äh sagen, auf beiden Ebenen resigniert, dass man das da doppelte Resignation nennen könnte. Ja so ähm.
Und äh das hat eben aber auch einen diese interessante Isomofie äh zu der Frage jetzt Zensur oder in dem Fall
ähm ja den Leuten.
Resistenz gegen solche Manipulationsnachrichten
ähm beizubringen. So, was aber eben auch bedeutet, dann äh Emotionen runter zu
Regeln zwangsläufig so, weil ähm allein auf rationaler Ebene äh
läuft diese diese ganze äh Manipulation ja gar nicht, äh sondern die läuft ja vor allem auf emotionaler.
Ebene so mit bestimmten Dingen, die Leute triggern und nicht irgendwie mit mit einer logischen, rationalen Argumentation, sondern mit
wenn's sein muss, frei erfundenen Dingen oder mit frei erfundenen Geschichten, von denen man aber weiß, dass diese Geschichte so an bestimmte Verhaltensmuster äh rangeht. Also
Grunde genommen, was die Nazis eben auch gemacht haben so Ausnutzung von ja, Gier oder Zweifel oder rassistischen oder
zentristischen äh Tendenzen oder von bestimmten äh ja Persönlichkeitsstörungen, wo man dann eben weiß, wie man solche Leute dann,
erreicht, ja und sozusagen die die Zensur wäre quasi jetzt,
das äh wegfiltern der der Information und das andere eben letztlich runterregeln von Emotionen.
Wobei nicht nur, sondern man dann natürlich auch gucken kann, wie man an die Glaubwürdigkeit äh oder so
äh betrachtet, aber selbst das, ja, selbst wenn man jetzt, ich sage mal, zu 90 Prozent sicher ist, äh dass irgendwas falsch ist, diese zehn Prozent nagen halt trotzdem an
einem ja so aber.
Kennst du wahrscheinlich auch, gibt's so ein Umfeld des Caos Computer Clubs gibt's so einen schönen Aufkleber, den man immer wieder äh sieht, der glaube ich auch an der Clubtür hängt. Alles zweifelhafte muss angezweifelt werden.
Hm
Was der Ursprung dieses Spruchs ist, aber.
Aber wie wir wie wir sehen ist sozusagen der Zweifel das Gegenteil von Verzweiflung, ja? So oder,
O2 eben als Ende des Zweifels so, also ist Zweifel äh schon eher äh was Positives, aber sagt in dem in dem Fall.
Äh ja denke ich, wir müssen also als erstes nicht verzweifeln, so dass es jetzt oberstes Bürgerrecht nicht verzweifeln.
Wollte ich damit ja auch unterstreichen. Also ich meine äh das das Zweifelhafte muss angezweifelt werden, heißt ja auch, man muss sozusagen den Kopf oben behalten.
Äh sich sozusagen seinen kritischen Geist äh
beibehalten und dann leider muss man aber wahrscheinlich auch in dieser ganzen Situation, dass es Teil der psychischen Belastung einfach auch widersprüchliches jetzt mal,
verkraften. Also es wird nicht alle Antworten sofort äh geben. Und dieses Beispiel will sich nochmal kurz aufgreifen, um da den die Klammer auch zu schließen.
Mit diesem RT ähm abschalten, Zensur, Zugangsbeschränkung, ja? Das ist eine eine Abwehrhaltung, die ähm.
Aus der Situation heraus rational wirkt.
Ja, da gibt es irgendwie eine Kraft, von der wir wissen, dass sie einfach lügt und betrügt und und diesen diesen Krieg das Wort redet.
Und man will das nicht haben. Das einzige, was uns in der aktuellen Situation.
Ermächtigt, das wegzuhaben ist eine Maßnahme, von der man weiß.
Dass wir sie so eigentlich auch nicht als Werkzeug haben wollen, weil sie eben auch missbraucht werden können. Nur.
Glauben wir, ich in diesem Moment, wir beide, was weiß ich, vielleicht die meisten Leute, die Politiker, dass das äh sozusagen derzeit einfach angemessen.
Ist, dass das sozusagen das kleinere äh Übel ist, dass es hier auch nicht,
hundert Prozent konsequentes, richtiges Verhalten geben kann, weil wir uns sozusagen in einer echten Notsituation.
Befinden und das das das werden wir wahrscheinlich auch noch mit mit vielen anderen Dingen sehen, dass wir einfach in diesen permanenten Konflikt bleiben,
werden und das ist halt einfach unangenehm, weil einfach die gesamte Situation unangenehm ist und wir uns es nur
zugutehalten, dass wir zumindest jetzt noch davon überzeugt sind, dass wir das dann eben zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt auch wieder aussortiert bekommen. Fehler werden gemacht werden.
Und äh da gibt's überhaupt gar keine Alternative zu der Zeit.
Und man muss sich da auch darüber klar sein, dass das ein Zeichen unserer Schwäche.
Ist. Äh ja, dass es keine keine Handlung aus einer Position der Stärke heraus ist, äh sondern dass es einen Rückschritt ist, dass es eine.
Maßnahme ist so äh die von der man hoffen würde, dass sie halt nicht nicht notwendig äh sein müsste, aber äh und auch.
Legt es halt ganz klar auch glaube ich offen, dass äh ja äh man dem Volk auch nicht wirklich vertrauen.
Kann und ähm ja das ist und das ist jetzt glaube ich keine keine Paranoia, sondern das konnten wir jetzt auch auch sehen, was sich was da an Geschichten ja rumgegangen
äh es an an äh wirklich Verschwörungs äh Geschichten und und an absolutem Unsinn.
Jetzt in in Zeiten oder was in den USA zur Wahl los war.
Daran sind wir verzweifelt. Da haben wir den, da haben wir den Zweifel, dass das irgendwie okay sein kann, den haben wir verloren.
Ja, ja, ja. Aber also ja, nicht verzweifeln, Hoffnung aufrechterhalten.
Aber ich denke nicht provozieren lassen. Es ist auch das Wichtige immer im Kopf zu behalten. Äh trotzdem äh ja auch auch kühl zu bleiben, weil wir werden Provokation sehen,
Putin wird versuchen uns äh rein reinzuziehen äh die NATO reinzuziehen in die in die Ukraine, um eben dann äh sagen können.
Kann man nicht oft genug betonen äh wenn wir da reingehen so spielen wir Putin in die Hände, dann kann er sagen sieht ihr äh ich hab's euch immer gesagt äh die.
NATO,
NATO-Nazis äh marschieren jetzt auf Moskau zu und haben jetzt die Ukraine sind jetzt in der Ukraine und deswegen müssen wir Generalmobil machen und ich hatte Recht und
und so und dann bröckelt's äh alles. Also da müssen wir halt höllisch äh äh einfach vorsichtig sein und aber eben ja auch die.
Die Wahrheit äh dann äh in die russische Bevölkerung äh irgendwie hineintragen. Keine Ahnung, wie man das auf
äh sinnvolle Weise machen kann, aber äh ich denke, das ist auf jeden Fall wichtig und das können, glaube ich, auch viele noch, weil das Internet ist nicht völlig,
geschlossen und ich glaube, da findet eine ganze Menge Informationen und.
Ja, Telegram läuft und so weiter. Ja, aber wir müssen auch noch, um das noch zu ergänzen, wir werden auch noch sehr leiden müssen.
Weil wir diesen.
Dissenz im Kopf. Nicht ausgeräumt bekommen. Auf der einen Seite so einen ethoisch moralische Verpflichtung zur Hilfe zu verspüren, aber trotzdem immer wieder jetzt äh das Gefühl haben, werden nicht genug,
getan zu haben. Nicht das Richtige zu tun, nicht genug
getan zu haben. Oh Gott, ich habe jetzt die Heizung noch mal um zwei Grad äh hochgedreht. Äh ich habe nicht genug gespendet. Äh sollten wir nicht doch irgendwie äh
militärisch Konvois absichern äh und so weiter. Also jede Nachricht von ähm Häuserzerstörung, Entführung, Massentötung, äh.
Viele viele Nachrichten werden noch auf uns einschlagen, die uns äh zerreißen werden und die die auch die ganze Debatte zerreißen werden.
Ja und deswegen auch in unserer, wie gesagt, in der einen äh äh Geschichte sozusagen, wie es für Putin
am besten äh äh laufen kann äh und wie gesagt, das hat er möglicherweise in der Hand, auch die NATO schlichtweg in die Ukraine hineinzuziehen durch
die Dinge, dass es wirklich dann einfach zu dem Punkt kommt, wo ja äh NATO einfach
wo wir äh sagen müssen, wir wir können äh wir können dem nicht nicht länger äh zusehen.
Wie es wie es da gerade läuft so ja aber das Ganze hat natürlich nach seine.
Auch noch seine andere äh Seite, weil äh die Ukraine hat das jetzt in der Hand äh wirklich ähm Putin und äh Russland so zu demoralisieren und äh,
wirklich das Ganze zu gewinnen, aber ähm quasi wir müssen
Wir müssen als NATO jetzt keine Angst vor den Russen haben, aber
vor der Weltöffentlichkeit und der Reaktion des des russischen Volkes und das sind
das sind so die die zwei Dinge nicht vor dem russischen Militär oder so, die und äh sagen eigentlich nicht das und
auch nicht davor, dass das Putin jetzt irgendwie,
uns angreifen könnte und auch atomar angreifen könnte und so, dass das äh denke ich, ist nicht ist nicht der der Punkt.
Ähm aber ansonsten ja äh glaube ich.
Müssen wir auch die Gradwanderung äh jetzt gehen, so wie Putin auch die Gradwanderung äh geht, nur dürfen wir nicht irgendwie.
Jetzt zu weit reingehen oder reinfallen in die Ukraine und Putin
darf jetzt nicht so weit ähm die NATO reizen, dass äh ja es zum Schießen kommt und irgendwo dazwischen äh spielt sich das das das Ganze ab.
Ja und wenn wir Pech haben aber müssen wir rein und äh dann kommt's halt zu der zu dem geteilten Ukraineszenario. Äh.
Vorsicht, ne? Wir sind jetzt wirklich am Ende und jetzt müssen wir nicht wieder diesen positiven Ausklang äh gefährden.
Na ja wir äh okay äh und äh ich ich glaube ja also äh Bismarck äh äh jetzt äh wir haben,
das mag glaube ich begonnen und äh hören dann ähm ruhig auch mit Bismarck auf, weil er einfach auf einem wirklich schönen, optimistischen Ausblick.
Und zwar hat er eben auch gesagt ein Gedanke der richtig ist kann auf die Dauer nicht niedergelogen werden und.
Lügen können Kriege in Bewegung setzen, Wahrheit hingegen kann ganze Armeen aufhalten.
Und äh ja ich glaube.
Mir gibt es äh zumindest Hoffnung, dass da an beiden was Fahreres dran ist und äh dass sich die Wahrheit dann durchsetzt.
Und äh ganze Armeen aufhalten wird so. Das ist irgendwie meine Hoffnung. Ja.
Super, super Ende. Dann würde ich sagen, bringen wir's auch zu Ende, Pavel, das war jetzt äh ein ausführlicher Diskurs und ich hoffe fast wir müssen nicht nochmal so ein Riesenupdate liefern, aber das sagen wir dann immer.
Und versprechen mal wieder gar nichts. Außer, dass wir mit dem Thema natürlich noch nicht durch sind, weil auch diese Krise muss begleitet werden und äh.
Nicht so lang wie die letzte.
Leute, äh wer auch immer jetzt bis zum Ende durchgehört hat, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und ähm wir hören uns bald wieder.